bin äußerst pünktlich heute sehe ich gerade fast exakt 9 uhr aber ich bin
ziemlich bett modus habe ich schon habe ich schon gerade jojo 27 20 monate
subscription das ist äußerst
und äußerst fett heute ich muss euch was erzählen ich hatte letzte woche auf der neuen arbeit den
ersten richtigen moment wo ich was gelöst habe was was schon monate gibt an fehler und bis jetzt
noch keiner drauf gekommen ist es kommt nicht so ist jetzt nicht so dass das regelmäßig jetzt eine
woche mal vorkommt so was aber ab und zu und dann freue ich mich immer wenn ich
irgendwie so was sich ergibt ja und zwar weil es erzähle ich euch erzählt euch gleich ein bisschen
mehr leute da sind weil vielleicht hat der eine oder andere auch das problem könnte ich mir
durchaus vorstellen dass wahrscheinlich ein bisschen verbreiteter ich bringe euch das ja
was also schon mal gefragt habe warum ist das so langsam dann erkläre ich euch das jetzt
muss gerade mal was schauen
ihr euch mal in den hopes
schreibt
hoffe auch mit
ja
da
das ist mir
ja
Twitch übertreibt es total.
Ich wollte gestern einen Stream gucken.
Und da gab es tatsächlich neun.
Ich wiederhole, neun Werbeblöcke.
Oder Werbespots.
Neun Stück.
Und ich habe das so nebenbei laufen gehabt.
Und habe mir gedacht, das ist aber irgendwann auch mal gut mit Werbung.
Und da steht da oben dann, fünf von neun Werbespots wären jetzt durch.
Und dann habe ich instant einfach den Tap zugemacht.
Und ich mir gedacht habe, nee.
Also, jetzt irgendwann fünf von neun.
Neun Werbespots.
Das ist doch nicht mehr normal.
Okay, das können natürlich die Streamer beeinflussen, wenn sie auf Werbung klicken.
Oder man kann ja irgendwie sagen, ich mache jetzt Pause mal irgendwie zehn Minuten.
Aber ganz im Ernst, nee, nee.
Also so ein Scheiß.
Es ist auch blöd, dass man es nicht ausschaltet.
Also ich würde es ausschalten.
Ich verdiene mit der Werbung eh so gut wie nichts, dass ich das lohnen würde.
Aber Twitch verdient da dran.
Also insofern wollen die wahrscheinlich nicht, dass man das deaktiviert.
Aber das ist total übertrieben.
Und nachdem es ja ein ziemlich enges Wettrennen mittlerweile geworden ist aus Twitch.
Und Adblockern.
Dass Adblocker, sagen wir mal, mindestens 50% der Zeit, so wenn man es so ein Jahr sieht, nicht in der Lage sind, Twitch-Ads zu blocken.
Außer mit Custom-Adblockern und Regeln und allem.
Fühlt sich auch immer nerviger.
Wegen mehr im Sommer.
Weiß nicht.
Warte, ich muss mal ein bisschen irgendwas an.
Was haben wir denn hier noch so?
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Bisschen, bisschen wupp, wupp, wupp.
Okay.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Ne, die müssen sich auch nicht.
Und ich hab...
Ihr werdet mich jetzt wahrscheinlich für bescheuert halten, warum ich das überhaupt mache.
Aber ich war letztens auf gutefrage.de über die Seite.
Ist ja jeder schon mal gestolpert und hat sich gefragt, was die Daseinsberechtigung überhaupt ist von dieser Seite.
Also ich verstehe, wie gesagt, das ist so eine Art Stack-Overflow für alle Themen im deutschsprachigen Bereich.
Nur, dass die Antworten halt absolut bescheuert...
Bescheuert sind oftmals, ja.
So, zumindest, ich hab, ich hab gegoogelt.
Und zwar, wisst ihr, was ich gegoogelt hab?
Ich wollte für meine Mutter auf dem Tablet einrichten, dass die sich mit der neuen...
Weiß gar nicht, welche...
ING-DiBa war das, glaube ich.
App.
Verbinden kann.
So, und die App ist so dermaßen beschissen gemacht, dass du nicht weißt, welche deiner Codes, Pins, Passwörter, Usernamen, Kontonummer, Deponummer und was auch immer es da nicht alles gibt.
Beim Login eingeben sollst.
So, und dann hab ich gegoogelt danach, was der Unterschied ist zwischen den unterschiedlichen Nummern, und das erste, was rausgekommen ist, ist eine Frage, also ist gutefrage.de oder gutefrage.net oder so ist es ja, glaube ich, als, als Antwort, so nach dem Motto, die, die wissen, die wissen, was Sache ist, ja.
Das Problem ist nur, die wussten es halt auch nicht.
Und die Seite, das, warum ich jetzt überhaupt drauf komme, ähm, die Seite.
Die Seite war komplett, die konntest du nicht sehen, die war komplett zu mit Werbung auf dem Tablet.
Es war links ein Werbebanner, und rechts war in der Mitte über die Seite noch ein Werbebanner.
Es war quasi so ein, so ein T-Werbebanner hier, so, und dann so ein Werbebanner.
Du konntest die Seite einfach gar nicht angucken.
Dann hab ich's auch gleich wieder zugemacht, wo ich mir so gedacht hab, jetzt ist ja auch mal gut.
Ich mein, will man wirklich so viel Werbung haben, dass die Leute die Seite nicht mehr sehen, weil dann gucken sie sich nicht die Werbe und nicht die Seite an und machen direkt wieder zu.
Ja, die sind alle toll, also, du kannst das Internet mittlerweile, es wird, es, es ist fast wieder so schlimm wie, sagen wir mal,
90, 90er, 2000 rum, wo alles auch voll mit Werbebannern war und teilweise noch mit Werbebannern,
die irgendwelche Sachen ausführen konnten in deinem Browser auf der Webseite, ganz, ganz wirres Zeug, wie das damals eingebunden wurde.
Und die Browser waren da damals auch noch bei weitem nicht so secure wie heute.
Es ist fast wieder so schlimm zu der Zeit, wo, wo die Werbe, wo die ganzen Werbeblocke überhaupt erstmal ursprünglich aufgekommen sind.
Du konntest ja damals,
das Internet auch gar nicht benutzen ohne Werbeblocker und es ist quasi konstant so geblieben, ein bisschen runtergegangen, vielleicht die letzten Jahre.
Aber insgesamt
ist das Internet wieder fast unbenutzbar ohne Werbeblocker.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die gehen mir wirklich auf den Keks im Internet.
Ähm, das sind, also, online, sagen wir mal, nicht, nicht nur im Internet, aber generell online,
gehen mir die auf den Keks, also, da ist die Werbung, also, diese ultra aufdringliche, wir erkennen von der Seite nix Werbung,
ist, ist da nur eins davon.
Ja, der, der Zwang dazu, bei jedem Scheiß, sich irgendwie einen Account anlegen zu müssen, ist auf jeden Fall auch einer.
Cookie-Meldung, DSGVO-Meldung, das nächste.
Gibt noch ein paar Sachen.
Wenn ich ja länger, länger drüber nachdenken würde, fallen mir bestimmt 20 Dinge ein, die mir echt auf den Keks gehen.
So, so in der heutigen Internetzeit.
Ja, aber das bringt ja bei vielen Contents, ach so, ja, und eine Sache, die mir auch extrem noch auf den Keks geht, ist,
immer noch, und wir, wir reden vom Jahr 2023, dass Filme, Serien und, sagen wir mal, generell Medien und Content,
immer noch Region-Log, nee, Region-Log ist das falsche Wort, immer noch Region-Based irgendwie released werden.
Das fuckt mich so ab.
Es gibt Dinger, die will man sich angucken und stellt dann fest, oh, der Release war ja nur Amerika,
wir müssen noch zwei Monate warten.
Und dann gehst du auf irgendeine Seite und willst dir das Ganze anschauen.
Und dann kommt dann, ach nee, sie befinden sich außerhalb von Amerika, sie können das jetzt noch nicht gucken.
Muss halt ein VPN oder sowas.
Warum, was soll dieser ganze Müll immer?
Man kann es doch eh relativ einfach umgehen.
Was soll der ganze Müll überhaupt?
Warum ist das noch ein Ding?
Und warum gibt es, und warum gibt es in Deutschland immer noch Word-Releases ohne Original-Tonspur?
Also was ich ganz gerne mache, ist zum Beispiel, wenn die, wenn das irgendwelche Sachen sind, wo sie,
wenn das irgendwas aus England ist.
Teilweise so abgedrehte, da gibt es ja ganz viele Dialekte, ja.
Nur wenn da irgendwelche Schotten ankommen und, und, und, verstehst ja kaum, wenn die Englisch reden.
Und dann mache ich manchmal ganz gerne halt Original-Tonspur, aber deutsche Untertitel,
weil ich einfach absolut keine Ahnung habe, was sie verstehen, äh, was sie sagen und es nicht verstehe.
Und, und ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass das sogar manchen Native-Speakers okay, dass sie die Kerle nicht verstehen.
Ja, und es ist halt blöd, wenn das nicht geht.
Also man, du kannst dann oftmals in Deutsch gucken, aber ich gucke es halt am liebsten in,
im Original-Tonspur und manchmal mit deutschen Untertiteln.
Das ist für mich so ein, so eine gute Kombination, wenn da ganz zu viel abgedrehte Dialekte drinne sind.
Aber, tja.
Geht halt oftmals nicht, weil Wortseiten zacken.
Ja.
Ja, ähm, übrigens, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was auch so eine, so eine schlimme Sache ist,
oder eine Sache, die mir auch auf den Keks geht im Internet?
Ja, hier, wir haben ein ganz tolles Angebot.
Bestell dir das doch jetzt.
Und du willst es dir angucken und denkst, ja, okay, ist doch eigentlich gar nicht so übel.
Und du suchst als den Preis und du findest den Preis nicht.
Und dann denkst du dir so, ah gut, klickst du das mal an, als willst du es bestellen.
Und bevor du den Preis siehst, sollst du einen Account anlegen.
Mach ich nie.
Das ist, das ist der Moment, wo mein Bestell, mein eventuell stattfinden könnender Bestellprozess
abrupt interrupted wird, weil ich mir keinen Account anstelle,
nur um zu sehen, was ich theoretisch bezahlen müsste.
Die sollen das halt ordentlich hinschreiben, was das kosten würde.
Und dann überlege ich mir auch, ob ich das haben will, wenn ich das haben will.
Und unbedingt einen Account brauche, vielleicht mache ich mir dann einen Account.
Aber umgedreht ist einfach ätzend.
Ja, ich kenne auch eine Wortseite, die nicht sagt.
Aber die ist ja leider nicht monetarisiert.
Sollten wir uns vielleicht auch mal überlegen.
Direkt, direkt fünf Werbebanner.
Nicht mal unbedingt, es gibt viele seriöse Shops, die das so machen.
Aber ich werde das dann nicht bestellen.
Ja, oder wenn du quasi schon den Versand...
Und den Bestellprozess nahezu abschließen musst, dass du den Versand ziehst, oder das teilweise wir.
Aber wenn man sich erstmal anmelden muss, um überhaupt den Preis zu sehen.
Und ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Shops, so nach dem Motto,
only for businesses, wo du dich erstmal mit Umsatz, Steuer, ID und allem möglichen Zeug registrierst.
Das meine ich gar nicht, ganz normale Shops.
Letztes Mal, Beispiel zum Beispiel, ja.
Letztes Mal habe ich irgendwie so eine Werbung bekommen.
Das war so sinngemäß, so hier verschönern sie ihre Wohnung.
Mit regelmäßigen Blumenlieferungen.
Leute, ich hätte nicht wirklich vor, das abzuschließen.
Aber ich wollte mir das mal angucken.
Ich habe mir gedacht, okay, ich meine, mal gucken, was ihr anzubieten habt, ja.
Habe ich draufgeklickt und da stand dann, ja, kaufen sie sich das jetzt und kriegen sie regelmäßig passend für das Ambiente und bla, kriegen sie irgendwie passend Blumen und so.
Also okay, dann zeig doch mal, was das kosten würde.
Ich wollte einfach nur mal wissen, was kostet das.
Habe ich draufgeklickt und dann erzählen sie,
oh, sie sparen jetzt 30 Prozent, wenn sie das jetzt abschließen und ah, das ist ganz toll und bei der ersten Bestellung gibt es noch eine kostenlose Vase dazu und bla, bla, bla, bla.
Und ich denke mir also, ich scroll die Seite durch, ich scroll die Seite durch und denke mir so, ja, und was, was kostet denn jetzt?
Einmal im Monat oder einmal im Jahr oder einmal irgendwann, was, was kostet denn jetzt?
Und ich scroll durch, es steht nirgendwo, steht nirgendwo, was das kostet.
Dachte ich mir, okay, weißt du was, ich tue einfach mal so, als will ich es bestellen.
Habe gesagt, ja, okay, ich will das hier einmal im Monat, so und so viel, so, keine Vase, next, next.
Und dann?
Dachte ich mir, es zeigt mir den Preis, aber nein, dann sollte ich erst mal einen Account anlegen.
Und ich meine, ich hatte eh schon nicht vor, mir das zu kaufen, aber spätestens an der Stelle war einfach harter Cut in meinem Bestellsprozess.
Ich habe direkt den Tab geclosed und werde den Shop wahrscheinlich auch nie wieder benutzen.
Was soll der Scheiß?
Warum könnt ihr mir nicht den fucking Preis anzeigen, ohne dass ich mich registrieren muss?
Vielleicht ist der Preis so krass, dass es eh keiner kaufen würde.
Aber das ist trotzdem nicht die beste Idee, das hinter einem Account zu machen.
Warum ist der Preis hinter einem Account zu machen?
Das ist einfach bescheuert.
Ich würde gar nicht mal so sagen, dass es, ja doch, also, wenn du das in der Summe anguckst, prozentual vielleicht, aber es gibt auch viel, viel mehr Zeug mittlerweile.
Ja, du hast ja neben so Sachen, die es früher gar nicht gab, früher hattest du ja so Sachen wie Twitch, YouTube und, fällt schwer zu sagen, so was wie TikTok und sowas, hattest du alles nicht.
Aber selbst wenn man so die klassischen Filme, Serien und sowas, Produktion nimmt, es gibt ja mittlerweile so viele.
Ja, wie nennt man das, Studios und Sachen, die Zeug produzieren oder so viele Unternehmen, die Sachen in Auftrag geben.
Jeder Streaming, jeder, jeder Hersteller hat eine eigene Streaming-Seite.
Jede Streaming-Seite ist der Meinung, wir brauchen ein paar exklusive Sachen und da ist auch viel Shit dabei, aber doch durchaus das eine oder andere Gute.
Also es gibt sehr viel und ich muss auch sagen, es ist sehr viel, sehr viel Müll, aber es gibt auch die ein oder andere guten Sachen.
Was mich ja persönlich immer so ein bisschen nervt ist.
Gerade, gerade wenn du dir irgendwie Serien anguckst und du fandest die erste Staffel ganz gut und die nächste ist halt so richtig mies.
Wo du so denkst, okay, ihr habt, ihr habt euch überhaupt keine Gedanken gemacht beim Erstellen der ersten Staffel, so nach dem Motto, wir können es weitergehen.
Das war überhaupt nicht im Scope.
Da gibt es, da gibt es einige Dinge oder auch, wo ich so im Laufe, Laufe der Serie denke, irgendwie ja so, pff.
Also ich habe, ich glaube, ich habe mehr Serien aufgehört zu gucken in der Mitte, als ich sie zuerst gesehen habe.
Also ich glaube, ich habe mehr Serien aufgehört zu gucken in der Mitte, als ich sie zuerst gesehen habe.
Wenn man, wenn man davon ausgeht, also zu Ende, also soweit sie guckbar waren, nicht wirklich zu Ende, viele werden ja auch eingestellt, aber gehen wir mal von aus, keine Ahnung, ich gucke irgendwas, es gibt schon drei Staffeln und es ist, es ist öfters passiert, dass ich irgendwie so Ende zweiter Staffel dann gedacht habe, boah, so langsam wird es aber dumm, als dass ich dann noch das letzte geguckt hätte oder so.
Also ich, ich gucke das meiste gar nicht fertig.
Deswegen mag ich auch Serien, die so nach einer Staffel halbwegs abgeschlossen sind.
Ja, also das, oder, äh, ja, das ist ein ganz, ganz, irgendwie, wenn es so einen ordentlichen Schlussstrich gibt.
Aber gut, ohne Cliffhanger gucken die Leute dann halt wahrscheinlich einfach nicht die nächste Season.
Ja, das ist im Enter, hast du recht, das ist im Enterprise, aber die wissen warum, die, die wissen, die wissen warum, weil, weil die Software aussieht wie von 1998 wahrscheinlich.
Das habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt, weiß gar nicht, ob ich das, ob ich das jemals mache.
Witcher ist auch so ein Beispiel.
Ich fand die erste Season auch nur, naja, aber ich hatte dann beispielsweise gar keinen Bock mehr weiterzugucken danach.
Naja.
Shopify, ist, ist, war Shopify nicht von irgendeinem Deutschen, der das entwickelt hat?
Also natürlich nicht in Deutschland, sondern irgendwo in den USA, aber ich glaube, das war irgendein deutscher Auswanderer oder so, der die, der Shopify entwickelt hat.
Ja.
Unterm Strich muss man aber sagen, ist das tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine gute Entwicklung gewesen, weil es gibt ja nicht nur Shopify, es gibt ja noch mehr solcher, solcher, wie nennt man das so, Sales, Sales, Customize, so quasi WordPress für Shops im Endeffekt.
Eigentlich eine ganz gute Entwicklung, weil früher war es wirklich nicht einfach, wenn jetzt irgendwie so eine, ich, ich kann euch mal eine Story erzählen.
Ich habe früher mal, das ist schon wirklich lange her, das müsste, keine Ahnung, 2000 oder so, wie alt war ich in 2016?
Ja.
Ja, das kommt, ich war noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen älter, 99, 2000 rum, so müsste das gewesen sein.
Da habe ich ein bisschen Webshops gebastelt, allerdings nur ein bisschen, ein bisschen das Styling und so drumherum.
Das war damals eine Software, die nannte sich Smart Store, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
So, und das war ein Shop Generator.
Du hast quasi deine Produkte reingeschrieben und dann hast du generieren gedrückt.
Ne, das meine ich gar nicht, Classic, ist das noch, ist das nicht Smart Store?
Ach, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Krempel hieß.
Zumindest hast du da deine Sachen eingetragen und dann hast du auf generieren gedrückt und das hat dir ein Verzeichnis rausgeworfen mit HTML, CSS und du hattest dann quasi einen statischen Shop, den konntest du hochladen auf irgendeinen Hoster oder einen halbweg statischen Shop.
Das war damals eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Die war in ihrer Zeit voraus, aus Aesthetics, Site Generation und so kam 20 Jahre später wieder als Riesentrend.
War aber eine gute Sache, weil du konntest es auf jeder Seite hosten, auf jedem Webspace hosten, du hast keine MySQL-Datenbank oder irgendeine Datenbank gebraucht.
Und, wobei bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob du die gebraucht hast.
Es war eine ganz coole Sache.
Und ich habe damals ein bisschen Styling und CSS, ein bisschen JavaScript-Zeug gemacht für so Shop-Seiten.
Und was damals halt...
Echt ein Riesenakt war, für kleinere Shops sowas zu erstellen.
Ich kann das...
Genau, jetzt weiß ich auch, was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte.
Ich habe damals für irgendeine Esoterik, so mit Heilstein und sowas...
Ich zeige euch jetzt nicht.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob es die Seite noch gibt.
Gucken, ob es das noch gibt.
Ne, gibt es nicht mehr.
So, und das war so ein Esoterik-Shop, für den ich ein bisschen Design oder beziehungsweise ein bisschen...
Setup von dem Shop gemacht habe.
Und die haben Anhänger verkauft und Heilsteine und so komischen Kram.
Und wie gesagt, da war ich so 15, 16 irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Und das habe ich dann, keine Ahnung, 50, 50 Euro oder so ab und zu gekriegt.
Ich meine, das fand ich damals halt schon extrem, extrem pock.
Ansonsten habe ich eh nur auf 24, 7 MMO Kreiselgrind gemacht.
So, zumindest...
Ich weiß noch, wie schwierig für die das damals gewesen ist.
Einen Shop online zu stellen.
Und damals waren gesetzliche Regelungen wahrscheinlich noch einfacher zu durchschauen.
Und für solche, gerade für solche kleinen Dinger, sind natürlich so WordPress-Style-Shops,
also quasi WordPress nur für Shops, eigentlich ganz gut.
Da musst du dich nicht um Bezahlung kümmern.
Du musst dich nicht um das Setup großartig kümmern.
Du musst eigentlich nur dein Zeug reinschreiben, ein bisschen customizen und gut ist.
Für kleine Shops ist das, glaube ich, wirklich extrem nice.
Das sind so Sachen wie Shopify und wie heißt der andere Krempel?
Das ist das...
Wie gesagt, ab und zu mal 50 Euro oder so war das.
Das war nicht, dass ich da reich geworden bin.
Aber es war für damals, so mit 15, 16, war das schon sehr nice.
Immer mal ein bisschen Money zu kriegen.
Ja.
Denke ich auch.
Ich hatte jetzt persönlich...
Also, ich habe da noch nicht selbst drüber verkauft oder was gemacht.
Aber alles, was ich bisher gesehen habe...
Wie heißt denn dieser andere?
Versus Shopware.
Genau, das meine ich.
Gibt es auch noch.
Da gibt es einige.
Nee, aber Shopware meinte ich.
Das ist teilweise...
Squarespace?
Das kenne ich.
Das sind die, die immer die T-Shirts verkaufen.
Wix.
E-Besser-Web-Hoster vom Namen her.
Die gibt es ja auch schon lange.
Und mittlerweile haben sie, glaube ich, diese Namen auch.
Gerade im deutschsprachigen Umfeld machen sie sich ja da auch selbst lustig drüber.
Moin, Max.
Und hast du gefunden, wie man Stop Words macht?
Ja, jetzt sind ja genug Leute.
Jetzt kann ich euch mal was erzählen.
Und zwar, ich hatte letzte Woche auf der Arbeit...
Ihr müsst keine Channel-Punkte raushauen.
Ich habe gerade schon was gedrungen.
Echt nicht? Okay.
Aber weißt du, was wir machen können?
Wir können das einfach...
Oder was heißt wir?
Jetzt hört es sich ja so an, als könnte ich da was machen.
Kleinzeitig einfach erstmal rausfiltern, wenn das jemand ins Suchfeld eingibt oder sowas.
Irgendwas Billiges, das reicht ja erstmal schon.
So.
Ich wollte euch irgendwas erzählen.
Genau.
Und zwar...
Ich hatte letzte Woche auf der Arbeit...
Vielleicht könnt ihr mir vorstellen, dass der eine oder andere von euch genau diesen Fehler schon hat.
Deswegen erzähle ich euch das mal.
Ich hatte letzte Woche auf der Arbeit so meinen ersten richtigen Five-Header-Moment.
Und zwar ging es um ein Problem, was es schon Monate gibt.
Und es hat bisher noch keiner den Fehler rausgefunden.
Das ist ja normal in einem größeren Umfeld, dass es da immer Probleme gibt.
Und auch viele Probleme Monate, Jahre bestehen bleiben.
Nee, habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Habe ich noch nie.
Ich habe noch nie Wix.com benutzt.
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es das eigentlich auch mit DE mittlerweile?
Nee.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Irgendwas anderes, was damit nichts zu tun hat.
Null.
Ich sollte mich einfach mal sponsoren.
Dann mache ich auch in irgendeinem Stream eine Wix-Webseite.
Aber nur, wenn ich gesponsert werde.
Ich sehe den Sinn von solchen Webseitenbildern für mich.
Für meine Anwender.
Für meine Verbindungszwecke nicht.
Zumindest kann ich euch erzählen, was ich euch erzählen wollte.
Also.
Erster Five-Head-Moment.
Und zwar, wir hatten ein Problem auf der Arbeit.
Und zwar, wenn man Kubernetes-Cluster administriert, dann verwendet man ja meistens das Tool kubectl,
wo manche Leute, wo ich immer, wo ich immer so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Pains champen
muss, wenn manche Leute nicht kubectl sagen oder kubectl, sondern kubectl.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, wo das herkommt.
Das machen erstaunlich viele.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es absichtlich ist.
Oder.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Doch.
Das machen ziemlich viele.
So kann man sogar.
Guck mal, sogar Google.
Sogar Google verauto-vervollständigt das.
Gibt sogar GitHub-Projekte.
Ja, da sprechen viele Leute so aus.
Zumindest.
Das ist überhaupt nicht, das ist überhaupt nicht das, worum es gehen soll.
Also.
Und zwar, wir hatten das Problem, dass immer, wenn du kubectl ausgeführt hast, dass es
unregelmäßig hing.
Das hing immer unregelmäßig in ein paar Minuten.
Weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch schon mal das Problem hatte.
Google Cloud, Google Cloud, GKE-Cluster, kubectl ausgeführt in unregelmäßigen Abständen.
Zumindest dachten wir das.
In unregelmäßigen Abständen hing das immer für ein paar Minuten.
Ja.
Also, falls ihr auch das Problem habt, erzähle ich euch jetzt, woran das liegt.
Und da ist, wir haben sogar intern, das war noch, bevor ich angefangen habe.
Und ich habe schon zweieinhalb Monate, bin ich jetzt schon da.
Gab es da schon, schon ein paar Monate alt, sogar ein Google Support-Ticket von uns.
Natürlich, selbstverständlich war Google nicht in der Lage, bisher das Ganze zu lösen.
So Support-Anfragen sind eigentlich immer absolut maximal.
Useless.
Hat jemand von euch schon mal eine wirkliche gute Antwort bekommen bei einer Support-Anfrage an Oracle, Google, Microsoft, IBM oder Konsorten?
Bisher, also ich kenne keine wirkliche Support-Sachen, die wirklich geholfen haben.
Vom Azure Support, okay, was habt ihr gefragt?
Also vom Azure Support habe ich bisher auch nichts Gutes mitbekommen.
Die haben immer den, die Standard-Taktik.
Die haben die Frage, die man gestellt hat.
Die haben das mal anderweitig formuliert, wiederholt, damit sie ihre Reaktionszeiten einhalten.
Und haben gefragt, wenn das das Problem gelöst hat, dann bitte das Ticket schließen.
Microsoft hat tatsächlich ihren Change richtig, okay.
Aber, okay, das war ja auch irgendwie so ein Bug-Report, was wahrscheinlich nicht nur euch betroffen hat.
Aber so Anfragen wie, warum hängen die Tools?
Also ich habe, ich habe selten, okay, sagen wir mal, streichen wir mal das nie.
Aber ich habe selten bisher zufriedenstellende Antworten von den großen Supports bekommen.
Gerade Oracle ist da ultra wenig hilfreich immer.
Aber Microsoft und Google auch.
Zumindest, es gab ein Ticket bei Google und es gab sogar ein Ticket bei Red Hat.
Weil man hat vermutet, also wie gesagt, Fehlerbild ist, man führt kubectl aus gegen den Google GKE Cluster.
Und es hängt ab und zu mal für ein paar Minuten.
Man hat, es gibt ein Ticket bei Red Hat, es gibt ein Ticket bei Google.
Und beide hatten keine Ahnung.
Warum gibt es dort Tickets?
Naja, weil es halt Red Hat, auf Red Hat zum größten Teil zumindest ausgeführt wird.
Und weil es halt Google Kubernetes Cluster sind.
Also insofern ist es ja logisch, warum man dort Tickets aufmacht.
Beide Seiten keine Ahnung.
So.
Und dann wurde ganz viel Zeug probiert und, und rumgebastelt.
Und irgendwie, irgendwie hat nix, hat nix gebracht.
So.
Und letzte Woche Freitag ging mir das so auf den Sack, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ey weißt du was?
Das musst du dir jetzt mal richtig angucken.
Das kann es doch nicht sein.
Also.
Auf geht's.
Ich kann euch jetzt ja mal grob erzählen, wie man, wie man sowas analysiert.
Wobei es auch ein bisschen Zufall war zwischendurch, dass ich das Richtige gefunden habe.
Aber ein bisschen Glück gehört immer dabei.
Okay.
Das Erstes ist, ich habe es ausgeführt und habe mal die Zeit gemessen, wie lange es hängt.
Und Leute, ratet mal, wie lange es hängt.
Es ist eine sehr, also eine sehr spezifische Zeit, die man kennt.
Wenn man Linux Tools verwendet.
Und es hängt immer gleich lang.
Sixty nine seconds.
Du bist gar nicht so weit weg von fünf Sekunden.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Minuten.
Minuten hängt es.
Nee, nee.
Es hängt, es hängt länger.
Also ich kann es euch sagen.
Es hängt immer zwei Minuten.
Ziemlich genau zwei Minuten.
So.
Das ist schon mal verdächtig.
Das ist schon mal, das ist schon mal sehr verdächtig, wenn was immer exakt zwei Minuten hängt.
Nicht, nicht mal drei mal vier mal eins.
Sondern immer zwei.
Das heißt, da ist irgendwas nicht kaputt in dem Sinn, sondern irgendwas reproduzierbar.
So.
Das nächste ist.
Ich habe mal probiert, wann es hängt.
Also was habe ich gemacht?
Ich kann euch übrigens mal Sixthead Befehl zeigen.
Wenn ihr, wenn ihr das noch nicht kennt, wie man sowas schön testen kann.
Machen wir mal kurz, machen wir mal kurz mein Linux verändern.
Hat sich schon gelohnt.
Ja.
Nein, das war nix mit Systemd.
Also was ich dann gemacht habe, ist ich habe eine Schleife angeschmissen.
While true, while true.
So Echo eins, zwei, drei.
Dann so Schleife.
So und in die Schleife habe ich folgendes reingeschrieben.
Timeout minus minus Signal.
Ich glaube Kill.
Nach zehn Sekunden.
Und dann glaube ich.
Ich mache jetzt mal sinngemäß ein Sleep.
Sleep fünf ergibt ja nicht wirklich Sinn.
Aber Kill zwei.
Ach so.
Okay.
So.
Und das geht mit Sleep überhaupt nicht.
Oder habe ich es jetzt falsch geschrieben?
Kill.
Tja.
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Quit.
Was ist, was ist Kill minus neun?
Was macht Terminate?
Term?
Okay.
Ich glaube ich habe das jetzt überhaupt richtig richtig geschrieben.
Na gut.
Ich mache ja keine Ausgabe.
Deswegen klappt das nicht.
Okay.
So kann man das machen.
Zum Beispiel.
Ich hoffe das stimmt jetzt, was ich gebaut habe.
Ja.
Genau.
Also was das macht ist.
Das startet.
Timeout startet ein anderes Programm.
Und nach zwei Minuten, wenn sich das Programm nach zwei Sekunden, wenn sich das Programm
innerhalb von zwei Sekunden nicht beendet hat, dann killt es das Ganze.
Also wenn sich Sleep fünf Sekunden nach zwei Sekunden nicht beendet hat, wird es gekillt.
Also es wurde immer gekillt.
Also habe ich das Ding mal in der Schleife laufen lassen und habe davor einfach ein Date
gemacht.
Und habe mir das angeguckt.
So wie oft das wie oft das auftritt.
Ja, normalerweise war das immer so nach dem Motto.
Ja, wir sind fertig.
Okay, okay, okay.
Abzug killt.
So.
Im Endeffekt hat sich herausgestellt.
Es ist alle 15 Minuten für zwei Minuten.
Und das ist doch schon sehr verdächtig.
Sachen, die alle 15 Minuten hängen.
Und dann exakt für zwei Minuten.
Das riecht doch wirklich nach Netzwerk Timeouts oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und es riecht nach Caching und in Verbindung mit Netzwerk Timeouts.
Also habe ich mich mal auf die Suche gemacht.
Woran könnte das da liegen?
Was macht kubectl denn?
Was Netzwerk Timeouts verursachen könnte?
Beziehungsweise an welcher Stelle könnte das Ganze hängen?
So und dann bin ich draufgekommen.
Mit.
Also man kann das ja mit unterschiedlichsten.
Ich habe hier kein Kubernetes.
Zeug laufen, aber ich kann.
Man kann das ja mit unterschiedlichsten.
Verbose Settings ausführen.
Ja, dann sieht man hier, was er macht.
Und zwischenzeitlich sieht man auch okay.
kubectl benutzt die Curl Library tatsächlich, um seine Request zu machen.
Und wisst ihr, was er default?
Default Timeout von Curl ist.
Aber so mal kurz gucken.
Ich glaube, dass ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht sehr auf 60 Sekunden stimmt.
Heim.
Out.
120 Sekunden ist nämlich eher das, was ich meine.
Ja, genau.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Der Curl Timeout defaultet zu zwei Minuten.
Und jetzt erkennt man schon irgendwie den Zusammenhang.
Okay, das Ding hängt für zwei Minuten.
Der default Curl Timeout ist zwei Minuten.
Das scheint ja irgendwas miteinander zu tun haben, zu tun zu haben.
So und.
Was ich dann als nächstes gemacht habe, ist.
Ich habe einen Proxy gesetzt.
Ein Proxy, den es nicht gibt.
Also sowas in der Richtung Export.
HTTP Proxy gleich 127001 oder sowas.
Ja, so.
Und wenn man jetzt kubectl ausführt, dann sieht man.
Okay.
Wir können.
Wir können nirgends.
Okay.
Ich dachte eigentlich, das benutzt er automatisch.
Aber okay.
Macht er nicht.
Zumindest kriegt man.
Vielleicht gedacht.
Zumindest hat mein kubectl automatisch Proxy Settings Plus.
Was auch immer.
Zumindest wenn man ein Proxy gesetzt hat, den es nicht gibt.
Dann hat man gesehen, dass kubectl ausspuckt.
Wir haben ein Problem bei der Verbindung.
Zu Google.
Und im Endeffekt hat sich herausgestellt, dass.
Und jetzt erkläre ich euch, woran es gelegen hat.
Also kubectl selbst macht einen Curl.
Auf eine externe Google Seite.
Nämlich G Static.
Feature XML.
Frag mich nicht, wie die richtige.
Ike Feature XML.
Also es gibt.
Es gibt irgendeine Public.
Public Seite von Google.
Und dort wird irgendeine Feature.
Jason ist es.
Glaube ich.
Wird eine Feature.
Jason abgerufen.
Findet man so über Google gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Passiert das.
Damit die Google.
Google.
Von Google.
Google Cloud.
Sub 먹고,
Google.
Google Jenner.
Googleубo.
Google Hub.
Google Health rus.
Und so weiter.
covers- clip aus.
Die.
stadt.
Und.
gcloud aus mit gcloud config helper aber die cloud config helper hieß das glaube ich ja die
cloud config helper ja und und und dann mit irgendwelchen magic mit irgendwelchen magic
parametern auch wenn man das versucht auszuführen mit mit wer wo sie gleich neun oder sowas den
config helper gibt es nicht wie ist das denn es ist einfach config helper ach was auch immer ich
krieg den kopf nicht mehr genau hin dann hat es ausgespuckt wir wollen eine verbindung machen zu
g static punkt com bla bla bla feature jason
feature xml und an der stelle hing es für 120 sekunden bis der call timeout erreicht war so
sobald ich den externen proxy gesetzt habe waren die timeouts instant weg sondern was eine
kombination aus wir müssen einmal warten 120 sekunden bis der timeout durch ist dann läuft
ctl weiter weil das aus weil das ort plugin abkackt und diese request die sind einfach
gecached für 15 sekunden in in hier und
Graham
youtube ganz hier genau
gut gut dass ich das hier auch habe hier sind die dinger sind reine gecasht und das timeout allerdings noch irgendwie 15 möglich minuten
Und dann geht das ganze wieder von vorne das heißt es an nichts damit zu tun wie oft man das benutzt und hat nichts
damit zu tun
dass sie random wer das problem ist dass das ding versucht ins internet zu kommen zu einer public google seite
von einer vm die nicht
ins internet darf das heißt wer sich wundert warum sein cube ctl mit google hängt in irgendeinem
privaten privaten cluster netz bei google was nicht im internet was ich nicht ins internet
darf das liegt daran dass google aus plugin möchte zu einer public internet seite connect
nun kann ich und dann hängt es zwei minuten und dass alle 15 minuten für zwei minuten fehler
behebung ist relativ easy man setzt den proxy das ist ins internet darf oder aber das ist das
was ich nächste woche mal ausprobieren muss oder aber das problem tritt da tritt tritt auf weil
unsere firewalls traffic trotten anstatt ihn zu rejecten gehe ich auch mal also gehe ich von aus
dass das mit da rein spielt weil normalerweise wenn du versuchst eine verbindung zu machen wo
du nicht hin darfst und die firewall sagt reject dann kriegst du eine fehlermeldung oder kann das
tool weitermachen wenn du einfach nur packages jobs dann muss das wirklich 120 sekunden da
bleiben und warten
bis das bis das durch ist also falls ihr mal irgendwie probleme habt dass euer cube ctl hängt
in umgebungen die nicht ins internet dürfen gerade in verbindung mit google cloud und im google cloud
plugin dann liegt höchstwahrscheinlich daran es ist reproduzierbar sobald es diese verbindung
machen kann geht es instant das ist das also entweder macht man auf jedem server eine iptables
regel die das die das rejected anstatt droppt
oder man macht eine host eintrag auf g static wobei das noch mehr auswirkungen hat ja solche
solche dinge aber da musste man auch erst mal drauf kommen nein ist es nicht es ist nicht die
cloud geht habe es es nicht also das authentifizierung planet ist nicht und ich glaube ach ist das hier
ich glaube nicht dass die cloud ist das g cloud cli ist das das ist python gedönst das weiß ich
ist das open source source die cloud source code ist es jetzt ist es jetzt open source oder nicht
naja da ist das wahrscheinlich mit drin moment das ist doch die falsche google cloud sdk geht
hab wo ist das denn gibt es das irgendwo anscheinend nicht oder an offiziell also
ist okay also es gibt es gibt nichts wo man pull request pull request machen kann dagegen
das aber schon ein bisschen blöd oder sonst hätten wir uns mal nützlich machen können und
und tatsächlich mal ein pull request einreichen können nicht nicht dass du die chance hättest
bei google was zu committen weil da musste irgendwie 1000 agreements sein und so was
mirror of gcloud mirror von wo wahrscheinlich von hier okay das ist irgendwie das gibt es
nicht da ist tolle antworten die nichts die nichts damit zu tun hat anscheinend anscheinend nicht
warum eigentlich google das musst du die leute fragen die das entschieden haben keine ahnung
ich persönlich jetzt auch netter gefunden wir hätten weiter wir würden er verwenden weil mit
er kenne ich mich besser aus wobei es mittlerweile mit google geht ich mache jetzt schon zweieinhalb
monate nur google cloud aber es ist halt so entschieden worden irgendwann mal dass die
hauptsächlich google cloud verwenden insofern
ja jetzt ist jetzt nicht dass ich da irgendwas großartig dran machen kann
das administrationstool probiert das wenn du wenn du auf irgendeinem client rechner
cubectl aufruft dann lädt das das google cloud authentifizierungs plugin das musst du benutzen
dass du dich gegen dass du cubectl gegen google kubernetes cluster verwenden kannst und das
wiederum ruft gcloud auf
das gcloud cli tool das da mit config helper und irgendwelchen parametern und das google cloud tool
cli tool macht die verbindung zu einem public public google service das ist schwierig zu verpacken in
einem video kommst du ein bisschen random aber könntest du vielleicht mal verraten wie du diese
formen oben reten was moment das da oder oder das da du meinst hier den krempel hier oben in der leiste
also zum beispiel auch so was wie cpu auslastung er meinte die cpu auslastung das hier den cpu
auslastungskraft die drei ach das hier die leiste ach ja das kann ich dir zeigen das ist nicht selbst
gemacht das ist ein tool was sich bumblebee status nennt da gibt es aber zig sachen die statusleisten
generieren für i3 und das verwende ich mit dem plug in alert
shell indicator memory disk load cpu und dings so und das hier ist die cpu auslastung das ist fertig
das gibt es auf github ob man richtig schreibt dass das ist das tool mit dem ich das mache
übrigens wie gesagt das ist nicht das einzige da gibt es da gibt es tausende solcher tools die die
statusleisten für i3 generieren wenn du dir meine config angucken willst kannst du dir bei mir in
github gucken unter.config i3 da ist sie unter .config i3 und jetzt kann ich hier diese platziert
ist meine E3-Config drin.
Der ist ja nicht so groß,
der ist nur irgendwie 100 Zeilen.
So, und...
Ach so, das wird bei...
Das eine Plugin wird bei dir nicht gehen,
nämlich das...
Ist das Alert?
Das ist das, was wir selbst gebaut haben.
Alert, diesen Countdown,
den haben wir selbst gebaut hier,
den gibt es nicht public.
Zumindest, das kannst du dir hier angucken
und die...
Ne, das war es.
Mehr Config hat das nicht.
Das ist alles, was du an Config brauchst.
Du kannst hier die Themes einstellen
und dann brauchst du noch
eine Schriftart, hier,
die...
gut aussieht.
Im Endeffekt, eine, die dir gefällt.
So sieht es aus, das war es.
Mehr musst du nicht machen.
Die Klimaanlage...
Kühl hier.
Aber warum sind die Packages nicht direkt in den GKE-Nodes?
Sodass der...
Es geht nicht um die GKE-Nodes.
Es geht um den Client-Rechner,
der die Admin-Tools ausführt.
Das hat nichts mit den GKE-Nodes zu tun,
weil du bist ja schon...
Du bist ja noch gar nicht connected
zu deinem GKE-Cluster zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Das geht ja folgendermaßen.
Du führst...
Du führst cubectl get pods aus,
was jetzt nicht geht, weil...
Naja, es...
Was jetzt nicht geht,
weil es läuft halt bei mir lokal
kein Kubernetes-Cluster.
Wenn du...
Wenn du cubectl...
irgendeinen cubectl-Command ausführst,
dann muss das ja...
sich zu irgendeinem Kubernetes-Cluster verbinden,
den du im Vorfeld konfiguriert hast.
Es gibt Plugins,
wie du einfach Cluster switchen kannst,
aber du musst den Cluster ja konfiguriert haben.
So.
Damit du dich gegen den Cluster connecten kannst,
brauchst du irgendeine Authentifizierung.
Und das kannst du entweder mit den offiziellen,
integrierten Authentifizierung-Sachen machen
oder mit irgendeinem Authentifizierungs-Plugin.
Und in Form...
Bei Google wird ein Authentifizierungs-Plugin
mit der Authentifizierung-Sache
mitgeliefert.
Wenn du cubectl über...
Wenn du gcloud-components oder sowas install...
Ja, guck, da musst du hier dieses
Authentifizierungs-Plugin installieren für cubectl,
was dann wiederum ein Request macht zu Google...
zu dem Google-Cloud-Tool,
was dann wiederum Authentifizierungs-Request macht
für den Kubernetes-Cluster.
Das ist damit...
Damit cubectl Credentials bekommt,
um sich verbinden zu können
zu deinem Cluster.
Zu deinem GKE-Cluster.
Ich weiß, warum bei mir Minikube nicht startet.
Das liegt daran, weil Docker hängt,
wenn man VMs resumt.
Oder weil ich...
Oder weil ich ein Kernel-Update gemacht habe,
ohne zu rebooten.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Das hängt mir jetzt aber schon erstaunlich lang.
Was ist denn da los?
Wir machen mal kurz ein Package-Update.
Eigentlich...
Oh, oh, da hat sich ein bisschen was getan.
Was gibt's hier noch?
Kein Kubernetes im Homelab.
Nee.
Ich hab keine...
Kein 16-Node-Cluster bei mir.
Docker run hello world.
Können wir mal gucken, ob Docker noch funktioniert.
Ja.
Nee.
Doch Kernel-Update, was bei mir hängt im Hintergrund.
Jetzt macht er auch grad Kernel-Update.
Lul.
Okay.
Dann machen wir noch mal Package-Update.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes hier?
Ja, Visual Studio Code.
Ein paar Icon-Themes.
Wunderbar.
Lassen wir updaten.
Dann machen wir ein Reboot.
Und dann sollte der ganze Camp wieder funktionieren.
Ich bin ja nicht Techniker.
Ich bin ja nicht nur Tim, der daheim drei Racks stehen hat mit Kubernetes und Virtualisierung-Sachen.
Wobei ich mich immer noch frage bei dem, was mit dem los ist.
Also, warum er diesen Kram überhaupt hat.
Den hier meine ich.
Fünf Kubernetes-Cluster daheim, ja.
Ich meine, es ist sicherlich nice, um...
Zeigt er seinen Rack irgendwo nochmal?
Einfach, wenn man Spaß am Basteln hat, ist das nice.
Aber ich brauche keinen zweiten Job daheim bei mir.
Um mich um meine Infrastruktur zu kümmern.
Irgendwie kann man es auch übertreiben.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Also, ich habe es ja früher auch total übertrieben mit Technik bei mir daheim.
Aber mittlerweile denke ich mir, ey, ich habe keinen Bock, mich neben meinem normalen Job noch um meine Infrastruktur daheim einen halben Tag kümmern zu müssen.
Macht er nicht nur YouTube?
Keine Ahnung, was der macht.
Wenn er nur YouTube macht und das sein Content ist, mit dem er Geld verdient, dann ja, verstehe ich es.
Aber trotzdem.
So, Docker Run sollte nicht gehen.
Wir rebooten mal und dann sollte er hoffentlich wieder alles tun.
Sehen wir gleich.
Ich reboote jetzt.
Und dann...
Jetzt kommt wieder die Frage.
Max, warum verwendest du keinen Display Manager?
Warum? Ich kann doch einfach einmal Start X eintippen.
Warum soll ich den Display Manager...
Leute, White Pepo Happy Time.
Sonnenaufgang.
So.
Restore.
Zack.
Docker Run.
Erstmal checken.
Gibt es neue Jetbrains?
Updates?
Tools?
Ja, Ryder wurde geupdatet.
Ach ne, die ERP-Variante.
Ne, die will ich gar nicht haben.
Warum habe ich überhaupt noch die ERP-Variante installiert?
Ich glaube für .98.
Brauchen wir mal.
Wollen wir aninstallen.
Weg damit.
Okay.
So, Docker Run funktioniert.
Minikube.
Minikube Start.
Gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert es.
Okay, gut.
Ja, mein Docker war broken.
Deswegen hat es nicht funktioniert.
Was zuckt denn der Download so?
Ah, jetzt funktioniert es.
Aber es gibt anscheinend eine neue Version.
Die habe ich noch nicht runtergeladen.
Deswegen dauert das jetzt kurz.
So, und ratzfatz haben wir gleich einen lokalen Kubernetes-Cluster.
Den ich gar nicht brauche, weil ich eigentlich gar nichts zeigen will.
Aber ich will wissen, ob es jetzt wieder funktioniert.
Unter...
Arch, by the way.
Habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt, dass ich bei meiner, bei meinem Vorstellungs...
Okay, nee, das muss ich, muss ich anders, muss ich anders machen.
Es gab vor ein paar Wochen bei uns so eine Einführungsveranstaltung.
Und das war so richtig cringe, äh, socialize Event.
Ihr wisst ja, wie sehr ich sowas mag.
Und da sollte man im Vorfeld, gab es so ein, ein gemeinsames, äh, ja, Board für neue Mitarbeiter.
Und da sollte jeder so einen kurzen Steckbrief ausfüllen.
Und das war quasi so eine riesen, so eine riesen Seite im Intranet.
Von jedem, von jedem halt einen, einen mit Name und Bild und, und Abteilung dabei, also ein Team dabei.
Und dann sollte man zwei Sachen unten drunter, unten drunter ausfüllen, so.
Für, für diese Forsch-, für diese große Einführungsveranstaltung.
Genau.
Und da sollte man raufschreiben so, was ist meine Superkraft?
Und so, so komisches, so komisches Zeug.
Und ich habe draufgeschrieben, I use Arch, by the way.
Nichts, es waren zwei Sachen, die man draufschreiben sollte, aber das, das war schon, das, ich habe schon wieder, ich bin wieder verdrängt, was das zweite war.
Achso, das eine war Fun Fact, das eine war Fun Fact über mich und das andere war meine Superkraft.
So richtig, das, das können sich nur irgendwelche, ähm, Personalabteilungsleute ausgedacht haben, die im Vorfeld irgendwelche, was weiß ich, Rhetorikkurse gemacht haben oder sowas.
Genau.
Das sollte, das sollte man draufschreiben.
Fun Fact und meine Superkraft.
So, und bei meiner Superkraft habe ich hingeschrieben, I use Arch, by the way.
Hat wahrscheinlich außer mir und vielleicht noch einem anderen nichts verstanden.
Und Fun Fact habe ich draufgeschrieben, also habe ich mit meinem, ich habe ja zusammen mit einem ehemaligen Kollege angefangen, jetzt bei der neuen Arbeit.
Wir haben beide das gleiche draufgeschrieben, so, dass wir uns schon von früher kennen, so.
Ich habe geschrieben, ich kenne ihn schon von früher und er hat geschrieben, ich kenne Max schon von früher.
Also total sinnlos.
Okay, so, wir haben, wir haben ein Kubernetes-Cluster am Start.
Get Pots.
Jawohl, es funktioniert.
So.
Und das ist das, was ich euch gerade zeigen wollte.
Es war bei mir auf der Arbeit so, wenn ich kubectl get Pots gemacht habe zum Beispiel, so, jetzt hing das Ding einfach zwei, es sah ungefähr so aus, wenn ich es ausgeführt habe bei mir auf der Arbeit, ja.
Ich habe kubectl ausgeführt, dann hing das zwei Minuten und dann, und dann ging es ganz, und dann ging es einfach ganz normal weiter.
Und 15 Minuten später gab es wieder die Probleme.
Ja, und wie gesagt, man kann dann, man kann dann Verbose Mode hier hochschalten und sieht, was der für, sieht.
Was der für, für Requests macht und alles Mögliche, ja.
Und da bin ich halt draufgekommen mit, mit der Zeit.
Also, wenn ihr das Problem habt, dass euer kubectl hängt in Verbindung mit Google Cloud.
Habe ich, das habe ich gerade ausführlich erzählt.
Also, wenn ihr Probleme habt, dass euer kubectl hängt, gerade gegen Google Kubernetes Cluster, alle 20, 15 Minuten für immer zwei Minuten, dann liegt das daran, dass, dass Google,
Kubernetes-Authentifizierungs-Plugin
beziehungsweise G-Cloud
nicht auf eine
Static-Google-Seite
ins Internet kommt.
G-Static.com, G-Cloud
Feature, JSON oder so,
will das runterladen und dann muss es auf
den Timeout warten.
Lösungsmöglichkeiten sind Proxysetzen, dass es
ins Internet kommt oder
Netzwerktraffic rejecten, anstatt
zu droppen. Eats.
Hat aber schon
eine Stunde oder so gedauert, bis ich dahinter
gekommen bin. Es war tatsächlich nicht so easy.
Aber im Nachhinein, wie das ist,
alles immer easy.
Easy as fuck.
GG Eats.
So sieht's aus.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ja, aber nicht nur bei mir,
sondern es betrifft ja alle.
Ansonsten, lass mal kurz gucken, was können wir uns denn
schönes anschauen?
Irgendwelche Chess-Player, die erneut sind.
Ich weiß nicht, warum mir YouTube
immer Schach-Videos vorschlägt.
Ich gucke keine Schach-Videos.
Aber wahrscheinlich weiß YouTube mittlerweile auch,
dass der Chat, dass wir
so ultra-high IQ sind, dass Chat,
dass, dass, dass, ähm,
Schach-Videos eigentlich genau
unserem Profil entsprechen.
Wann probieren wir Twin?
Text-based Window Env...
Was?
Das ist doch eh outdated as fuck, oder?
Das sieht aus, als
basiert's auf Endcurses und Endcurses benutzt
doch niemand mehr.
Ja, aber was für ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
Da kannst du keinen Browser aufmachen.
Das ist komplett unsinnig.
But if you've been working behind
BSD, graphical like
Features, it's...
...environment.
Like, it's not laid out
as one new terminal,
oh, C for coffee,
really, really...
Naja, ich weiß nicht.
So, wo gibt's denn das Ganze hier?
Okay, es wird tatsächlich
aktiv entwickelt, ja.
Okay.
Moment.
Twin.
Wie heißt das?
Twin?
Ja.
Outdated, overrated,
she baited.
Gibt's nicht.
Twin.
Get up.
Ja.
Release it.
Tags.
09, ne, es ist tatsächlich...
Okay, das kann man
nicht installieren.
Man muss das...
Man muss das selbst bilden, oder?
Oh, ne, da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Install.
Hier.
Building and installing.
Okay, ich klone das Repo jetzt.
Und entweder es
kompiliert instant, oder wir lassen das
und gucken dann Videos.
Okay, Twin.
Also, wie geht das?
Insta...
Installing.
Ich mach mal einen Snapshot davor.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was das Ding...
Oh.
Warum hab ich noch so viele Snapshots?
Das verbraucht viel zu viel Disk.
Okay.
Make und...
Okay, erst Configure.
Make.
Okay, es sieht so aus, als ist alles da.
Hackerman-Modus aktiviert.
Nice.
Make.
Let's go.
Chat.
Ich glaube, es ist obvious, was passiert.
Ich muss dazu nix erklären.
Sollte jeder instant verstehen.
So.
ein wenig ein wenig unsinnig ich wüsste jetzt halt nicht so wirklich was ich damit anfangen
soll ja okay gut man muss es glaube ich erst mal also ich ich wüsste wirklich nicht was ich da
warum ich verwenden sollte ist ich habe echt keinerlei anwendungszweck dafür block yep clock
okay wir beenden das jetzt mal ich habe ich keine ahnung was ich damit anfangen soll die farben ja
die sind bisschen kaputt so als werden wir erst mal wieder den snapshot restore bevor ich das
installiert habe das ist ein weiterer grund dafür warum vor ems und snapshots best best ever sind
jetzt jetzt kommt natürlich jemand um die ecke sagt ja aber max zf s snapshots man kann es auch
dafür übertreiben ja dass das das schon irgendwie ich weiß nicht so wirklich warum ich für was und
warum ich verwenden würde so und jetzt wo ich aber meine ganzen alten snapshots löschen weil
die umgänge nicht mehr so gut sind und ich weiß nicht so wirklich warum ich für was und warum ich
unsinnig viel ram verbrauchen magst ans trinken erinnern exzellent ok why rollercoaster tycoon
ist ja weil es in der sampler programmiert ist weil das extrem sex hat ist rollercoaster tycoon
das was ist das hier i try to find hidden gems und aliexpress again hat er denn hier ist so
eine mini wasser pfeife oder sowas und das war das mal
zack jetzt so und jetzt lösche ich mal meine ganzen snapshots und die lied jetzt weiß ich
mal warum ich die snapshot snapshot snapshot überhaupt warum ich die überhaupt snapshot habe
aber ich glaube nicht dass man das irgendwie noch braucht und es frisst unsinnig viel guck mal hier
wie lahm das schon ist und das ist auf der ssd die irgendwie
5 terabyte die sekunde oder was auch immer die 5 gigabyte die sekunde oder so übertragen kann die
flutscht extrem die ssd und das ist lahm als fakt na gut also was haben wir denn hier zu bieten i try
to find hidden gems und aliexpress so werden grafiker auch mal wieder ein video vom auer
haben wir schon lange nicht mehr geguckt ab 30 minuten klein was ist das die neue
arbeitswelt der gen z ok das ist wahrscheinlich wieder übelst cringe je nachdem wie lange das
ist ich weiß gar nicht ob das eine von boomern erstellte reportage ist oder irgendwie zumindest
so ein bisschen was in meinem alter oder so rip google domains ok fire ship ist immer nice
neues smart home video auch ich weiß gar nicht was gucken wir dann wir gucken jetzt hin gems
und aliexpress erstes video da kann man ein bisschen drüber skippen wenn ein paar sachen
dabei sind die mich alter wie lange braucht er für die snapshots man
leckge
man wir müssen nicht zu gucken wie er das macht also ich kann wir können schon weitermachen aber
ich bin immer wieder erstaunt wie lahm teilweise das aufräumen von snapshots ist auf der anderen
seite ist es auch verständlich weil er muss ja den ganzen diff rausfinden und dann applying in
ein neues image weil soweit ich weiß funktionieren die vor allem was snapshots ja auf wie nennt sich
das copy und write was ach weiß ich machen das snapshot und vom snapshot zeitpunkt werden dann
quasi nur noch diffs gespeichert wenn du das die wenn die snapshots löscht muss ja quasi neues
disk image erzeugen mit den aus den diffs zum snapshot deswegen dauert das ein bisschen unter
btrfs geht schneller benutzt vor allem bei workstation btrfs als snapshot backend kannst
das also bei unter windows ja schon mal mit btrfs gar nicht er ist fertig ok nice und bei btrfs ist
ja generell immer die frage ist es btrfs beta fs butter fs oder was ist es denn eigentlich
oder ist es gar btrfs okay dann lasst uns mal die die hidden gems auf aliexpress angucken
do you know what this is ja sie ist wie gesagt sieht aus wie irgendwie so low budget wasser pfeife
and no it is not a vape das erste was ich gedacht habe do you know what this is and no it is not a
vape it is by electronics but do not worry i also had no idea what it is used for for
making this video okay keine ahnung was das ist but that is the beauty of shopping on aliexpress
ja und und das stimmt schon man kann da wirklich useful stuff finden aber es ist bei aliexpress
auch enorm wirklich enorm viel schrott dabei und teilweise auch wirklich gefährliche sachen
also offensichtlichste sachen die gefährlich sind sind zum beispiel laser die man sich bei aliexpress
Du kannst dir bei AliExpress Laser kaufen, die sind so stark, die brennen dir quasi ein Loch in die Hand, so nach dem Motto, also das ist wirklich heftig, was es da gibt und du darfst es dir wahrscheinlich offiziell, darfst du dir das wahrscheinlich gar nicht einführen und bestellen, also ihr wisst, was ich meine, also du darfst es nicht in das Land einführen und du darfst es wahrscheinlich nicht besitzen und benutzen, aber realistisch betrachtet wird es wahrscheinlich auch keiner merken.
Deswegen will ich nicht wissen, wie viele Leute sich dort irgendwelche komischen Sachen bei AliExpress bestellen, die durchaus gefährlich sind und dann andere Sachen, die auch schon mal sehr fragwürdig sind, die bieten zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Muttermalentfernungssets und sowas an.
Das würde ich, ich würde mir doch im Leben nicht bei AliExpress ein Muttermalentfernungsset kaufen und dann an mir rumschnippeln und lasern. Alter, wie lost kannst du eigentlich sein, dass du das machst?
Ja, Max, kein Witz. Wird da an allen Ecken beworben. Ist die Leistung eines Lasers gesetzlich geregelt?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich würde mal vermuten, ja. Dass es da Vorgaben gibt.
Sonst hast du wieder irgendwelche lustigen Leute, die mit AliExpress-Lasern Flugzeuge anlasern und sowas.
Gab es ja schon ein paar Fälle in den letzten Jahren. Die haben dann Flugzeuge angelasert.
Mit, mit...
Mit viel zu starken AliExpress-Lasern.
Was übrigens, wer hätte es gedacht, verboten ist, Flugzeuge anzulasern.
Hat das nicht ApoRed mal gemacht?
Keine Ahnung, aber ganz ehrlich, es würde zu ApoRed passen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er das gemacht hat, aber passen würde es wirklich gut.
Könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wisst ihr, was auch bei AliExpress verkauft wird, was bei uns nicht mehr verkauft werden darf?
Oder...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei uns nicht mehr verkauft werden darf oder nur mit Auflagen.
Glühbirnen.
So ganz normale Glühbirnen.
Kannst du dir bei AliExpress noch kaufen.
Und die werden dann dort oftmals auch gar nicht als Glühbirne beworben, sondern...
Genau, genau.
Die werden beworben als Heizung.
Als Heizung, die ungefährliche Strahlung im sichtbaren Bereich abgibt.
Keine Glühbirne.
Way to Dank ist das.
Gibt es AliExpress?
Ich gehe davon aus, man kann einfach nach Glühbirne suchen.
Glühbirnen.
So.
Nein, das sind LED-Sachen.
Das ist Fake.
Retro Edison-Birne.
Ampulle.
Ah, es war Simon Desue, nicht ApoRed.
Ja, das ist...
Okay, das schlägt aber in die gleiche Kerbe.
Ich hätte das beiden ohne Probleme zugetraut.
Es gibt gutes Zeug bei AliExpress.
Ja, das ist...
Keine Frage.
Ich habe auch schon viel bei AliExpress bestellt.
Bei mir hauptsächlich Elektronik-Teile.
Aber AliExpress ist nicht pauschal schlecht.
Es gibt halt viel Schrott, aber man kriegt da so ein bisschen das Gefühl für...
Ich hab nie geplant, wie man bei AliExpress bestellt.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Für viele sieht AliExpress halt ultra nach Scam aus, wobei ich noch nie gescampt wurde.
Und der eine, nennen wir das mal Scam-Versuch.
Und der andere, nennen wir das mal Scam-Versuch.
Aber AliExpress ist nicht pauschal schlecht.
Es gibt halt viel Schrott, aber man kriegt da so ein bisschen das Gefühl,
ich habe nie geplant, wie man bei AliExpress bestellt.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Für viele sieht AliExpress halt ultra nach Scam aus,
wobei ich noch nie gescamt wurde.
Und der eine, nennen wir es mal Scam-Versuch,
wurde mir direkt von AliExpress erstattet.
Also wurde ich auch nicht gescamt.
Also gut, das Bestellen bei AliExpress ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Du legst dir ein Konto an und am Ende,
ich glaube, man kann mittlerweile sogar schon per PayPal bezahlen.
Das hängt ein bisschen vom Shop ab.
Also AliExpress ist ja eigentlich gar kein Shop.
AliExpress ist ja eigentlich nur ein großer Marketplace.
Das hier sind die eigentlichen Stores, die da was verkaufen.
Das heißt, wenn du dir irgendwie so einen Set-Microcontroller kaufen willst,
dann kannst du hier sagen, bla bla bla,
das ist dieser Shop, der das verkauft,
Pünktlichkeitsgarantie, was auch immer.
Und da musst du gucken, was die für Payment und Versandarten und sowas anbieten.
Aber viele bieten auch PayPal an.
Teilweise sogar Apple Pay, wenn es der Chat sagt, ja.
Also ich habe AliExpress schon lange benutzt
und damals musste man sich noch einen Alipay-Account anlegen.
Und Leute, ich sage euch,
Alipay-Account wäre nichts für Aluhut-Leute gewesen.
Du musstest in der Seite, die rein China-Chinesen-mäßig war,
musstest du mit einem Google Translator,
weil du die Seite sonst nicht verstanden hast,
musstest du Alipay anlegen.
Du musstest Alipay über Google Translate irgendwie aufmachen,
dann musstest du dich da registrieren.
Und dann musstest du deine Kreditkarte auf einer China-Chinesen-Seite,
die du nicht verstanden hast, deine Kreditkarte registrieren.
Und dann konntest du mit Alipay auf Aliexpress bezahlen, Leute.
Ich sage euch, das war wirklich nichts für Internet-Noobs.
Und eigentlich war es auch eine blöde Idee,
wirklich meine Kreditkarte dort einzutragen.
Heute hätte ich wahrscheinlich irgendeine Fake-Kreditkarte generiert.
Also, eine, die funktioniert,
aber die ich direkt wieder sperren lassen kann, instant.
Es ist aber nicht schlimm,
weil die Kreditkarte, die ich da hinterlegt habe,
das ist schon Jahre her, die ist mittlerweile eh längst abgelaufen.
Und wo ihr auch aufpassen müsst,
hier bei diesem Blödsinn bei Aliexpress,
wenn da teilweise steht, irgendwie 46 Cent und sowas.
Leute, die ganzen Dinger, die kosten nicht 46 Cent.
Das ist immer...
Also, zum Beispiel, ich zeige euch mal was, mal gucken, ob ich sowas finde.
Ja, manchmal haben die so Sachen wie hier, kostet 46...
Okay, die kosten wahrscheinlich wirklich so wenig hier.
Kostet 46 Cent und sowas.
Ja.
Und wenn ihr da drauf geht, werdet ihr feststellen, je nachdem, was es ist.
Ja, das ist schon mit Rabatt.
Manchmal machen die es auch so,
die packen vier verschiedene Produkte in diese Seite rein
und das, was du haben willst, kostet 8 Euro.
Aber die haben dann noch einen USB-Stick mit da drin.
Ja.
Und der USB-Stick kostet nur 40 Cent.
Und dann wird das angezeigt auf der Übersichtsseite als 40-Cent-Produkt,
obwohl das eigentlich 9 Euro kostet, das, was du haben willst.
Das ist...
Also, Aliexpress ist echt so eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Aber die Bestellung ist mittlerweile ziemlich easy.
Es sieht halt ultra nach Scam aus irgendwo, ja.
Es sind Stufenbohrer.
Keine Kegelbohrer.
Da musste ich mich mal belehren lassen.
Das ist ein Gift.
Alles klar.
Ich bezahle es, aber es ist ein Gift.
Ich finde das immer sehr nett von denen,
dass die mir was schenken, wenn ich das bezahle.
95 Prozent günstiger.
Zusätzlich noch mal sagen...
Ja, ja, Leute, klickt das mal an und dann werdet ihr sehen,
am Ende kostet es trotzdem mehr.
Die kosten am Ende 9 Euro, ja.
Die sind wahrscheinlich auch ziemlicher Schrott.
Aber ich habe auch so ähnliche.
Für...
Für 3D-Drucker und so sind die ganz gut.
Ja, ja, wenn du...
Du siehst den Preis schon, wenn du es in den Warenkorb gelegt hast.
Ich kann es nicht richtig in den Warenkorb legen, weil ich nicht angemeldet bin.
Digi-Tailing-Store?
Ja, Aliexpress halt.
Ich kann euch nur empfehlen, es mal auszuprobieren.
Ich meine, es ist nicht, dass irgendwie was passieren könnte.
Ja, wenn du über PayPal bestellst und irgendwie auch nur...
Nur bestellst, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20 Euro oder so.
Also, was soll passieren?
Es kann euch halt Schrott geliefert werden, aber das war es dann auch.
Kann man ausprobieren.
Also, Aliexpress lohnt sich.
Es hat sich jahrelang gerade für Elektronikteile gelohnt.
Also, wenn du dir Transistoren, Relays, Widerstände, Kondensatoren, Leiterplatten,
also irgendwelche Breadboards, ESP-Microcontroller, alle möglichen Dinge...
Also, wenn du dir so Elektronik-Krams bestellen wolltest,
dann war Aliexpress einfach exklusiv.
Extremly pog.
Deswegen habe ich auch noch so viel ESP32 hier im Vorrat.
Die werde ich wahrscheinlich nie für irgendwas brauchen können.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
Was hat er für Hidden Gems bei Aliexpress?
Moment.
Da hatten wir aber das deutlich bessere Projekt schon.
Mit so einem Board hatten wir schon das deutlich bessere Projekt.
Moment.
Archiv.
Titel.
Da ist es doch.
Es.
Also, ich finde, das ist der bessere Anwendungszweck dafür.
Oder?
Jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage heute.
Weeps in oder weeps out?
Also, warum sollte ich mich da drauf anzeigen lassen,
wenn man auch was Gescheites drauf anzeigen lassen kann?
Leute, ich...
Meint ihr nicht auch, es wäre mal wieder Zeit für ESP-Bastel-Stream?
Das Problem ist so, ich weiß nicht, was ich basteln soll.
Ich habe gerade keinen Anwendungszweck.
Ja, das Board von ihm hat eine Webcam.
Ich weiß, ich habe es schon gesehen.
Schauen wir uns noch mal an sechs weitere Produkte von Aliexpress an,
die sehr interessiert waren,
um euch zu erzählen, ob ihr sie aussehen oder sie einfach ignorieren solltet.
Lass uns anfangen.
This video is sponsored by Keysight World Innovates.
Excellent.
Let's start off with this development board here,
consisting of a screen, camera and most importantly...
Was ist es? Es ist...
Was ist es denn?
Äh, was ist es denn?
...a module built around the TX-51 OIC,
which is an AI face recognition module
that you can altogether get for around 54 Euro.
So...
Ja, geil.
Und was...
Also, und was soll ich damit machen?
Da hätte ich jetzt spontan überhaupt keinerlei Anwendungszweck für.
So, in theory, according to the name,
this board should be capable of capturing an image of my face
and then recognizing it under a variety of conditions,
which could be really awesome for certain electronics.
Also, die alten...
Also, die alten Hardware dieser Kategorie,
die konntest du ja übelst leicht austricksen.
Somit...
Wir halten ein Foto von dem Typ davor und sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut die Neuen davon sind.
Weil das ist ja auch jetzt an Sensoren und so jetzt nichts wahnsinnig Krasses,
was da drin sein kann.
Nee, nee, nee, den Bewegungsmelder habe ich noch nicht.
Da habe ich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr geguckt.
Nice.
Schöne China-Chinesen-Anleitung.
Ach ja, ist RISC-32-Core, ist das nicht dieser China-CPU?
Nee, das ist was anderes, oder?
Bis zu 400 MHz, okay.
Zackig.
1000 Fäße und dass es in dunklen Umständen funktioniert.
Aber dankbar ist diese Sache ziemlich selbstverständlich.
Das heißt, nach dem Poweren können wir den S1-Button benutzen,
um ein Fäßbild zu kapieren und mit dem S2-Button...
Ja gut, richtig interessant.
Richtig interessant.
Das ist doch aber nur mit eigener Firmware drauf.
This system does its face recognition procedure.
And yes, as you can see, my face has been successfully recognized.
Die Frage ist,
recognized das auch andere als ihn, oder wenn man ein Foto hinhält?
Wasser ist er lange für den Zapf.
...what the limitations of this board are.
And all in all I can say,
that as long as you directly face the camera,
it can pretty much always recognize you,
no matter if you cover part of your face,
wear a hat, wear glasses, or sit in complete darkness,
thanks to the integrated infrared LEDs.
You cannot even trick the board with 2D images of the captured face,
meaning its only weak point is that it cannot recognize your face at an angle,
which is acceptable, I would say.
So after the initial testing, I was rather happy with the board.
And since it requires 5V and a maximum of 800mA to work,
so nothing exotic,
it should be pretty versatile to use.
But for that, we of course needed to communicate with other microcontrollers.
And for that, the board comes with a serial communication port,
that other makers already successfully used.
And they even already integrated the board into Home Assistant.
Awesome!
So yeah,
all in all, I would recommend it.
Okay, that is indeed quite nice,
if you want to build something yourself,
with facial recognition.
One problem, that I see again,
is that you need a case,
well, you have to build a case yourself,
and apparently there is nothing ready for that.
And if you want to hang something like that outside,
it is probably not done with a 3D printed case.
You have to get it waterproof somehow.
But indeed, a very interesting board.
I would not have another board,
if not for the use of it.
But it is definitely good,
that there are such things.
The only downside I see,
is maybe the rather high price point.
Which I honestly think though,
is justified.
Because there is a lot going on,
on this development board.
But anyway, let's move on to the next product.
Which is this hotplate,
that at 50 Euro,
is in my opinion quite cheap.
I initially got it,
because even though my...
This is a mini,
a mini-heizplatte.
Some people use it,
to solder things evenly.
So you put your parts on it,
so you put a controller on it,
or some kind of PCB on it,
you equip it with soldering paste,
you put your components on it,
and then you heat it.
For spot-out plates,
NTRY-1 works perfectly fine,
when it is soldered,
and when it is soldered,
they are sadly limited in size.
And thus,
I quickly pushed them to their limits.
But as you can see,
this new hotplate,
can house both of my old ones onto it.
And in numbers that means,
a heating area of 10x10cm.
Which should be enough,
for the majority of my PCBs.
It heats up to a maximum of 350W,
which means,
that it heats up to a maximum of 350W,
with an okay accuracy.
And after taking it apart,
I can say that its overall build quality
is pretty good.
Pretty much the only problem it comes with,
is that its surface
does not really heat up evenly,
and thus comes with a hotspot.
Which is a problem
my old hotplates do not come with.
But even with the hotspot,
I had no problem so far
using the product.
And thus,
I would definitely recommend it.
Because I think,
the price performance ratio is incredible.
Next we got a case here,
where you can find the,
I would say,
pen from the beginning of the video.
That is actually a rosin dispenser.
Ein was?
Ich hätte ernsthaft keine Ahnung,
was ich damit mache.
Cool mini cooling fan?
Was?
USB charging soldering fume
for phone repair?
Okay, fume sind Dämpfe?
Lötdämpfe?
Lötdampf?
...
Let me show you how it works
and why you might need it.
After charging it up,
Hey Max,
habe am Dienstag ein Telefoninterview
für Ausbildung
zum Fisi. Da würde ich mal sagen,
das ist extremly nice!
Ist ja schon übermorgen.
Kannst ja mal erzählen, was rausgekommen ist,
wenn das durch ist.
Telefoninterview, weil die wahrscheinlich
im Vorfeld erstmal gucken wollen
nachladen sie dich ein oder? Ja, dann guck mal, dass du einen guten Eindruck machst am Dienstag.
Eats.
Sag einfach, du guckst immer Wubbler aus, dann ist schon direkt Einladung raus.
Wir müssen den Button furchtbar drücken, um es eventuell anzupassen.
Und dann, wenn wir den Button drücken, können wir sehen, dass der Keil am Topf
ziemlich viel Wärme erzeugt.
Danach brauchen wir die vier kleinen zusätzlichen Pakete.
Ich habe immer noch absolut keine Ahnung, wofür das gut sein soll.
A.k.a. Truffle, die mit der Penne kommen.
Das ist im Grunde genommen ein hartes Rosenfrax, glaube ich,
das du normalerweise mit deinem Sorter benutzen kannst, damit...
Das ist hart, das ist Kunstharz, oder?
Zum Schützen von irgendwelchen Schaltungen, das ist das Kunstharz?
Ja, das einzuatmen ist bestimmt extrem gesund, ja, Chat, glaube ich auch.
Es steckt besser zu deinen Komponenten.
Das ist Kunstharz!
Aber in unserem Fall wollen wir das Ganze in den Dispenser füllen.
Oh ja, das ist bestimmt sehr gesund, einzuatmen.
Wir schließen es auf und heben es auf, um den Schmuck zu erzeugen,
den wir dann literally über unsere elektronischen Komponenten füllen können.
Wie ihr sehen könnt, schlägt das ein Schmuck-like Lager auf die Komponenten,
das schnell wegfällt, sobald die Heizung stattfindet.
Sieht aus wie Leute am Bahnhof-Stift.
Also die Idee ist, dass wenn ihr einen 40er-Komponenten-Komponenten habt,
mit vielen Komponenten und wollt den Komponenten finden,
der schlecht ist und dadurch die höchste Heizung erzeugt,
könnt ihr diese Technik nutzen, um nur das zu machen,
was ich glaube, großartig ist.
Und ich habe das ehrlich gesagt noch nie gehört.
Bis jetzt habe ich...
Wollte ich gerade sagen, man könnte einfach so eine Kamera nehmen.
...meine Thermalkamera benutzt, um Hotspots zu finden.
Aber das ist nicht so exakt und auch ziemlich teuer.
Weshalb dieser Rosen-Dispenser definitiv eine Rekommendation bekommt,
von meinen Seiten.
Und der einzige negativen Aspekt, den ich fürchtet habe,
ist, dass seine Heizung nicht so lange dauern könnte.
Aber dann wiederum ist sie verwendbar.
Okay.
Ja gut, verwendbar kostet...
Das Verwendungskosten kostet mehr als einfach einen Zehner-Pack neu bestellen.
Danach kommen wir zu einer Trend, die ich immer mehr sehe.
Welche sind solche normal aussehenden USB-Kabeln,
deren andere Seite...
Ja, da habe ich auch mal...
zwei...
verschiedene...
Sorten von gekauft.
Und ich muss euch sagen, es wirkte erstmal sehr praktisch.
Benutze ich aber nicht mehr.
Weil du musst permanent in deinem Gerät halt den Stecker drin lassen.
Und wenn du es mal irgendwo laden willst,
wo du halt nicht die andere magnetische Seite hast,
musst du das jedes Mal raushummeln.
Also das ist auch was, was in der Theorie her cool klingt,
aber in der Praxis hat es mir nicht gefallen.
...
nicht so gut. Dann guck dir aber
auf jeden Fall die Webseite von denen im
Vorfeld an. Dass du ein bisschen
punkten kannst mit Sachen, die bei denen
relevant sind.
Also hast du ja wahrscheinlich schon. Guck dir mal
ein bisschen an, was die machen.
Kannst du vielleicht auch das ein oder andere
Knowledge droppen.
Oliver, danke für den Sub und
danke an die
Subscriptions hier, Leute.
IQ-Punkte wieder massive gestiegen
im Chat.
Because there are not as much in the way
if you want to use your phone while
charging. But as you
might know, due to one of my previous
videos, I love it
when my USB cables waste the
least amount of power while charging.
And this magnetic connection
here gave me nightmares concerning
that. Meaning I had
to test it out.
So first off, a normal charging
test.
Real Fritteo. Danke für den Sub.
Du musst nicht Passwörter googeln. Ich würde
bei denen auf der Webseite mal gucken, was die so
machen. Und dir das im Vorfeld
anschauen. Also so, dass
du zumindest ein bisschen was anfangen kannst
mit den Dingern.
...with both cables. During
which the purple cable pulled
off a current flow of 2.7
amps, aka fast charging,
while the red one
only did 1.2 amps.
So, not fast charging.
Even though they claimed it
could do that.
Next I built up my usual used
B-Cable-Test-Setup,
in which I pushed more and more current
through the cable.
Ist das noch ein alter Zahlmann-Kühler, Leute?
Kennt ihr die Teile noch?
Das sieht aus wie früher
die Kühler, die man auf AMD
Athlon XP drauf gemacht hat.
Ja?
Ups, falscher Knopf. Aber ja.
Ich glaube schon, oder? Das ist das.
Guckt's mal. Ja, 100 Pro,
Alter. Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist so ein Ding.
Das war ein
Das war damals absolute
High-IQ-Pog-Lüfter.
Das war der einzige Lüfter,
den ich jemals von Zahlmann hatte.
Ich wusste vorher nicht, dass die Lüfter machen.
Und, ähm...
Die haben danach irgendwie auch
keine Lüfter mehr gemacht.
Nefferts, danke für den Sub.
Oh, Klickmaps.
Uri!
Das Einzige, was ich mir aus der Schule in der Richtung
gemerkt habe, Uri!
... die Messungen mit beidem Kabel,
es scheint, dass der rote Kabel
mit einer Resistenz von 0,35 Ohm kommt,
während der rote mit 0,26 Ohm,
was ziemlich nahe ist
an den schlechtestes Kabel
aus meinem vorherigen Video.
Um das in Perspektive zu bringen,
während das schnellste Kabel mit dem roten Kabel
fast 20% der Kraft
verpasst wird, als Heizung,
was man einfach fühlen kann,
wenn man das Kabel anfängt.
Also, all in all würde ich sagen,
diese Kabel tun ihren Job, wie es geplant ist.
Aber, für mich,
ist die Lüftung einfach zu groß.
Das heißt, ich würde sie nicht
empfehlen.
Okay, aus dem Gesichtspunkt habe ich das gar nicht gesehen.
Ich habe ja auch so Dinger schon verwendet.
Ähm, ich fand sie einfach nicht praktisch genug.
Moving on
to something way more amazing though.
Also, insofern...
These Bugboost Converters,
6302 OIC,
that you can get
for around 3 Euro a piece.
Das ist ein ganz normaler
Spannungswandler, oder?
Ja. Hm.
Da kann man ja auch noch ein paar rumfliegen.
In allen möglichen Größen.
Das ist...
Ist das einer, der immer das gleiche rausgibt?
Oder ist das einer mit so einem
einstellbaren Output?
Weil ich sehe jetzt da nichts zum Drehen.
Now, by shorting one of these four pads,
Ja, Step Up
Down ergibt wenig Sinn, ja.
Ach so!
Da kann man das abgreifen, was man haben will.
Also es ist immer...
You can adjust the output voltage
to 2.5 Volts,
3.3 Volts, 4.2 Volts
or 5 Volts.
But I think for us most important
is 3.5
5 und 3.3 Volt, ja.
Was Microcontroller angeht.
3 Volts and 5 Volts to power
your electronics projects.
This output voltage stays fixed
even when varying the input voltage
between 1.8 Volts
and 5.5 Volts.
Which is awesome
if you only got one or two batteries
that you want to use
to power your electronics projects.
But at this point you might say
this is nothing special.
There are tons of other voltage converters
out there that can do that.
So why should we care
about this specific one?
Well, if we look at the input current
of this generic converter
then we can see that it draws
around 160 microamp
while powering nothing
on the output.
Combine that with my battery's capacity
of 2 Ah
and we know that my battery
could theoretically solely
power the converter for
520 days.
Which is not bad.
But when going through
the data sheets
of the TPS
we can find out
that it only requires
25 microamps.
Meaning my battery
could power it for
3333 days.
Big difference.
Only problem was
that the converter drew
way more current than that.
Around 11.5 milliamps
to be precise.
Das
zieht viel zu viel
für ein Microcontroller-Projekt
was du an der Batterie
laufen lassen willst.
Ich mein,
ein ordentlicher
ESP32
die sind eh schon nicht für so Low-Power-Projekte
gut geeignet.
Aber wenn du einen ordentlichen ESP32 hast
der im Deep Sleep
nicht viel verbraucht
dann geht das prinzipiell.
Allerdings wenn du dann
einen Spannungswandler hast, der 11 milliampere braucht,
dann kannst du ja knicken.
Das ist ja ratzfatz leer
die Batterie.
Also ein ESP32 zum Beispiel
so ein Firebeetle ESP32
die verbrauchen ein paar microampere
im Deep Sleep.
Die schalten sich halt auch wirklich komplett
aus.
Stromverbrauch.
Wo steht's denn?
Low Power Consumption.
Es wäre natürlich sehr sinnvoll
wenn man da was hängt.
Es braucht so 10 microampere.
Das ist natürlich
Faktor 1000
einfach unterschiedlich.
Das ist schon besser.
Das macht es eine perfekte Anwendung
für Low Power Microcontroller Projekte
die mit nur einer Batterie
für Jahre laufen müssen.
Aber bevor ich es
voll recommendiere
musste ich natürlich die restlichen
elektrischen Fähigkeiten testen.
Und hier muss ich sagen
dass der beklagte Max Output Current
von 3 Ampere nur erreichbar war
bei einer Input Voltage von 4 Volt.
Und alles unten
resultierte in viel weniger
Output Current.
Aber das war ehrlich gesagt
das größte Problem.
Denn der Noise Output sah gut aus
und nach ein paar Effizienz-Kalkulationen
kann ich sagen
brauche ich eh nicht so oft.
Also ich habe hier noch
Spannungswandler in allen möglichen
Ausführungen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich sowas brauche.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Und so kommen wir zum letzten Produkt.
Das ist ein weiteres
Entwicklungsgerät.
Okay, das ist bestimmt Schrott.
Ah, obviously. Alles klar.
Leute, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, oder?
USB.
Das ist auch das einzige, was ich hier dran verstehe
an dem ganzen Ding. USB.
Free Shipping Speech
Synthesis
Module TTS
Pure Text to Speech
Playbacked
Halilingo AI
Intelligent Speech Broadcast
Alles klar.
Die Daten sind einfach immer absolut pfeifert
bei AliExpress.
Synthesis Module
That you can get for around 15 Euro
So in theory, by typing in text
this module should be able
to turn that into hearable speech
which once again
sounds promising
for certain electronics projects.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das taugt.
Only problem was that after connecting the boards
to my computer and following
the product descriptions instructions
I was not able to communicate with the boards.
Das Nordbank explodiert.
Die China Software, die sieht immer so geil aus,
guckt euch das an.
I was not able to communicate with the boards.
Das sieht immer echt aus 1995,
Alter, der Kram.
Wahrscheinlich ist das auch von 1995.
Die sehen alle immer aus,
die Dinger, was die da benutzen.
I was not able to communicate with the boards.
Ui Design aus der Hölle, oder?
You see,
it also uses a serial port
for communication
for which the datasheet gives you
lots of commands.
Alles klar.
But no matter what I tried,
the board never responded to any of them.
Even while replicating
the exact same settings
from the datasheet,
the board refused to work for me.
Which is a shame,
but this way I sadly cannot
recommend it.
Although it initially sounded promising.
And that brings us
to the end of this episode.
And once again,
luckily for me,
there were quite a few hidden gems
that you should consider checking out.
And do not worry,
I have lots more promising candidates
laying around for the next episode.
So, next!
Aber ich kann es nur nochmal wiederholen.
Wer Elektronikteile kaufen will,
jetzt mehr als eins,
der ist bei AliExpress wirklich gut dabei.
Der ist bei AliExpress wirklich gut dabei.
Es gibt viele Sachen auch bei Amazon
oder sonst wie in Deutschland zu kaufen.
Aber das ist,
gerade was Microcontroller angeht,
ist es viel, viel teurer.
Lass uns das mal vergleichen.
Wir holen uns zum Beispiel
mal einen ESP32.
Also das Board hier.
So,
kostaktuell,
kaum lieferbar sogar.
Hier.
3 Stück für 25 Euro.
AliExpress.
3 Stück für
1,80 Euro.
Oder so.
Das scheint mir ein bisschen sehr billig zu sein.
Das glaube ich aber kaum.
Zumindest gibt es anscheinend hier
2 Stück
für 3 Euro.
Also wie dem auch sei, es ist auf jeden Fall billiger.
Ja, na gut.
Aber es ist immer noch billiger als wenn du es
bei Amazon oder sonst wo bestellst.
Der einzige Vorteil,
den Amazon hat, ist natürlich,
dass die Bestellung meistens ein bisschen schneller
geht als bei AliExpress.
Aber AliExpress selbst, das muss auch keinen Monat
mehr dauern, bis Sachen bei euch eintreffen.
Die haben ja mittlerweile Warenlager
in EU, also in
Spanien haben die beispielsweise, Niederlande,
Frankreich,
weiß nicht, ob sie auch welche in Deutschland haben. Also sie verschicken ja oftmals
schon
hier irgendwo aus Europa.
Das heißt, du musst dir um Zoll und sowas
auch keine Gedanken machen.
Und das ist richtig, wobei ich sage,
was ich sagen muss, das hatte ich bisher bei AliExpress auch.
Ich wurde einmal versucht zu
scammen bei AliExpress, da hat AliExpress
direkt gesagt, Geld zurück.
Okay.
Habe ich noch nicht bestellt dort.
Aber ESP32 sind höchstwahrscheinlich
kein Fake, weil ESP32 sind ja
China-Chinesen-Chips.
Ja, machen sie. Aber an der Stelle
müssen sie ja schon Einfuhrgebühr, müssen sie ja schon
bezahlen.
Nur dir kann es dann egal sein.
Ja, also AliExpress hat es lange Zeit
gerne gemacht, die haben die Sachen über Holland
verschickt und dann war es dann halt
versandt in der EU. Die haben das quasi von
China nach Holland und von Holland
beziehungsweise von Niederlanden dann
innerhalb der EU verschickt.
Da musste man sich mit Zollsachen
nicht rumschlagen.
Was auch gut ist, denn ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte
bisher bei AliExpress nie
Probleme, was in Holland so einfach ist.
Die haben einen großen Hafen.
Und vielleicht sind die, was die Abfertigung
angeht, besser. Keine Ahnung. Zumindest ist Niederlande
sehr beliebt für Einfuhr
aus China. Spanien angeblich auch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Hamburg und so aussieht.
Wollten die
China-Chinesen nicht im Hamburger Hafen
sogar Teile von kaufen?
Die sind teilweise sogar noch schneller, wenn es hier
Warenlager in der EU ist.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes
hier zu bieten?
Die neue Arbeitswelt der Gen Z.
Da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder ist diese Reportage
von irgendwelchen Ultra-Boomern
erstellt, die erzählen, dass
es ja nicht sein kann, dass sie nicht so viel
arbeiten wollen. Oder vielleicht jemand in meinem
Alter, der das ein bisschen realistischer sieht.
Ich habe übrigens das richtiges, absolutes
Lost-Comment erhalten unter
meinem letzten Video auf YouTube.
Hallo Leute.
Gestern irgendwo.
Ja.
Sowas in der Richtung. Gab es ein paar Leute, die Kommentare
drunter geschrieben haben.
Wenn Versager darüber reden, warum sie Versager
sind. Ich bin ja froh,
dass er so das krasse
Crimeset-Mindset, High-Performer-Mindset
hat und uns das
unter den YouTube-Comments alle mitteilen muss.
Die Leute
immer, Mann.
Der einzige Grund, wie ich mir das vorstellen kann,
ist,
die kriegen selbst nichts geschissen
und haten jetzt dafür rum,
dass andere mehr geschissen bekommen.
So, mal gucken, was die hier
in der...
Ist das überhaupt
was deutsches?
Oder ist das was österreichisches?
Oder was schweizerisches?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Oder F1?
Die Österreicher sind am Start.
Okay, mal gucken, wie es in Österreich abgeht.
Aber wahrscheinlich
haben die da genauso wenig Bock,
ähm,
50 Stunden die Woche
für kaum Kohle zu arbeiten.
Für plus minus 0 am Monatsende
auf dem Konto.
Ja, gell?
Er könnte in der
Zwischenzeit auch...
Der hat das überhaupt nicht mehr nötig,
High-Performer-Arbeit zu leisten.
Der hat 5000 Euro passives Einkommen
im Monat. Der hat einfach verstanden,
wie es funktioniert.
Der ist halt schon auf den
Mount Everest angekommen. Wir nicht.
Sind einfach
viel zu low.
Morgens, während er auf dem Klo sitzt,
hat er die 5k passiv schon gemacht.
Okay, schauen wir uns das mal an,
warum die GenZ nicht
arbeiten möchte.
Oder warum auch immer, ich weiß ja nicht,
was die uns hier sagen wollen.
Wurde mir letztens empfohlen.
Das ist ja ein Thema, wo ich immer sage,
also meine Meinung dazu kennt ihr ja.
Ich bin der Meinung, die machen das richtig.
Erstens
muss man mal von den technologischen Entwicklungen
der letzten 50 Jahre auch mal was haben.
Ja, also sprich
weniger arbeiten, ohne dass es einem scheiße geht dabei.
Und zweitens, warum
sollte man mehr arbeiten als notwendig,
wenn man genug Geld verdient,
um alles das machen zu können, worauf man Bock hat.
Oder sagen wir mal so, um guten Kompromiss
zu finden.
Ich kann das meiste machen,
worauf ich Bock habe, ohne mich kaputt zu arbeiten.
Warum sollte man das nicht machen?
Weil man lebt ja nicht dafür, nur arbeiten zu gehen.
Man lebt nicht dafür,
quasi 8 Stunden am Tag und sonst nichts
von der Welt rum
mitzubekommen.
Also insofern
finde ich das vollkommen verständlich,
wie die Leute das machen.
In manchen Berufen geht halt
weniger Arbeit nicht. Warum?
Warum sollte das nicht gehen?
Weil die könnten dort ohne Probleme
auch zwei Leute einstellen, anstatt
einen und beide arbeiten nur
halbzeit. Ja, ich verstehe, dass das
gewisse Herausforderungen birgt
und ich verstehe auch, dass das
managementtechnisch für viele Unternehmen
sicherlich nicht so einfach ist, aber die werden
schlicht und ergreifend mit der Zeit gehen müssen.
Wenn die Leute suchen und keine Leute finden,
gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder sie machen dicht,
sie geben sich mit
geringer qualifizierten,
weniger guten Leuten zufrieden,
können sie auch machen,
was dann aber im Endeffekt auch
auf Dauer vielleicht Probleme macht,
oder sie machen den dritten,
sie machen
die dritte Taktik,
sie kacken die Leute mit Geld zu,
dass die halt so viel schaffen.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Also ich glaube,
das muss man etwas differenzieren an der Stelle.
Es gibt sicherlich Berufe,
da ist das jetzt unter den aktuellen
Bedingungen
nicht möglich.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es prinzipiell
nicht möglich ist. Moin Patrick.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn man sich mal anguckt,
aktuell so in der alten Krankenpflege
und sowas, so nach dem Motto,
man hat drei Leute am Start,
für jede Schicht einer und das reicht
gerade so, dass die Leute nicht sterben.
Dann verstehe ich, wenn man sagt,
man kann aktuell nicht weniger arbeiten.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass das prinzipiell
nicht gehen würde. Man könnte ja
einfach die Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern
und indem man anfängt, mehr Leute einzustellen,
dann wäre allen geholfen.
Na gut, außer denen, die es bezahlen müssen
natürlich.
Möglich ist das sicherlich alles.
Ist halt die Frage, ob man gewillt
dazu ist, das zu machen.
Okay, mal gucken, was sie
dazu sagen.
Ich möchte auf keinen Fall 40 Stunden arbeiten.
Ja, kann ich verstehen.
Wer will das schon, ne?
Die Jungen sind faul und respektlos.
Ah, das sind ein paar Österreicher hier am Start.
Das hört man gleich.
Wetten, dass das da genauso ist, wie bei uns?
Also,
das ist doch ganz einfach, Adi.
Das kann durchaus
sein, dass sich da nie was ändert.
Unter der Voraussetzung,
dass sie immer genug Leute finden
oder im Zweifelsfall auch mit schlechteren Leuten
zufrieden sind, die das machen wollen.
Solange das der Fall ist, wird sich
da nichts ändern.
Sollten die keine Leute mehr finden,
dann müssen sie sich
anpassen, weil ansonsten
gehen sie pleite und können dicht machen.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, was wollen die machen?
Wollen sie sich anpassen oder wollen sie pleite gehen?
Oder wollen sie dicht machen?
Ja, gut, dann machen sie halt dicht.
Das ist halt auch eine Möglichkeit.
Die Boomer brauchen keine Angst vor
ihrer Rente zu haben, weil die kriegen noch ein bisschen was.
Die Leute, die Angst um ihre Rente
haben müssen, ist meine Generation.
Die darf nämlich auch schön ihr ganzes Leben
lang schaffen und kriegt kaum noch Rente.
Deswegen bleibt mir ja nichts anderes übrig,
wie
noch zusätzlich Stonks zu machen.
Ja, Anpassungen dauern
immer ein bisschen und
man darf jetzt auch, denke ich, nicht
rein den Arbeitgebern oder den Arbeitnehmern
da so die Schuld in die Schuhe schieben.
Es geht auch immer ein bisschen um
gesetzliche Rahmenbedingungen und was
da möglich ist. Also man kann da sicherlich Anreize
und Rahmenbedingungen so setzen,
dass sich das verbessert.
Aber
gut, das
muss sich die nächsten Jahre überall zeigen.
Und ich glaube nicht,
dass die Generation, die jetzt anfängt
zu arbeiten oder gerade eingestiegen ist ins Arbeiten,
dass die dann auch großartig umdenken.
Weil im Ernst, wer
fängt mit dieser Einstellung an
zu arbeiten und denkt sich nach fünf
Jahre arbeiten, ach ja, jetzt hätte ich
aber schon Bock, 40 Stunden zu arbeiten.
Das ist ja Blödsinn. Das macht ja keiner.
Das ist eher umgedreht. Die Leute fangen mit 40 Stunden
zu arbeiten an und denken sich dann, oh, da habe ich aber gar keinen Bock drauf.
Aber die fangen ja schon mit der Einstellung
an, was ich auch vollkommen, äh,
nachvollziehen kann. Ich bin ja mittlerweile auch
an dem Punkt angekommen.
Und ich mache ja auch Werbung, wo es nur
geht dafür, dass die Leute weniger
arbeiten, wenn sie mit der Kohle hinkommen.
Das ist so, ja.
So sieht es aus. Wer nicht mit der Zeit geht,
geht mit der Zeit. Korrekt.
Ich denke, es sollte jedem frei stehen,
das zu machen, was er will.
Aber unbezahlt ist schon mal
generell irgendwie eine blöde
Idee. Es sei denn, es ist dein Unternehmen.
Du bist der Chef, dann ist es natürlich
was anderes. Aber ansonsten,
würde ich nie unbezahlte Überstunden machen
mehr. Selbst wenn es Spaß macht.
Hast du vier Tage
oder einfach weniger am Tag? Ich habe
vier Tage. Also, ich habe 80%
Arbeitszeit. Ich könnte
sicherlich auch fünf Tage arbeiten
und dann irgendwie nur, irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
fünfeinhalb oder
was auch immer, wieviel das rechnerisch wäre.
Ja. Könnte ich bestimmt
auch machen. Oder sechs Stunden oder so.
Aber mache ich nicht.
Okay. Ja,
also, das ist ein Punkt,
hast du noch? Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Also, was witzig ist, bei uns gibt es
gerade zwei Leute in Altersteilzeit, die sind auch
bald weg. Das heißt, wir brauchen gleich demnächst
noch ein paar Linux-Five
Heads bei uns.
Gucken, ob ich da noch ein paar Leute vermitteln
kann, die ich kenne.
Immer direkt Prämie abgreifen.
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Muss ich mal gucken. Also, sollte ich mal irgendwann
wirklich sagen, ey,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen nervt es mich.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen nervt
es mich dann. Ja, ist sicherlich eine Option,
aber aktuell denke ich da eigentlich nicht dran.
Ja, und das ist tatsächlich auch was, wo ich sagen muss,
da schlagen
wir schon ein bisschen über die Stränge.
Also, wisst ihr, was eines der ersten Sachen,
als das Thema Chat-GPT und AI
so im Mainstream aufgekommen ist?
Wisst ihr, was eines der ersten Sachen war,
was ich dort von irgendeinem Politiker oder
Politikerin war, das glaube ich, gehört habe?
Noch, wo es überhaupt nicht um die Technik
geht. Das erste war, was ich gehört habe,
ist, ja, wir müssen irgendwie einen
Ethik-Rat oder irgendwie sowas in der
Richtung gründen für
AI-Entwicklung. Und wenn ich sowas
schon höre, denke ich mir, okay,
wir schaffen wieder irgendwelche gut bezahlten
Stellen, die
einfach nur Kohle verbraten
und die wahrscheinlich niemand brauche.
Egal. So, gucken wir uns mal an, was
die Gen Z so
macht.
Die sieht aber schon ein bisschen älter
aus als Gen Z, oder?
Keinen Fall 40 Stunden arbeiten.
Die Jungen sind faul und respektlos,
sagen die Älteren. Die jungen Generationen
haben mir die Frage gestellt, wenn ich andere Prioritäten
habe, wer finanziert mir die?
Naja, sie selbst.
Sie selbst finanzieren
die. Die gehen ja arbeiten. Die haben aber
für sich entschieden, dass es ihnen reicht, was sie
bekommen und nicht 40 Stunden oder
sonst was arbeiten müssen, um noch ein bisschen mehr zu
bekommen. Die finanzieren sich das doch genauso
selbst wie er.
Verschwenden ihr Leben in einem 40-Stunden-Job,
der sie nicht glücklich macht. Die Gen Z sagt,
gar keinen Bock. Ich frage mich,
wird die Generation Z den Arbeitsmarkt
revolutionieren? Wir sind halt die Generation
der Zukunft. Die werden den Arbeitsmarkt
genauso revolutionieren wie alle Generationen
davor. Das wird sich anpassen müssen,
wer da bleiben will.
Oder nimmt sie sich doch ein bisschen
zu wichtig. Ich besuche Leonie
bei ihrer Arbeit. Sie ist Social Media
Managerin. Was sonst?
Also,
ich hab,
ich will meinen Rant vom letzten Mal nicht wieder
wiederholen, ja.
Aber Online-Marketing-
Influencer-
Marketing-Sachen, Leute,
das ist der größte Müllhaufen
an Leuten, die ich kenne.
Sagt jetzt natürlich nichts über sie. Ich weiß nicht, was das
für eine Agentur ist. Aber ich hab da so
viel Bodensatz an Leuten kennengelernt
in den letzten über 10
Jahren.
Also, ich
kann da immer kein gutes Haar
dran lassen. Das ist wirklich, das sind meistens
Leute, die lügen dich an,
verkaufen dir morgens ihr
Oma und
mittags verarschen sie dich so.
Also, ich bin
prinzipiell skeptisch,
wenn irgendjemand
sagt, er ist
im Influencer-Marketing und Online-
Marketing unterwegs. Da gehen bei mir
direkt so im Kopf
an, so nach dem Motto, okay,
das ist jemand, der dich,
ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, direkt bescheißt.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal,
Digitalwerk.
Also, ich sag nichts,
by the way, ihr müsst mich nicht verklagen
oder so.
Ich sag nichts über euch, sondern
nur meine Erfahrungen, die ich bisher mit Online-
Marketing gemacht hab. Allerdings,
es gibt durchaus auch gescheite Leute. Ich hatte
beispielsweise nie Probleme mit den
Marketing-Leuten von Hetzner oder damals
auch von Elgato oder sowas. Es gibt schon durchaus
faire
und
normale Business-Leute
da, keine Frage. Aber darüber, wie ich da
hingegangen bin,
habe ich mich nicht wirklich
mit den Online-Marketing-Leuten
beschäftigt.
Also, das ist ein
ganz wichtiger Teil. Online-Marketing ist
einfach nur kompletter,
menschlicher Bodensatz.
Die kannst du komplett vergessen.
Okay, was machen die denn hier so?
Die bauen Autos mit
Lüftern, mit Zotac-Lüftern.
Geschäftsfelder.
ADTF, was ist das?
Ja, das sieht auch schon vielmehr
nach Marketing-Stells aus,
diese Webseite.
Die Webseite laggt.
Leute, habt ihr das gesehen?
Guck mal.
Alter, ist das Absicht?
Nee. Alter, mein Browser hat 90%
CPU-Auslastung.
In Chrome ist es, okay, das ist 3D
beschleunigt und mein Chromium hat damit Probleme.
Der ganze Browser laggt, Mann.
Wow, wow, wow.
Das ist keine gute Idee, seine Webseite
komplett irgendwie
2D-accelerated, was auch immer,
zu rendern. Lass mal kurz
gucken. Chrome? Ja.
Haben die den Kryptomaner im Hintergrund
laufen?
Jesus. Boah, Alter,
das laggt ja erst. Fuck!
Okay, jetzt geht's wieder.
Ich hab keine
Ahnung, was die eigentlich machen.
Die Webseite ist ja pepega hoch 10, Mann.
Ja, im Chrome läuft's
bei mir auch flüssig, Chromium hat Probleme.
Ach, guck mal, die machen Suchmaschinenoptimierung,
Social Google und Ads Development.
Was machen die denn?
Gibt's irgendwas, was die nicht
machen?
Die machen Frontend-Entwicklung, UI,
Social Media,
die machen einfach
alles. Boah, die haben sogar einen YouTube-Channel.
Okay, also so 0815
Marketing-Agentur
mit ganz viel Zeug noch
dabei. Egal, darum ging's ja in dem Video
gar nicht.
Was ist denn mit der
Reaktion, die da ist?
Ja, es ist ja, wie gesagt,
die Reaktion ist eher
ein bisschen
blöd.
Ja, die Reaktion ist
eher ein bisschen
ein bisschen
blöd.
Ja, sie sagen, dass sie
ihre Reaktionen
und wir können am besten unser krasses Networking, Socialising, Marketing lokal machen,
deswegen macht da sicher keiner Homeoffice. Weiß man ja nie.
... von ihren bisherigen Jobs.
Ja, für mich war eigentlich schon immer klar, dass ich sofort eigentlich in die Arbeitswelt
eintauchen möchte. Ich habe natürlich so ein Reisejahr quasi dazwischen gehabt,
das wollte ich schon und habe Australien und Südostasien eine Reise gemacht,
das war schon wichtig für mich.
Nach der Matura beginnt Leonie zu...
Da sieht man schon mal, ich bin nicht kompatibel mit Marketingleuten in der Weltanschauung, so.
Ich glaube für mich wäre so eine Weltreise das Schlimmste, was ich machen könnte.
Und so neun Jahre, nice, ich reise durch die Welt und treffe mich da mit ganz vielen Leuten.
Das ist schon mal das komplette Gegenteil.
Wenn du mich fragst, Max, was willst du machen?
Eine Weltreise und dich mit möglichst vielen Leuten treffen oder im Keller sitzen und was programmieren?
Dann würde ich sagen...
Ich sitze lieber im Keller.
...zu arbeiten. Heute erinnert sie sich an ihre Anfangszeit zurück.
Und habe dann 40 Stunden gearbeitet tatsächlich.
Das war anfangs auch ein echter Schock, muss ich sagen.
Ja, das geht jedem so.
Ich habe keine Zeit mehr. Ich habe überhaupt keine Zeit mehr für irgendwas.
Und wisst ihr, was das richtig Dumme daran ist?
Wenn es Winter ist, du gehst aus dem Haus, wenn es dunkel ist und du kommst heim, wenn es schon wieder dunkel ist.
Aber jetzt wird es schwierig.
Weltreise oder im Keller C++ programmieren?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Das müsste ich mir mal genauer überlegen.
C++ programmieren ein Jahr lang ist schon eine ziemliche Strafe, ja?
Dann würde ich Rust lernen.
Okay, weiter.
Mein Privatleben hat da echt voll drunter gelitten.
Sei es allein nur zum Arzt gehen oder Dinge erledigen.
Paket bei der Post abholen. Man hätte nie gedacht, dass es mal Probleme macht.
...dich sehen und der will dich sehen.
Und da musst du hin und da ein Brunch und hier und so weiter.
Okay, wenn man sozial veranlagt ist, dann macht man ab und zu mal da einen Brunch oder nicht.
Oder alternativ, man macht das so wie ich.
Man sitzt für die Arbeit acht Stunden vorm Rechner.
Und dann sitzt man YouTube und Twitch noch mal acht Stunden vorm Rechner.
Und dann geht man schlafen.
Und zwischendurch geht man mal eineinhalb, zwei Stunden draußen sich ein bisschen bewegen.
Aber das reicht nicht. Dann reicht die Zeit nicht.
Also realistisch betrachtet.
Okay, lass mal kurz überlegen.
Ich setze von sieben bis ungefähr 15.30, 16 Uhr vorm Rechner für die Arbeit.
Dann von 16 Uhr bis 17.30 oder so.
Manchmal auch 18 Uhr.
Einmal täglich Sport.
Das geht sonst nicht.
Leute, ich habe das gemerkt.
Ich habe sonst zu viel Kopfschmerzen, Rücken und alles mögliche.
Also eineinhalb Stunden.
Also eineinhalb Stunden Bewegung.
Muss sein.
Und dann sitze ich eigentlich bis 22 Uhr, 22.30 Uhr wieder vorm Computer.
Und mache YouTube-Stells, Twitch-Stells oder irgendwie Bastelkram.
Ja.
Ja, ich kann es auch nicht verstehen.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht, wie man das aushält.
Ich hatte letztens vor ein paar Wochen so einen Einführungs-Neue-Mitarbeiter-Event.
Und das waren sieben Stunden Socializen.
Das war ganz schlimm auf der Arbeit, Mann.
Danach musste ich erst mal abends hier ein bisschen Stream machen und mich darüber auskotzen.
Egal, wir müssen das Video mal fertig gucken, Leute.
Das Video geht nur neun Minuten.
Und wir sind jetzt bei einer Minute.
Ich labere nur sinnlos rum.
Also, okay.
Was hat Leonie denn gerade erzählt?
Dass sie nicht zum Brunch gehen kann.
Der will dich sehen.
Und der will dich sehen.
Und da musst du hin.
Und da ein Brunch.
Und hier.
Da ein Brunch.
Das hört sich so an.
So nach dem Motto.
Da ist keiner voll.
Und hier gehen wir essen.
Hier gehen wir Mittag essen.
Und da müssen wir irgendwie Party gehen.
Und da müssen wir uns mit dem treffen.
Und so.
Boah, das sind einfach so Marketing-Leute.
So Social-Networking-Marketing-Leute.
Das ist einfach so.
Das ist ein Lebensstil, der ist nicht kompatibel zu meinem.
Und meiner wahrscheinlich nicht zu den ihren.
Aber ich denke mir, jeder, was ihm Freude bringt und Spaß macht und ihn glücklich macht,
wenn Leonie das gefällt, ist es doch vollkommen okay.
Nur weil das für mich nichts ist.
Oder weil das für uns teilweise hier nichts ist.
Ist ja in Ordnung.
Hier und so weiter.
Also.
Ja.
Unmöglich.
Das stimmt.
40 Stunden Woche Zeit demnach nicht mehr zeitgemäß.
Die Leute haben gelebt für die Arbeit.
Das war einfach das Ding.
Meine Oma zum Beispiel, die sagt immer, die Leute sind ja nicht ausgegangen.
Ist ja niemand essen gegangen.
Heutzutage sehen die Leute das anders.
Okay, sorry.
Ich muss nochmal unter...
Die sieht aus...
Das ist jetzt nicht das, was ich sagen wollte.
Aber es fällt mir gerade ein.
Die sieht aus wie die Frau von Prinz Harry.
Ein bisschen, oder?
Ich kenne mich in dieser Adelsgeschichte nicht wirklich aus.
Das ist, glaube ich, die einzige, die ich kenne.
Aber die sieht ein bisschen aus wie die Frau von Prinz Harry.
Nicht?
Naja.
Okay, dann nicht, Chad.
Chad, wenn ihr das sagt, dann nicht.
Okay.
Was ich eigentlich...
Was ich...
Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte...
Moment.
Och, die sieht ja schon ein bisschen ähnlich aus.
Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ist...
Sie hat ja gerade gesagt...
Sie hat ja gerade erzählt, was ihr Opa und ihre Oma und so immer erzählt hat.
Also, es gibt eine Sache, die hat mein Opa immer erzählt.
Und da merkt man einfach, dass der aus einer anderen Zeit kommt.
Mein Opa kommt aus einer Zeit...
Also, ich meine jetzt nicht Zweiter Weltkrieg und sowas.
Oder mein Opa kam aus einer Zeit, da war das vollkommen undenkbar, dass man zu seinem Chef
gesagt hat, oh nee, ich habe jetzt Feierabend, ich gehe jetzt heim.
Oder...
Oder generell gesagt hat...
Oh, das ist jetzt aber keine so gute Idee.
Anders wäre besser.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Das...
Mein Opa kommt aus einer Zeit, was sein Chef gesagt hat, war Gesetz.
Was irgendwie damals sein Lehrer gesagt hat, war Gesetz.
Was die Frau gesagt hat...
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Wenn die Oma gesagt hat, wir müssen das jetzt machen, dann wurde das gemacht, so nach dem
Motto.
Also, mein Opa war halt sehr davon überzeugt, so, derjenige, der quasi über ihm steht und
was zu sagen hat, ist wichtig.
Wichtiger.
Und das muss man alles so befolgen und sowas.
Zumindest, der hat immer...
Der hat immer eine Sache zu mir gesagt, mein Opa.
Und zwar, das war schon ganz lang.
Solange ich denken kann.
Und wahrscheinlich hat er das auch schon beim Kindergarten gesagt.
Und zwar hat mein Opa immer gesagt, so ey, warte mal ab, bis du in die Schule kommst.
Also, was weiß ich.
Ich habe irgendwie...
Ich habe meinen Opa genervt mit irgendwas oder ich habe ihm gesagt, es ist Blödsinn,
was er erzählt oder was auch immer.
Zumindest immer, wenn mein Opa der Meinung war, du wirst später mal nicht immer deinen
Kopf durchsetzen können, dann hat mein Opa immer den gleichen Spruch gebracht.
Der hat immer gesagt, warte mal ab, bis du in die Schule kommst, dann wirst du noch schwer
Kordel nachgeben müssen.
Das wird man wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich verstehen.
Kordel ist sowas wie Schnur auf oder Strick oder sowas.
Das heißt so viel wie übersetzt, du wirst nicht immer deinen Kopf durchsetzen können.
Er hat immer gesagt, warte mal ab, bis du in die Schule kommst, dann wirst du schwer Kordel
nachgeben müssen.
So, dann bin ich in die Schule gekommen und irgendwie, weiß nicht, war das nie so richtig
der Fall.
Dann hat er gemeint, ja, warte mal ab, bis du in die weiterführende Schule kommst, dann
wirst du noch schwer Kordel nachgeben müssen.
War wieder nicht so der Fall.
Warte mal ab, bis du deine Ausbildung machst, dann wirst du noch schwer Kordel nachgeben
müssen.
Ja, warte mal, bis du richtig arbeiten gehst, dann wirst du sehen, da kannst du nicht alles
so machen.
Dann wirst du noch schwer Kordel nachgeben müssen.
Und dieser Punkt ist bis jetzt nie eingetreten.
Selbstverständlich in gewisser Weise.
Ganz Unrecht hat er nicht.
Du kannst nicht immer hundertprozentig das machen, worauf du Bock hast.
Aber es ist ein Unterschied zu dem, wie es mein Opa gesehen hat.
Mein Opa war jemand so nach dem Motto, wenn der Chef sagt, jetzt springst du aus dem Fenster,
dann springst du aus dem Fenster, übertrieben gesagt.
Okay, jetzt hätte er wahrscheinlich gesagt, warte mal ab, bis du in Rente gehst.
Keine Ahnung.
Mein Opa gibt es ja leider nicht.
Übrigens, ich habe mal vor Jahren ein Video mit meinem Opa aufgenommen.
Ja.
Nichts Sinnvolles dabei.
Ich lege kein Interesse darauf, in das Gelaber der großen Menge zu kommen.
Das ist mein Opa.
Ja.
Er legt keinen Wert darauf, in das Gelaber der großen Menge zu kommen.
Alles klar.
Und solche Dinger.
Zumindest, das war halt so sein Standardspruch, den er immer gebracht hat.
Du wirst auch Schwerkordel nachgeben müssen.
In gewisser Weise, ganz Unrecht hat er nicht.
Natürlich kann man nicht immer hundertprozentig das machen, was man will.
Aber in der heutigen Zeit ist es nicht mehr so, dass alles automatisch Gesetz ist.
Die Arbeitswelt hat sich insofern schon ein bisschen verändert.
Es wird auch, sicherlich nicht überall, aber es wird oftmals auch geschätzt oder sogar verlangt, dass man Leute hat, die ein bisschen mitdenken.
Also nur, weil jetzt irgendjemand sagt, wir brauchen unbedingt, stell dir vor, der Abteilungsleiter kommt zu dir und du bist Netzwerktechniker und sagst, hey, wir haben ein Projekt, das hat Zugriffsprobleme, mach jetzt sofort mal Firewall-Freischaltung.
Und dann sagst du, ja, aber wenn wir die Firewall-Freischaltung machen, ist das keine so gute Idee.
Denn dann haben wir public im Internet auf einmal acht Webserver hängen.
So, und dann wird der Abteilungsleiter entweder sagen, ist mir scheißegal, mach trotzdem.
Oder er wird sagen, na okay, ist vielleicht doch keine so gute Idee.
Natürlich ist es bei mir auch schon vorgekommen, dass er dann gesagt, also das ist jetzt ein Beispiel, ja.
Natürlich ist es bei mir auch schon vorgekommen, dass er dann gesagt hat, ja, dann mach trotzdem.
Wie gesagt, ihr könnt es auf alle möglichen Sachen übertragen.
Und dann denke ich mir an der Stelle immer, das ist ja kein Kordel nachgeben in dem Sinn.
Das ist, ich habe gesagt, das ist eine scheiß Idee und ich bin fein raus, wenn dann wirklich scheiße passiert.
Weil wenn scheiße passiert, kann ich sagen, naja, wer hätte auch schon damit rechnen können,
dass das Freischalten von Port 80 auf Internet-Server eine blöde Idee ist.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich euch nicht gesagt.
Also deswegen, das, was mein Opa da propheziert hat, ist nie eingetreten in der krassen Weise, wie er es gesagt hat.
Aber natürlich zum Teil hatte er nicht gesagt.
Zum Teil hatte er nicht Unrecht.
So, okay, jetzt habe ich keine Ahnung mehr, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Die Leute sind ja nicht ausgegangen.
Es ist ja niemand essen gegangen.
Das stimmt wohl auch.
Also ich glaube, gerade die Generation von meiner Oma, Opa, ich meine, die haben ja nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg das ja alles noch mit aufgebaut und sonst was.
Da war im Prinzip, wir haben ein Klo daheim, schon absoluter Luxus.
Und später, wir haben sogar ein Auto oder einen Fernseher, war absoluter Luxus.
Da sind wir heute schon ein bisschen verwöhnt.
Das stimmt schon.
Aber man muss halt auch mal sehen, es hat sich viel getan, die letzten 80 Jahre.
Und wir haben viele neue Technologie am Start, die letzten 80 Jahre über.
Wir haben auch vieles verbessert.
Auch wenn in der heutigen Zeit es irgendwie im Trend ist, zu sagen, es ist alles scheiße und das ist so schlimm wie noch nie, hat man den Eindruck.
Aber es hat sich enorm vieles verbessert.
Die letzten 80 Jahre.
Sicherlich nicht alles.
Wir haben auch andere Probleme, aber es hat sich vieles verbessert im Vergleich zu früher.
Und gerade, was wir an technologischen Möglichkeiten haben, ich denke, irgendwann ist auch mal der Punkt gekommen, wo man das, wo man das irgendwie ausnutzen muss.
Wo man auch einfach mal sagen kann, okay, ich habe Hunger, ich bestelle mir jetzt was bei Lieferando.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr einkaufen zu gehen.
Ich lasse mir was, lasse mir vom Rewe was liefern.
Oder ach, ich gehe jetzt einfach mal um die Ecke was futtern.
Ich meine, das Durchschnittsgehalt ist die letzten so und so viel gestiegen.
Das kann man jetzt einfach mal machen.
Es hat sich ja auch vieles verbessert, die letzten 80 Jahre.
Also ich denke, der Vergleich zwischen den Generationen ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber ich denke, wir sind echt an dem Punkt angelangt, dass man jetzt mal sagen kann, wir sollten von der Technologie, die sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten entwickelt hat, auch langsam mal was haben.
Und nicht einfach 40 Stunden durcharbeiten.
Für Dinger.
Für Dinger, die nicht wirklich so relevant sind.
Und nicht wirklich wichtig sind.
Wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie viele Bullshit-Bürokratie-Jobs es mittlerweile gibt.
Die wahrscheinlich die nächsten Jahre über schlicht und ergreifend ersetzt werden durch irgendwelche Bots.
Egal, gucken wir mal weiter.
Heutzutage sehen die Leute das anders.
Vor allem eben die Leute aus meiner Generation.
Und da hat die Generation auch recht.
Und ich kann euch sagen, viele aus meiner Generation, ich bin ja Generation Y quasi.
Die sehen das auch so.
Meine Generation ist gespalten, was das angeht.
Viele sind noch so ein bisschen, viele in meiner Generation, in meinem Alter, jetzt so 38, 39, sag mal 35 bis 45 so die Generation.
Die ist da so ein bisschen gespalten.
Du hast welche, das sind die Ultra-Boomer vor dem Herrn, also die sind mehr Boomer als Boomer je sein könnten.
Und du hast welche wie ich, die ein bisschen mit der Zeit gegangen sind.
Die sitzen jetzt vorm Rechner und reden in Twitch-Emotes.
Oder auch irgendwas dazwischen.
Ich glaube, das hat sich so ein bisschen entschieden.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt, alles so in dem Dreh, würde ich sagen, so in dem Dreh 1995 rum.
1995 so in dem Dreh rum hat sich das alles entschieden.
Leute in meiner Generation, die damals aufgeschlossen waren, was Technik gegenüber angeht.
Internet, Computer daheim und solche Geschichten.
Die sind keine super krassen Boomer geworden.
Und werden es wahrscheinlich auch nie.
Weil die immer dank Internet und Technik so ein bisschen am Puls da sind.
Sicherlich, ich finde vieles auch schwachsinnig.
Ich habe beispielsweise, und das ist vielleicht ein bisschen der Boomer in mir.
Ich habe den Hype um TikTok nie so wirklich nachvollziehen können.
Oder auch, warum die Leute Snapchat verwenden, konnte ich nachvollziehen.
Weil sie dachten, man kann Nacktbilder verschicken, die sich automatisch wieder löschen.
Was ja schon ein Trugschluss war.
Und mittlerweile es ja sogar Sachen gibt, um Bilder zu realisieren.
Um Bilder zu recoveren und sowas.
Das habe ich nie so richtig verstanden.
Aber ich glaube, in meiner Generation hat sich das so alles ein bisschen entschieden.
So im 1995 rum.
Die, die damals Technologie, Internet, Computer daheim scheiße fanden.
Die sitzen heute wie die größten Boomer mit anderen Boomern zusammen beim Stammtisch.
Und erzählen, dass sie wissen, wie die Welt funktionieren müsste.
Wenn sie das sagen hätten, wäre die Welt viel besser.
So typische Stammtisch-Geschwätze.
Und es gibt so ein bisschen eher technologieinteressierte.
Generation Y-Leute wie mich.
Die halt durch Internet und Heimcomputer und vielleicht auch, weil sie in der IT arbeiten.
So ein bisschen immer so am Puls der Zeit mit sind.
Ich glaube, meine Generation ist da sehr gespalten in dieser Richtung.
Eine Sache, die mich ja persönlich auch immer schockiert, ist wie wenig Ahnung von Technologie, die diese Generation hier hat.
Ich dachte eigentlich früher, als ich angefangen habe mit Internet.
Computer und sowas.
Dass es überhaupt keine Diskussionen und Fragen mehr geben wird bei der nächsten Generation.
Wisst ihr, weil bei mir war das alles neu und auch sehr in den Kinderschuhen alles.
Und ich dachte mir so, okay, die Generation, die nach mir kommt.
Die wächst damit auf und für die ist es überhaupt gar kein Ding mehr.
Die Generation Z wird niemals fragen müssen, wie schließe ich mein DSL-Modem an.
Das machen die.
Das machen die quasi so schon im Kindergarten.
So nach dem Motto dachte ich damals.
Da habe ich allerdings falsch gedacht.
Generation Z hat heute ganz andere Probleme mit Technik.
Generation Z hat das entgegengesetzte Problem wie die Generation vor mir.
Die Generation vor mir hat das Problem oder teilweise auch noch die Leute in meiner Generation.
Die haben das Problem, für die war Technik was Neues.
Und die haben da nie Zugang für gefunden und waren halt komplett lost.
Heute ist es so, die Leute sind von Anfang an mit Technik aufgewachsen.
Die funktioniert.
Und das ist das Problem.
Die mussten sich nie mit Technik auseinandersetzen, die nicht funktioniert.
Und wenn mal was nicht funktioniert, sind die auch komplett lost.
Die haben keinen Plan von.
Wenn ich mir heute angucke, geht mal Leute gutefrage.net und sucht mal nach PC-Problemen.
Okay, gute Frage ist immer kein gutes Beispiel dafür, weil das komplett voll ist von Ultra-PP-Gas überhaupt.
Die sind komplett lost teilweise.
Okay, so, jetzt müssen wir aber echt mal das Video gucken.
Es gibt einfach so viele Dinge, die man ausprobieren kann, machen kann, statt zu arbeiten.
Das ist wahr, das würde ich auch unterstreichen, ja.
Man kann auch einfach nicht arbeiten, anstatt zu arbeiten und machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Eine Einstellung, die bei älteren Generationen oft auf Unverständnis stößt.
Meine Wahrnehmung von dem Ganzen ist, dass die jüngeren Mitarbeiter im Grunde genommen ziemlich schwer zu motivieren sind, überhaupt Arbeit und mehr Leistung zu bringen.
Ein Geist.
Man liegt vielleicht daran, dass das, was das Unternehmen sagt.
Oder dass die Arbeit, die sie haben, halt schlicht und ergreifend langweilig ist oder halt wie vor 50 Jahren und keiner Bock drauf hat, das zu machen.
Ich kann euch, ich kann euch sagen, es gibt durchaus Arbeiten, die mich auch nicht motivieren.
Ich meine, wenn das halt so ein Ultra-Boomer-Unternehmen ist, muss man sich doch nicht wundern, dass die aktuelle Generation da wenig motiviert ist, die Arbeit durchzuführen.
Generationenkonflikte.
Ganz davon abgesehen haben die sicherlich auch gelernt, dass nur, wenn man sich reinhängt alleine, das nicht zwangsläufig zu mehr Bezahlung führen muss.
Gerade in so richtig krassen Boomer-Unternehmen ist es halt so, dass sie bei vielen modernen Sachen komplett den Anschluss verloren haben.
Also beziehungsweise auch bei ein bisschen moderneren Denkweisen den Anschluss verloren haben.
Zum Beispiel.
Ein Punkt, den es bei ganz vielen so Oldschool-Boomer-Unternehmen gibt.
Das ist das Problem.
Der einzige Weg, Karriere zu machen, ist Management.
Und das ist, finde ich, komplett der falsche Ansatz.
Das haben viele etwas modernere, gerade ein bisschen mehr auf Technologie setzende Unternehmen verstanden.
Es macht keinen Sinn, die einzige Karrieremöglichkeit zu bieten, ins Management zu gehen.
Weil gute Techniker sind nicht zwangsläufig gute Manager.
Umgedreht selbstverständlich auch nicht.
Ich würde sogar sagen.
Ein Bruchteil guter Techniker sind gute Manager.
Das heißt, es macht wenig Sinn, nur weil jemand super Five-Header ist und der beste Programmierer ist in der Firma.
Der beste Entwickler in dem Unternehmen ist.
Den auf einmal zum Teamleiter für die Entwicklung zu machen.
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Viele etwas modernere Unternehmen haben das verstanden.
Aber gerade viele alteingesessene Boomer-Unternehmen.
Nicht.
So.
Das Problem ist jetzt natürlich, dass der Techniker, der der beste Programmierer im Unternehmen ist, sicherlich ja auch eine Karriereperspektive haben will.
Und wenn man ihm sagt.
Hey, die einzige Möglichkeit, dass du bei uns mehr Geld verdienst, ist, Teamleiter zu werden.
Dann wird er sagen.
Leckt mich.
Ich will kein Teamleiter werden.
Entweder sagt er dann.
Ich mache das.
Ist ein schlechter Teamleiter.
Oder aber er sagt.
Okay, ich sehe hier für mich keine Karrieremöglichkeiten und sucht das weiter und sucht sich ein anderes Unternehmen.
So.
Das wird im Endeffekt passieren.
Deswegen haben viele etwas moderner denkendere Unternehmen.
Nee, das ist nicht.
Das Peter-Prinzip ist ja die Geschichte, damit wir befördern den, der am wenigsten das kann.
Etwas moderner denkendere Unternehmen sind dann schon auf die Idee gekommen.
Okay.
Wir müssen sowohl einen Management-Karriereweg bieten.
Als auch einen Fachtechnik-Karriereweg.
Was finde ich auch der richtige Ansatz ist.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel als Entwickler, wenn du, also die Standardsachen sind ja sowas in der Richtung, wie du fängst als Junior-Entwickler an.
Dann wirst du was auch immer Entwickler.
Irgendwann wirst du Senior-Entwickler.
Irgendwann wirst du vielleicht Experte-Entwickler.
Dann wirst du irgendwann mal Architekt.
Was auch immer.
Es gibt ja unterschiedlichste Sachen.
Und.
Das Wichtige daran ist, dass du bei diesem Karriereweg nicht auf einmal Personalverantwortung oder Personalmanagement-Sachen aufgedrückt bekommst.
Was du nicht machen willst.
Sondern du bekommst trotzdem mehr Verantwortung.
So ist das nicht.
Allerdings nicht in Form von klassischen Management-Aufgaben.
Du wirst dann vielleicht Hauptansprechpartner für eine bestimmte Technologie im Unternehmen.
Dass man sagt.
Okay.
Der Typ ist unser Experte für, was weiß ich, Authentifizierung oder sowas.
Und dann hast du dann an der Stelle jemanden sitzen, der ein guter Entwickler ist.
Der Ahnung hat von diesem Thema.
Und der quasi Ansprechpartner ist für alle möglichen Sachen.
Wenn einer nicht weiß, was Sache ist, dann zum Thema Authentifizierung.
Dann fragt er halt den.
Also sprich.
Die Variante, dass man nicht nur Karrieremöglichkeiten bietet in Form von Management.
Ist was, was so Oldschool-Boomer-Unternehmen wohl vollkommen fremd ist.
Aber was unglaublich wichtig ist.
Wenn man ein bisschen moderner denkt.
Wenn man auch nicht will, dass einem die feigen Leute wegrennen.
Ja.
So.
Weiter geht's.
Ups.
Das ist schön.
Das ist übrigens zu gutem.
Das ist auch ein Punkt.
Den hätte mein Opa komplett anders gesehen.
Ja.
Ich sehe das übrigens genauso wie du.
Die Aufgabe einer Führungskraft ist nicht einfach nur.
Ich bin der Chef und bin viel geiler als ihr.
Nein.
Die Aufgabe einer Führungskraft ist, seinen Job ordentlich zu machen.
Und die Aufgabe von der Technik ist.
Eine Führungskraft hat genauso einen sinnvollen Job, den es zu erledigen gilt.
Wie der Techniker, der zu dem Team gehört.
Früher war es eher so.
Ich bin der Chef.
Dementsprechend bin ich was Besseres.
Das ist noch so die Zeit von meinem Opa.
Das sollte aber.
Nie das Verhältnis von Techniker zu Manager sein.
Sicherlich ist das in diese Denkweise bestimmt noch in irgendwelchen Unternehmen verbreitet.
Aber ich bin der Meinung.
Alle haben einen wichtigen Job.
Unter anderem der Job eines Teamleiters ist es, die Leute ihre Arbeit machen zu lassen.
Also bzw. ihnen zu ermöglichen, dass sie ihre Arbeit machen.
Was auch heißt.
Zum Beispiel, wenn es Probleme gibt, die entsprechend zu kommunizieren.
Die Pläne, die oben weiter im Management getroffen werden.
Ordentlich dem Team gegenüber zu präsentieren.
Wenn es Probleme gibt, zu vermitteln.
Für Voraussetzungen zu sorgen, dass sie erfüllt sind, dass man gescheit arbeiten kann.
Und letztendlich, das ist eines der wichtigsten Punkte.
Vorgaben machen, auf die man sich verlassen kann.
Und dann, wenn die Leute halt irgendwas richtig machen anhand der Vorgaben.
Aber das trotzdem in die Hose geht.
Klar zu sagen, Leute, eure Vorgaben sind scheiße.
Nicht meine Leute, die das erledigt haben.
Also das sind so Dinge, die würde man von einem guten Teamleiter und einem guten Chef, unter anderem, gibt es sicherlich noch mehr, erwarten.
Und diese Sache mit, hier ist gut gelaufen und sowas.
Das ist was, das hätte mein Opa komplett anders gesehen.
Mein Opa hätte gesagt, so nach dem Motto, wir sind hier nicht im Kindergarten.
Hier wird nicht gelobt, hier wird gearbeitet.
So nach dem Motto.
Das ist auch, finde ich, eine typische Baustellenaussage.
Vielleicht schon.
Könnte ich mir sowas auch vorstellen.
Aber das Problem dabei ist, Eigenantrieb ist deutlich motivierender wie Schimpfen.
Wie soll ich das anders, versteht man, was ich meine?
Also, du kannst jetzt einem sagen, Alter, du bist so scheiße.
Wenn du weiter so scheiße bist, dann werfen wir dich raus.
So mal extrem gesagt, ja.
So.
Und man denkt sich dann so nach dem Motto.
Oh, der ist jetzt sicherlich super krass motiviert.
Weil, wenn es weiter scheiße oder wenn es irgendwie schlecht, dann weiß er, dass er raus geht.
Ne, das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Der wird wahrscheinlich eher komplett unmotiviert sein.
Und permanent sich überlegen, okay, wie kann ich was machen, dass es möglichst wenig auf mich zurückfällt.
Was dann oftmals wiederum dazu führt, dass er möglichst wenig macht.
Weil, wer nichts macht, kann auch nichts falsch machen.
Das heißt, es ist tatsächlich besser.
Man sagt den Leuten so nach dem Motto.
Oh, hier, du musst ja nicht sagen, du bist der geilste Ever, der je gelebt hat oder sowas.
Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Aber man kann durchaus sagen, wenn Projekte gut gelaufen sind, mal Ansprache halten und sagen, dass es gut gelaufen ist.
Oder, boah, das war jetzt hier seit fünf Monaten, hat es keiner rausgekriegt.
Ey, guck mal hier, was wir für schlaue Leute im Team haben.
Meine Leute haben das geschafft.
Und der und der hat sich da richtig reingehängt und so.
Also sprich, es ist immer besser, du motivierst die Leute, indem du sie halt quasi...
...bestärkst in dem, was sie machen, anstatt ihnen zu sagen, sie sind scheiße und sie werden sonst rausgeschmissen.
Also, dadurch, dass die Leute von sich aus motiviert sind, klappt das viel besser.
Das ist auch was, was viele Boomer-Unternehmen noch nicht verstanden haben.
Natürlich, es kann nicht immer nur alles ist toll geben.
Es gibt auch durchaus Sachen, die sind scheiße gelaufen.
Da kann man nicht sagen, ja, an sich ist das eigentlich alles ganz toll.
Aber wir haben hier noch leichte Unschärfen entdeckt.
Du musst schon sagen, wenn was kacke ist.
Aber wichtig ist, dass man es nicht so...
Dass man nicht sagt, so nach dem Motto, ey, hier ist was kaputt gegangen.
Und wir suchen jetzt nach drei Monaten, drei Monate lang den, der sich eingeloggt hat, um ihn danach zwei Wochen lang zu flamen.
Und täglich im Daily auszulachen, so nach dem Motto übertrieben gesagt.
Sondern wichtig ist zu sagen, ey, das ist scheiße.
Und lasst uns doch mal gucken.
Und lasst uns doch mal gucken, wie es dazu gekommen ist.
Also sprich, warum ist das System ausgefallen?
Wie ist es dazu gekommen, dass wir 24 Stunden Ausfall haben?
So, dann findet man sicherlich Fehler, die Mitarbeiter begangen haben.
Aber es ist ganz selten einer, der es verkackt hat.
Meistens ist es eine Verkettung von Umständen und oftmals auch eine Zusammenarbeit von Leuten.
Ja.
Der Erste hat nicht richtig gesagt, was er haben will.
Der Nächste hat es falsch interpretiert.
Der Dritte hat eine Anleitung copy-pasted, die jemand anderes geschrieben hat, die er nicht verstanden hat.
Das sind meistens so Verkettungen verschiedener Sachen.
Das ist selten einer, auf den man jetzt deuten kann.
Es gibt Ausnahmen.
Ich habe euch das ja schon erzählt.
Wir hatten mal einen Storage-Experte, der gesagt hat, er ist Storage-Experte.
Und am Endeffekt hat er halt Sachen falsch konfiguriert im Storage, für das er Experte ist.
Und ist dann erst mal fünf Stunden im Storage.
Und ist dann erst mal fünf Stunden abgehauen Mittagessen.
Und man hat am Ende rausgekriegt, ja, er hat Mist gebaut, ist abgehauen, hat nie was gesagt.
Ja, den haben sie dann relativ schnell wieder raus entsorgt.
Das sind aber auch so Sachen, da bist du echt pepega, wenn du sowas machst.
Hätte der gesagt, oh Mist, Leute, ich glaube, ich habe mich gerade verklickt, lasst uns mal gucken.
Hätte keiner irgendwas dagegen gesagt.
Aber meistens ist es ja mehrere.
Und was wichtig ist, dann nicht zu gucken, wer hat am meisten Scheiße gebaut.
Um dann zu sagen, du machst nie was.
Um dann zu sagen, du machst nie wieder Änderungen an produktiven Systemen oder so einen Blödsinn.
Sondern, was übrigens auf meiner alten Arbeit genauso passiert ist, da gab es richtig Stress mit jemand Neuem.
Das war auch, egal, erzähle ich euch jetzt nicht.
Sondern man guckt, warum ist der Ablauf so kacke gewesen.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, warum ist der Ablauf so kacke gewesen, kann es durchaus an mehreren Stellen gelegen haben.
Ich habe ja schon oft genug Videos dazu gemacht, zu Systemausfällen und so.
Das lag meistens an verschiedenen Stellen.
Und wichtig ist doch nur, dass man daraus lernt und weiß, okay, wir haben es verkackt an den und den Stellen.
Vielleicht sollte man in Zukunft sich mal überlegen, wie können wir das anpassen, dass das so nicht mehr passiert.
Und ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ist das irgendwelche Ami-Memes?
Hältst du Management überhaupt für eine sinnvolle Tätigkeit?
Ja.
Klar.
Es gibt leider nicht viele fähige Manager.
Aber ich halte das für wichtig.
Du kannst nicht, also, es gibt so eine, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie das heißt.
Es gibt so eine ungeschriebene Regel.
Da gibt es, glaube ich, auch irgendeinen Spruch für, wie das heißt.
Und zwar, dass Projekte relativ schnell 80% fertig sind.
Und dass quasi 20%, die letzten 20%, quasi irgendwie fünfmal länger sind.
Quasi irgendwie fünfmal länger dauern, wie die ersten 80%.
Da gibt es irgendwie so eine, oder 80-20-Regel, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und das passiert, wenn du Techniker fragst nach dem Status.
Heißt das so?
Es sagt, dass 80% der Ergebnisse mit 20% des Gesamtaufwands erreicht werden.
Ja, ja, das, genau.
Das ist das, im Prinzip ist es das, was ich meine.
Im Prinzip ist es das, was ich meine.
Und das kommt raus, wenn du nur Techniker nach dem Status fragst.
Das ist aber auch verständlich, weil ganz im Ernst, wenn man irgendwas programmiert,
man sieht ja, man weiß ja, was am Ende rauskommen soll.
Und wenn man was programmiert, so nach dem Motto, man hat es am Laufen,
es funktioniert prinzipiell, man weiß, wie alles geht,
man muss es quasi nur noch ordentlich machen,
dann denkt man gerne mal, man ist 80% fertig.
Aber dieses, man muss das nur noch ordentlich machen,
das ist halt das, was eigentlich der eigentliche Aufwand ist.
Weil zu diesem, man muss es nur noch ordentlich machen,
zählt nämlich auch, dass wenn in einem halben Jahr jemand sagt,
ey, können wir da noch was einbauen, dass das geht.
Bei dem wild gestrickten anderen eher nicht.
Und deswegen ist es wichtig, dass es Projektmanager gibt und Manager insgesamt.
Aber die müssen halt auch was können.
Die müssen das halt auch gescheit machen.
Und da gibt es tatsächlich wiederum nicht so viele Gescheite,
die das auf die Reihe bekommen.
Angeführt, eine gute, ganz schnelle Karriere wie bei uns,
ist das tatsächlich so, dass du nur mit Teamleiter und Bereichsleiter steigen kannst,
nicht unbedingt Teil in dem...
Ja, und du kannst ihm auch sagen,
also du kannst ihm auch Beispiele bringen.
Sag ihm, Google macht es auch so.
Also, bei Google ist das ja auch so.
Oder bei Microsoft oder bei Meta oder sonst wie.
Es ist eigentlich bei allen größeren,
ein bisschen IT- oder technikfokussierten Unternehmen
oder Unternehmen mit nicht unerheblicher IT-Abteilung so,
du hast...
Oder du musst auch nicht bei IT sein.
Du hast in vielen Unternehmen heutzutage fachliche Karrieremöglichkeiten
und so Management-Karrieremöglichkeiten.
Also du kannst dir auch ruhig ein paar Beispiele raussuchen, wo das ist.
Und dass es dort auch wunderbar funktioniert.
Und es liegt ja auf der Hand.
Die Stärken eines guten Technikers ist die Technik
und nicht irgendwie Personalmanagement oder sowas.
Das sollten alle so machen.
Leider machen das nicht viele.
Das ist übrigens ein Punkt,
der auch zu einem guten Teamleiter zählt.
Ich meine damit nicht,
dass der Teamleiter bei jeder Kleinigkeit sagen soll,
wir haben aber die geilsten Leute,
wir sind die Besten und ihr habt das so toll gemacht.
Das wirkt auch nicht glaubwürdig.
Aber zum Beispiel,
es ist ein Ausfall,
irgendjemand meldet sich nachts an,
weil er zufällig auf sein Handy geguckt hat oder so
oder wird angerufen,
der fixt den Ausfall in zwei Stunden
und alle gehen wieder pennen.
Gehen wir mal von dem Fall aus.
Dann wird ja irgendjemand im höheren Management sagen,
okay, was denn da passiert?
Und dann gibt es die Variante,
entweder man konzentriert sich,
das ist das, wie es in miesen Unternehmen läuft,
man konzentriert sich rein auf Play'n'Game,
wie konnte das sein?
Wer hat es verkackt,
dass es kaputt gegangen ist?
Oder aber es fällt vielleicht auch mal nach dem Motto,
hier Wahnsinns-Einsatz von dem und dem Mitarbeiter,
und hier Fachkompetenz gezeigt,
dass er das nachts um 3 Uhr auf die Schnelle hinbekommen hat.
Wir geben das mal weiter an seinen Teamleiter
und der muss das dann auch weitergeben.
Also sprich, dass dann ein Teamleiter dir auch mal sagt,
ich meine, ich erwarte ja nicht,
dass mich der Vorstandsvorsitzende anruft nachts oder morgens
und sagt, hey Max, cool gemacht.
Ich meine, ey, warum nicht?
Das würde ich ja nicht erwarten.
Aber wenn so was fällt, würde ich von meinem Teamleiter erwarten,
dass der so was auch weitergibt.
Dass er sich nicht einfach nur loben lässt dafür,
was er für tolle Leute im Team hat,
sondern dass er auch noch mal sagt,
Jungs, das kam richtig gut an
und der Vorstand bedankt sich noch mal für den Nachteinsatz oder so was.
Vollkommen, reicht ja voll und ganz aus, ja.
Ja, dann muss er sich nicht wundern,
wenn die Leute ihm wegrennen.
Das sind Leute,
die mal ein paar Führungskräfte-Seminare besuchen sollten.
Das tritt aber auch oft auf,
oftmals leider in so ein bisschen Oldschool-Unternehmen auf.
Da werden dann Leute Chef
und haben eigentlich, wie soll man sagen,
eher so eine merkwürdige Vorstellung im Kopf,
die auch nie korrigiert wird.
Die sind quasi so, wie soll man sagen,
wie man beim Programmieren sagt,
man hat sich selbst beigebracht.
Ja, die haben sich das dann auch selbst beigebracht.
Und es gibt durchaus sinnvolle Kurse,
die man als angehender Teamleiter,
angehende Führungskraft machen kann.
Die einem ein bisschen was beibringen,
ja, in dieser Richtung.
Das ist nicht verkehrt, das zu machen.
Gerade, wenn man vorher damit nichts zu tun hat.
Das sollten auch viele mal machen.
Naja, Führungskräfte ist aber Manager-Karriereweg.
Ja, ich weiß aber,
das würde ich schon mal alles so in die gleiche Schiene schieben.
Ja, so muss das sein.
Ich habe davon keine Ahnung.
Ich wäre ein mega schlechter Teamleiter, das weiß ich.
Meine Leute, ihr wisst, wie gut ich mit Leuten klarkomme.
Auf Dauer und in gehäufter Form.
Ich wäre ein richtig schlechter Teamleiter.
Ich glaube, das ist auch was,
wo sich jeder mal Gedanken drüber machen kann.
Es ist ja überhaupt nicht schlimm,
sich mal zumindest darüber bewusst zu werden,
was man gut kann und was nicht.
Man muss nicht alles gut können.
Oftmals kann man auch Sachen nicht gut,
weil man da schlicht und ergreifend so innerlich ist.
Kein Antrieb dazu hat, sich da drin zu verbessern.
Das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Man muss sich nicht für alles interessieren.
Dann macht das deine Teamleiterin aber verkehrt.
Es ist ja durchaus sinnvoll,
es ist ja durchaus sinnvoll,
sich technische Zusammenhänge erklären zu lassen als Teamleiter.
Ja, das war bei meiner alten Arbeit auch so.
Da kam öfters Arbeit.
Man muss sagen, mein Chef, der hat auch ein VMware-Zertifikat
und hat lange Zeit Virtualisierung in Linux gemacht,
also mein Alter vom alten Unternehmen,
der kannte sich da ganz gut aus.
Dem konnte man technische Zusammenhänge erklären.
Hätte ich jetzt einen Teamleiter gehabt,
der technisch gar keine Ahnung hat,
dann hätte ich gehofft,
dass er das irgendwann mal realisiert
bzw. dass man mit der Zeit erkennt,
dass es nicht unbedingt die beste Idee ist,
ihm technische Sachen zu erklären
und er versucht, die technischen Sachen dann weiter zu erklären,
sondern ich finde, es ist nicht verkehrt,
wenn man das in Zusammenarbeit mit seinem Chef macht.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn Abteilungsleiter-Runde ist,
wo aktuelle Produktionsprobleme, aktuelle Projekte,
was auch immer vorgestellt werden,
da finde ich es gar nicht so weit hergeholt zu sagen,
okay, man nimmt sich als Teamleiter mal den Experten
für das jeweilige Thema mit, wenn der will.
Also ich bin auch kein Fan von, man zwingt jemanden dazu,
der überhaupt keinen Bock auf solche Vorträge hat.
Aber es kann schon Sinn machen, zu sagen,
hey, wir nehmen den Experten einfach mit
und nicht einfach nur übrigens hier nächsten Montag
ist da und da Abteilungsleiter-Runde,
sondern nee, man setzt sich vielleicht im Vorfeld mal zusammen,
lässt sich das erklären, überlegt sich,
okay, was können wir denen erzählen,
dann nimmt man den Experten mit,
falls sie den noch nie gesehen haben,
sagen wir hier, das ist der Max,
das ist unser Experte für Bereich XY
und dann kannst du ein bisschen was zu erklären
oder bist einfach nur dabei,
dass du ein paar Rückfragen beantworten kannst.
Das macht, denke ich, einen viel besseren Eindruck,
als wenn deine Teamleiterin da sitzt,
irgendwas zusammen stottert,
was die anderen nicht verstehen
und im Endeffekt dann Entscheidungen getroffen werden
auf der Basis von etwas,
was keiner der dort Beteiligten verstanden hat.
Natürlich muss dann die Teamleiterin auch erst mal erkennen,
dass ihre Stärke nicht das technische Know-how ist.
Was aber wiederum auch kein Problem ist,
weil dafür ist sie eigentlich auch gar nicht da.
Es ist schwierig, ja.
Es kommt immer ein bisschen darauf an,
wie die Leute so drauf sind.
Egal, wir müssen jetzt echt das Video weitergucken.
Ich habe schon wieder komplett vergessen,
um was es geht.
Also Gen Z will nicht arbeiten.
Das letzte war irgendein Boomer,
der gesagt hat, die sind aber blöd oder sowas.
... die bei älteren Generationen
oft auf Unverständnis stößt.
Meine Wahrnehmung von dem Ganzen ist,
dass die jüngeren Mitarbeiter
im Grunde genommen ziemlich schwer zu motivieren sind,
überhaupt Arbeit und mehr Leistung zu bringen.
Das war der Aufhänger dafür,
warum ich eben so lange geschwätzt habe.
... fliegt am Arbeitsmarkt.
Während viele Boomer geprägt sind von
Arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten, wir müssen was schaffen.
... will es die Generation Z ganz anders machen.
Nicht so viel krassen Leistungsdruck,
sondern mehr auf die Menschen eingehen.
Alexandra Thule ist
Menschen?
Menschen? Alter, hör mal auf.
Was ist denn mit denen los?
... ist stellvertretende Chefredakteurin
vom Biber-Magazin.
Für mich als Millennial war es so ganz klassisch,
dieses Danke, dass ich...
Wait a minute.
War Leonie24 nicht die andere?
Das ist der falsche Text, oder?
Das ist nicht Leonie24.
... vom Biber-Magazin.
Für mich als Millenial...
Alexandra Thule...
Das ist Alexandra, das ist nicht Leonie.
... ist stellvertretende Chefredakteurin
vom Biber-Magazin.
Für mich als Millenial war es...
Exposed.
Ganz klassisch, dieses Danke,
dass ich hier überhaupt sein darf,
weil ich auch nicht mit dem aufgewachsen bin.
Wollte ich gerade sagen,
die sieht auch ein bisschen älter aus als 24.
Und das ist nicht Leonie.
... dass man überhaupt Ansprüche stellen kann.
Anfang des Jahres schreibt sie...
Jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört.
Was hat sie gesagt?
Für mich als Millenial war es so ganz klassisch,
dieses Danke, dass ich hier überhaupt sein darf,
weil ich auch nicht mit dem aufgewachsen bin,
dass man überhaupt Ansprüche stellen kann.
What?
Die ist so...
Okay, die ist ungefähr mein Alter.
Da sieht man...
Das ist im Prinzip das, was ich gesagt habe.
Meine Generation ist extrem gesplattert,
was das angeht.
Du hast welche,
die sind boomerischste Boomer
und welche,
die reden mit 38 in Twitch-E-Mails.
Anfang des Jahres schreibt sie einen Kommentar,
in dem sie die Arbeitsmoral der Gen Z kritisiert.
Liebe Generation Z,
wir müssen über eure Arbeitsmoral sprechen.
Was kritisierst du daran genau?
Dass ich am Anfang eines Praktikums jetzt herkomme
und sage, nein, ich muss da jetzt gehen,
weil ich habe da noch Yoga.
Oder nein, ich mag das nicht machen,
weil irgendwie taugt mir das Thema jetzt nicht so.
Mache ich nicht.
Das sind so Dinge,
wo die Gen Z das so...
wo die Gen Z das so selbstverständlich sieht.
Die zahlreichen Reaktionen darauf zeigen...
Wenn es nach Feierabend ist,
ist das auch selbstverständlich.
Also ich sage nicht,
dass es immer so sein muss,
aber wenn...
Gerade ein Praktikant, Alter,
der nun wirklich schon
eigentlich nichts dafür kriegt
und im Endeffekt eh an der untersten Stelle
der Nahrungskette steht
und wahrscheinlich von dem Praktikum am Ende
noch nicht mal großartig was hat.
Naja, also wenn der seine Zeit dort war
und kurz vor Feierabend der Chef um die Ecke kommt
und es ist ein Praktikant.
Weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich gebe zu, es ist nicht immer schlau
zu sagen, mache ich nicht.
Weil es muss eine gewisse Balance geben
zwischen dem, was man selbst will
und das, was man so von seinem Arbeitgeber erwartet.
Wenn ich nie was mache quasi,
wenn ich nie irgendwie mal auch ein bisschen Einsatz zeige,
dann kann ich auch nicht erwarten,
dass mein Arbeitgeber mal mir entgegenkommt
in Sachen, die er auch nicht unbedingt machen müsste.
Nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel Urlaubsplanung jetzt.
Wenn ich jetzt jemand bin,
der immer super korrekt mit allem ist,
so nach dem Motto,
ja, ich habe jetzt da eigentlich schon was eingetragen,
aber es ist zufälligerweise,
keine Ahnung,
es geht zwei Tage vorher Totalausfall
und ich sage, oh ne, ich mache jetzt erst mal Urlaub.
Versus ich würde sagen,
okay, ich fahre eigentlich erst zwei Tage später weg,
ich helfe euch jetzt noch zwei Tage, das zu fixen,
aber dann muss ich wirklich weg,
weil ansonsten verliere ich 3000 Euro,
weil ich Urlaub, Reise, sonst wie schon bezahlt habe.
Kann dem Arbeitgeber in gewisser Weise entgegenkommen
und sagen, okay, ich helfe euch jetzt noch zwei Tage,
das mit zu fixen, aber mehr geht halt nicht.
Und dementsprechend kann ich dann aber auch,
denke ich, erwarten,
dass man bei der nächsten Urlaubsplanung sagt,
okay, ich weiß es jetzt noch nicht genau,
wie das im Sommer ist,
könnt ihr mir da nochmal einen Monat mehr Zeit geben
zum Einreichen der Planung.
So, das sind so zwei Sachen,
würde ich in beide Richtungen erwarten,
da ich sage, okay,
ich komme mal meinem Arbeitgeber ein bisschen mehr entgegen
über das, was ich eigentlich machen müsste,
umgedreht, allerdings die auch.
Und dann ist das auch okay
und ich denke, so sollte das auch sein.
Dass man jetzt allerdings,
wie ganz selbstverständlich erwartet,
dass einer über seine Arbeitszeit hinaus,
nur weil es dem Chef fünf Minuten vor Schluss eingefallen ist,
ja, da kann man sich drüber streiten.
Man kennt jetzt das Verhältnis
zwischen den Mitarbeitern nicht.
Aber ich kann ihren Punkt auch
durchaus nachvollziehen, ja.
Wir hatten auch schon Praktikanten,
die sind angerückt und haben gesagt,
so nach dem Motto, ah, Alter, ich sitze hier eh nur rum
und eigentlich kann ich das schon alles.
Ich bin ja quasi schon, oder Azubis,
die haben angefangen so, ich habe da schon
den kompletten Durchblick und kann alles
und eigentlich sitze ich nur noch hier.
Das waren wir eh die Liebsten dann immer. Egal.
Was man so selbstverständlich sieht.
Die zahlreichen Reaktionen darauf zeigen,
das Thema polarisiert.
Unglaublich viel ist da abgegangen,
auf Twitter, auf Instagram.
Egal, was ich für sonst Reportagen mache,
zu wirklich wichtigen Themen,
darauf kriege ich nicht so eine große Response.
Und auf diesen Kommentar,
weil die Response war riesig,
es waren zwei Lager.
Also es gab entweder die, die gesagt haben,
was ist das für ein Blödsinn, oh mein Gott.
Millennials sind die neuen Boomer.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
... in schlecht bezahlten Positionen
kein Blatt vor den Munde nehmen.
Ich gehöre ja auch dazu.
Ausgebrannt und mental am Ende
mit Anfang 20.
Danke für nichts.
Und dann aber auf der anderen Seite gab es Leute,
die dann gesagt haben, wow, danke für diesen Text.
Ich finde auch, ein bisschen mehr Respekt
und strenge...
Das ist im Internet ja normal.
Es gibt Leute, die stimmen der Sache zu,
die erzählen dir dann...
Okay.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen.
Immer, wenn im Internet,
also wenn im Internet einer was postet,
was der Meinung
oder der Weltanschauung eines anderen entspricht,
da gibt es so Standard,
so Standardantworten,
wo ich immer richtig cringen muss.
Richtig und wichtig ist dann so ein Ding,
was dann immer kommt.
Richtig und wichtig, dass das mal gesagt wurde.
Oder was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Meine höchste Achtung und Respekt,
dass das mal einer ausspricht
oder sowas.
Okay, da weißt du immer, okay,
da sind Leute, die haben im Prinzip
eh schon die ganze Zeit das gedacht,
was der geschrieben hat
und feiern sich jetzt darauf ab.
Meine höchste Achtung ist auch immer...
Das ist so ein...
Wenn ihr den richtig...
Den Boomer-Poster
oder den...
Weiß nicht, ob ich es jetzt sagen soll.
Es gibt so ein paar Leute,
da endlich sagt es jemand mal.
Das ist auch sowas.
Ich sage jetzt nicht nur,
aber das sind so Dinge,
die liest man immer so aus
aus ähnlichen Ecken.
So dieses, ja,
endlich sagt es mal jemand.
Das ist richtig und wichtig.
Danke für den Mut,
das endlich mal auszusprechen.
Das liest man entweder von Leuten,
die eh schon so ein bisschen extreme Ansichten haben
oder ein bisschen aus so
Verschwörungstheorie-Richtung
so nach dem Motto,
gesunder Menschenverstand hat mir das schon immer so gesagt.
Sehr wichtiger Beitrag.
Endlich sagt es mal jemand.
So in der Richtung, ja.
So ein bisschen Aluhut-Lager.
Ja.
Liest man das dann auch immer drauf,
solche Antworten.
Und ja, das ist im Internet halt so.
Du hast einmal die,
die dann halt total überschwänglich zustimmen
und dann dauert es meistens nicht lange.
Dann schlägt es ein gegengesetztes Lager auf
zu dieser Meinung
und das ist im Internet so,
dass es kaum jemand gibt,
der noch in der Lage ist zu sagen,
okay,
ich kann einen Punkt vielleicht aus deiner Sicht nachvollziehen,
aber ich sehe das komplett anders
aus diesen und diesen Gründen,
sondern es gibt nur richtig und wichtiger Beitrag.
Endlich sagt es mal jemand.
Meine Hochachtung, Hut ab dafür,
dies auszusprechen.
Oder es gibt so,
Alter, ich ruf morgen bei deinem Arbeitgeber an,
dass du gefeuert wirst, du Kackspast.
So. Es gibt irgendwie, gefühlt,
genau diese zwei Lager, ja.
Und das ist halt auch schon echt
pepega, gerade auf Twitter.
So, weiter.
... die dann gesagt haben, wow, danke für diesen Text.
Ich finde auch, ein bisschen
mehr Respekt und strenge sich selbst
gegenüber würde dieser Generation nicht schaden.
Anna Miller, 86.
Gut, ungefähr genauso alt wie ich.
Ehrlich gesagt, das müssen
die Leute noch alles selbst lernen.
Die Leute müssen selbst drauf kommen.
Ich hab es auch,
noch nie, also viele Sachen
hab ich auch immer gesagt,
Alter, das ist Boomer-Geschwätz.
Ja, so warte mal ab,
wenn du älter wirst, dann fallen dir manche Sachen
nicht mehr so leicht und so. Da hab ich früher immer gesagt,
ja, bla bla bla bla.
Und ich glaube zu dem Punkt,
dass es sich durchaus lohnen kann,
in manchen Situationen
Einsatz zu zeigen oder sich anzustrengen.
Das müssen Leute
einfach selbst lernen.
Guck mal,
wenn dir irgendwelche Telegram-Leute
erzählen, oh, musst du krass abhasseln,
hascheln und
was du nicht alles machen musst, das geht doch
realistisch betrachtet den meisten
Leuten ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere raus,
glücklicherweise. Ja, und wenn die Eltern erzählen
so nach dem Motto, du musst jetzt mal ein bisschen Leistung
bringen, an der Stelle kannst du ja nicht immer nur
den ganzen Tag rumchillen und so,
das wird doch so nichts. Das geht ins eine Ohr
rein, das geht ins andere Ohr raus.
Aber ich glaube, es muss einfach
jeder selbst merken,
dass es durchaus
sich auszahlt, dass es durchaus
Vorteile für jemand hat oder für
einen persönlich hat,
wenn man sich
bei manchen Sachen auch mal ein bisschen anstrengt.
Aber das müssen die Leute selber einfach
merken mit der Zeit.
Und die Menge
und Intensität,
wie sehr man sich anstrengen will,
das muss dann im Endeffekt auch jeder selbst
für ihn
ja,
bestimmen, weil
letztendlich ist es sein Leben.
Der kann machen, was er will.
Was ich dann halt ein bisschen merkwürdig finde,
ist Leute, die permanent abchillen
und sich dann beschweren,
dass es ihnen nicht gut geht.
So nach dem Motto, Alter, ich harze
seit 15 Jahren und chill mein Leben
und ich kann mir keinen neuen BMW kaufen.
Ja gut, der Staat
muss das bezahlen, wie kann das sein, dass ich keinen
neuen BMW kaufe? Ja gut,
dem kann man dann auch nicht helfen.
Ja.
Aber das ist ja das eine Extrem und das andere Extrem.
Ich denke, die Leute müssen es früher oder später
selbst merken, dass es sich lohnt,
ein bisschen Eigeninitiative
zu zeigen. Und nur, weil Anna Miller
86 in ihrem
Leben festgestellt hat,
ähm, tja,
oder für sich festgestellt hat,
wie das sein muss, heißt nicht
zwangsläufig, dass es für jeden anderen auch so sein muss.
Leute, die irgendwie ganz am Anfang daherkommen.
Junge Leute werden immer als
respektlos eingestuft. Das hat schon,
auch wenn es Sokrates nicht wirklich gesagt hat,
aber man dichtet ihm das ja an,
das hat ja angeblich sogar Sokrates schon gesagt.
Ja, und wenn die Griechen das schon erzählt haben,
scheint das doch ein weit verbreitetes Phänomen
zu sein, dass die älteren Leute
immer denken, die Jungen sind super krass,
respektlos und sonst was. Und ja,
sind sie wahrscheinlich auch, aber
waren sie selber auch.
...kommen und
ähm, einfach respektlos
sind und einfach so sagen wie
ja, du weißt eh nix, ich kenn mich da jetzt
besser aus. Wenn mir jemand von Anfang an schon
daherkommt mit diesem, du bist eh alt,
du hast eh keine Ahnung, ja, was, was,
also, weißt du, was willst du denn noch hier?
Glaubst du, dass sich die TGNZ
auch ein bissl zu wichtig auch nimmt?
Ich glaub schon, jetzt fühl ich mich
wirklich sehr alt, wenn ich das sage, aber
ähm, auch so dieses Internetmäßige,
Instagrammäßige, jeder muss zu,
jeder ist relevant, jeder muss zu jedem
Thema was sagen. Meine Meinung zu
jedem Thema ist wichtig.
Na ja, ja,
ja, ja,
ja, es stimmt schon,
aber ich wette mit dir, sie denkt auch, dass
ihre Meinung relevant und wichtig ist.
Also insofern, ich,
ich würde mich
wundern, wenn, wenn das nicht
jeder von sich denkt, dass
die eigene Meinung relevant und wichtig ist.
Also ich mein, die eigene Meinung ist ja auch
relevant und wichtig,
zumindest für einen selbst, ja.
Ob das natürlich, wie das heute
teilweise auf Twitter diskutiert wird,
jeder Hirnfurz, den irgendjemand hatte,
ähm,
rausposaunt
werden muss, so als würde es jetzt die Welt
verändern, ja, da kann man
sich sicherlich drüber streiten.
Und ob man sich jetzt
über Nebensätze, die Leute
in irgendeinem Interview gesagt haben, die
überhaupt nicht Teil so der, der
Kernaussage waren, auf Twitter
drei Wochen
circlejurken muss über irgendeine
blöde Bemerkung in nem Nebensatz,
das find ich auch übertrieben, ja.
Was da in der heutigen Zeit abgeht.
... Mut,
Bewusstsein für Themen wie Klima und
Mental Health. Wir können laut Alexandra
einiges von der Gen-Set lernen,
aber dennoch... Alter, was ist mit der
Armlehne los? Seht ihr das?
Das ist komplett RIP, die Armlehne.
Guckt mal.
... fragt sie sich, wie soll
das weitergehen? Wir haben auch Deadlines und da
frage ich mich schon so, wie das
eigentlich dann in Zukunft ausschauen soll.
Ganz einfach, realistische Deadlines machen.
... um das... Und nicht
so nach dem Motto, ah, wir sind in einer
Woche fertig, wenn jetzt alle super
krass crunchen 24-7.
Da macht man halt gescheite Deadlines und
da braucht man halt auch mal gescheite Manager,
die ihren Jobtitel verdienen.
... frage ich mich schon so, wie das
eigentlich dann in Zukunft ausschauen muss. Und halt nicht
einfach Agentur-Bullshit labern den ganzen
Tag. ... soll.
Um das herauszufinden, besuche ich die
lange Nacht der Bewerbung in Wien.
Hier treffen Arbeitssuchende auf
Unternehmen. Ich will mich weiter umhören.
Wie will die Generation Z arbeiten?
Von meinem zukünftigen
Arbeitgeber würde ich mir auf jeden Fall
Respekt erwarten. Auch, dass
er mich als so einen Gleichgestellten
quasi sieht. Flexible Arbeitszeiten
wären mir wichtig. Also ich glaube, ich
bin nicht gemacht für diese 9-to-5-Jobs.
Ich kann dir schon mal sagen, ich glaube
gemacht ist da keiner für. Von Montag
bis Freitag. Schon arbeiten gehen,
aber halt immer noch genügend Freizeit
haben, um halt andere Sachen zu
machen. Um zu veranschaulichen,
wo...
Auch lustig,
dass die Armlehne gewichtiger ist, als
der Inhalt. Seriously, ich habe mich
jetzt seit fast einer Stunde mit dem Inhalt
beschäftigt, ja? Und habe zwei Sätze
über die Armlehne gesagt. Oh nein!
Ganz schlimm.
Da versteht der Patrick
keinen Spaß bei sowas.
Vielleicht hat er es auch gar
nicht so gemeint.
Wir sollten ihm da schon mal eine Chance geben.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass ich das auch falsch verstanden habe.
Okay, jetzt wird
Zeug sortiert.
Was wird sortiert?
Sicherheit, Gehalt, Sinn im Job.
Okay. Selbstverwirklichung.
Ich würde sagen Work-Life-Balance, weil
ich mag meine Freizeit.
Und dann Gehalt,
weil ich mag auch Geld.
Ja, gut.
Okay.
Tatsächlich, ja.
Seriously, ich glaube,
ich würde das wahrscheinlich
genauso raten, wie
die Work-Life-Balance
und Geld.
Sicherheit,
ähm...
Okay, okay.
Soll ich auch mal raten?
Soll ich auch mal raten? Okay, was haben wir denn?
Was haben wir denn? Lass mal kurz gucken.
Wir haben Work-Life-Balance,
wir haben Gehalt,
wir haben Sinn im Job, was auch immer.
Sicherheit,
Flexibilität
und Selbstverwirklichung.
Okay, Work-Life-Balance
ist bei mir das Erste.
Das liegt bei mir
schon daran, dass
der Job nicht mein einziger Job ist,
sondern dass ich noch YouTube und Twitch mache,
auch noch
mich mit Dingern beschäftigen will,
auf die ich Bock habe, was oftmals
irgendwie schon mit meinem Job zusammenhängt.
Weil wenn ich mir irgendwelche neuen Programmiersprachen,
Frameworks, sonst was angucke,
früher oder später bringt einem das immer mal was, auch im Job.
Aber
da lege ich Wert drauf, ja.
Also, dass ich halt genug Zeit habe, um noch YouTube
zu machen, Twitch zu machen und halt auch noch Sachen,
auf die ich Bock habe. Also ich würde sagen, erstes
würde ich bei mir auch sagen, ganz gleich,
ähm, Work-Life-Balance.
Das Zweite ist bei mir auch
Gehalt. Letztendlich, ich gehe arbeiten, dass ich Geld verdiene.
Keine Frage.
Sinn im Job.
Ob mein Job Sinn macht,
ist mir scheißegal.
Also sprich, ob da
irgendwie ein, ich nenne es mal, ein Mehrwert
irgendwie für die Menschheit rauskommt,
ist mir wurscht, ja. Also ob ich da jetzt
irgendwas mache, wo ich sagen würde,
oh ja, das hat jetzt irgendwie unsere
Gesellschaft oder sonst was irgendwie
voll vorangebracht oder so,
ist mir egal. Ganz ehrlich, ich arbeite
bei einer Versicherung
oder, ja, ich habe bei einer Bank gearbeitet,
ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung. Ob da der
Außendienst jetzt bei uns, ähm,
irgendwelchen Omas
hundert Sachen mehr verkaufen kann
durch gute IT-Systeme oder nicht, ist mir
wurscht, ja. Ähm,
Sicherheit ist mir tatsächlich auch nicht so
wichtig. Flexibilität,
ja, ist die Frage, was damit
gemeint ist. Also, wenn damit gemeint
ist, dass man, ähm,
auch mal nach Hamburg fahren muss,
um was zu machen, dann ist es relativ weit
unten. Hm.
Ich würde sagen, das ist gar nicht
mal so unwichtig.
Was ich damit meine ist,
wie gesagt, es mag jetzt vielleicht merkwürdig
anmuten, wenn ich sage Sinn,
äh, wenn ich sowas, Sinn, ja,
Homeoffice und sowas, dann ist das dritter, dritter Punkt.
Homeoffice, also hier Home,
Homeoffice und, und, und
Kleidzeit und, und,
und so weiter, ja. Dann, dann würde ich
das, würde ich das tatsächlich auf den, ähm,
auf den dritten Platz setzen, ist mir,
ist mir auch sehr wichtig. Ähm, das vierte
ist tatsächlich Selbstverwirklichung, weil
ich würde darunter sowas sehen, wie
dass ich, äh,
daran beteiligt bin an Technologie,
Technologieauswahl und, äh, in der
Umsetzung von neuen, von neuen
Projekten und dass ich dort auch
die Möglichkeit hab,
meine Sicht der Dinge
einzubringen und auch Sachen so
umzusetzen, wie ich sie für richtig und gut
halte. Das bringt mir
auch Spaß an der Arbeit, ja. Das ist, das ist
für mich auch, was Motivation angeht,
sehr wichtig, dass die Dinger
gebaut werden nach
einem System, was ich
gut finde, sagen wir mal so. Und ihr wisst, dass ich teilweise
merkwürdige Ansichten habe, wie was gut
sein muss, aber
ich bin dann meistens recht überzeugt von,
dass das ein guter Weg ist, wenn ich mich dafür
entschieden hab, was so zu bauen. Und das
finde ich gut, wenn ich da an Entscheidungen beteiligt bin.
Beißt sich das
nicht mit... Sinn im Job würde ich eher
sehen in der Richtung, wie, ähm,
ja, äh, leiste
ich da was so für das, für das große
Ganze, so. Zum Beispiel Sinn im Job
würde ich sagen Altenpfleger, ja.
Da geht's, da geht's, oder, oder, oder
Notarzt oder sowas. Da geht's, da geht's um Leben und
Tod. Da haben wirklich viele andere
Leute was von, wenn ich diesen Job mache.
Ähm, das würde ich
sagen, das ist mir eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Ja, also irgendwie sowas Soziales
oder so, vielleicht Sinn im Job.
Sicherheit ist mir tatsächlich gar nicht so
wichtig. Klingt jetzt vielleicht
auch blöd. Ich meine, ich hab beim, ich hab
bei meinen letzten Arbeitgebern
Jahrzehnte gefühlt gearbeitet, ja. Bei den letzten
zehn Jahren, bei dem da vorne, bei dem jetzt hab ich auch nicht
vor zu wechseln. Aber trotzdem, es ist
mir, es ist mir nicht so wichtig.
Also wenn, wenn die jetzt sagen würden,
morgen, ja, wir machen die, also über,
unrealistisch as fuck, aber nur mal
theoretisch, ja. Würden die jetzt sagen,
Max,
ähm, in zwei Monaten wird die
gesamte IT dicht gemacht,
ähm, wir bezahlen dir ne
Abfindung, mach, dass du rauskommst, dann würde
ich sagen, okay. Ich fänd's
zwar irgendwie kacke, es ist nicht so, dass ich sagen
würde, oh easy, alles kein Problem.
Ich fänd's kacke, ja. Gerade,
wenn man schon ne Weile da ist, die Leute kennt sich
ein, gearbeitet hat, in gewissen, ja auch
Bezug zu den Projekten und Teams und
Leuten hat, mit denen man arbeitet. Ich fänd, ich fänd's blöd.
Ja. Ich fänd's echt
auch bisschen belastend.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich, dass ich sagen würde,
oh nein, ähm,
ich verzichte auch komplett
auf mein Gehalt für nen halbes Jahr,
wenn es dann noch ein bisschen weiter geht.
Nee. Also, ja, ich fänd's blöd.
Ich fänd's blöd, aber ich weiß auch, dass man
in der IT relativ easy was Neues findet,
genau. Also Sicherheit ist für mich
nicht ganz so wichtig.
So, und Sinn im Job, ob ich da irgendwas für die,
für die Allgemeinheit tue, ist mir egal.
Das sind sechs Punkte, ne, ja.
Das ist mir hier so, so quasi
für die Allgemeinheit,
ja. Das ist
mir egal.
Also so würde, so würde ich das
raten, ja. Work-Life-Balance,
Gehalt, Flexibilität sowas, ja auch mal
Selbstverwirklichung, Sicherheit, ja. Ja, so würde,
so würde ich's wahrscheinlich raten. Falls
das, also falls das,
was ich mir denke, was hinter den Punkten steckt,
auch wirklich hinter den Punkten steckt, weil
wir haben die Einführung hier nicht, nicht
mitbekommen dazu.
Du siehst es komplett anders, weißt du, das ist
ja das Schöne an der ganzen Sache, es kann ja jeder
für sich sehen, wie er will.
Wenn wir jetzt auf Twitter wären,
dann würdest du jetzt dafür geflamed und ich
dafür geflamed.
Aber ich finde, das sollte man jedem zugestehen.
Ich meine, es geht ja auch um seinen Job, um sein Leben,
soll jeder so gewichten, wie er will.
Die ist 16, ja, die sieht es halt
nochmal anders, ist doch okay. Es kann doch
jeder sehen, wie er will. Und
das ging doch allen so, dass ihr die
Welt mit 16 ein bisschen anders gesehen habt.
Als mit 40.
Und ich wette mit euch, und das wird auch anders,
ich wette mit euch auch, dass
viele Leute, die sich jetzt an der
Autobahn festkleben,
das mit 40 vielleicht noch ein bisschen
anders sehen werden.
Das ist immer im Wandel.
Ich glaube, die
wenigsten
verändern ihre
Ansichten, oder sagen wir mal so,
doch, vielleicht verändern viele
ihre Ansichten nicht, aber
die Welt drumherum verändert sich. Oder sagen wir mal so,
die Ansichten der Leute verändern sich vielleicht
langsamer als die Welt drumherum.
Aber so diese Interaktion zwischen
den Leuten und der Welt drumherum,
das bleibt halt nicht einfach 80 Jahre gleich.
Also selbstverständlich
hat man da andere Eindrücke mit 16 als
mit 40. Und das muss auch
irgendwie so sein.
Das gehört halt irgendwie,
das gehört dazu.
Das hat jeder.
Und es ist auch normal, dass die Älteren sagen so,
du weißt noch gar nicht, was auf dich zukommt.
Und die Jungen sagen, Alter,
eure Boomer-Ansichten sind total outdated.
Und mit 40 haben sie die gleichen
Boomer-Ansichten gegen 16-Jährige dann,
wenn sie 40 sind.
Also das ändert sich alles.
Deswegen finde ich auch, ich denke,
da muss man unterscheiden können.
Also, ich finde es gut,
dass die Leute das machen.
So.
Ah ne, das muss ich, das muss ich,
wenn wir jetzt nochmal bei, wir kleben uns an die Straße
bleiben.
Ich finde gut, dass Leute den Antrieb
haben, für ihre
Überzeugung, sowas zu machen.
Letztens habe ich gelesen, es hat sich einer in der Autobahn,
das ist kein Spaß, es hat sich einer
von der Last Generation
einbetoniert bei der Autobahn
Auffahrt, Alter.
Da dachte ich mir auch so, ey, weißt du was,
wäre nicht das Beste gewesen,
ich meine, es ist gerade 32 Grad draußen,
hätte man den nicht einfach, hätte man das nicht
irgendwie mal 8 Stunden sperren können und den einfach
8 Stunden einbetoniert da stehen lassen oder so?
Ja. Also,
ich finde es gut,
oder ich muss das, ich muss das, ich muss das
formulieren, weil ich finde, es sind zwei verschiedene
Paar Schuhe. Ich finde gut,
dass Leute
von irgendwas, wie soll ich sagen, von irgendwas
überzeugt sind und versuchen,
das der Welt mitzuteilen.
Nennen wir es mal so. Über die Art und Weise
kann man sich, kann man sich sicher, kann man
sich sicherlich streiten, aber das finde
ich prinzipiell gut. So.
Die Aktion an sich, für
meine,
für mein Daily Business,
finde ich
kacke. Weil ich habe keinen Bock
dass meine Bahn oder mein Auto oder sonst was
Verspätung hat. Also, also ich
finde, man muss das, man muss das voll, also
das ist ähnlich wie bei einem Bahnstreik, ja?
Ich finde es voll und ganz in Ordnung, dass die streiken
und wahrscheinlich ist es auch gut, dass die
mehr Geld bekommen. Ich finde es trotzdem kacke,
dass sie streiken, weil ich zu spät ankomme.
Deswegen finde ich es immer blöd, wenn dann erzählt
wird auf Twitter, Max, sei doch mal
solidarisch mit den Bahnmitarbeitern. Nein,
muss ich nicht. Muss ich nicht.
Ich kann aber den Unterschied machen
zu, ich
verstehe, warum
das gemacht wird alles, ja?
Aber für mich ist die Auswirkung
scheiße. Und so
sehe ich das da auch. Wenn ich im Stau stehe,
weil sich irgendeiner festgepappt
hat, finde ich das kacke.
Ich finde nicht kacke,
dass sie prinzipiell
ihre, wie soll man sagen,
ihre
ihre Ansichten durchsetzen wollen. Das nicht.
Und ich glaube, das ist in vielen
Bereichen so.
Also es ist immer ein Unterschied zwischen, wie soll ich sagen,
zwischen so
Rechtfertigung und Rechtfertigung
oder ich weiß nicht, wie man das
gescheit beschreiben kann.
Das ist so. Richtig, richtig.
Du hast voll und ganz recht.
Wenn die Leute es nicht scheiße finden würden,
würden zum Beispiel, guck mal,
würde die Bahn nicht massig
Geld verlieren und würden es die Leute nicht scheiße
finden, wenn sie bei der Bahn streiken, hätten sie
keinen Erfolg damit. Sehe ich
genauso und ich kann das auch komplett
nachvollziehen und aus dem Gesichtspunkt finde ich es auch gut,
dass sie streiken. Ich muss es aber nicht gut
finden in dem Sinn, weil ich später auf den
Darm auf die Arbeit komme oder weil ich im Stau
stehe oder sonst was. Also es ist ein Unterschied
zwischen, wie betrifft mich das Ganze
persönlich
und wie finde ich solche
Aktionen an sich. Ich kann es durchaus
nachvollziehen und kann das vom
Ansatz her gut finden, dass sie
bei der Bahn streiken. Ich finde es aber für
mich persönlich trotzdem scheiße, dass sie
streiken. Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Es ist nicht unbedingt immer so ganz schwarz
und weiß.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich eigentlich sagen will.
Es ist nicht immer schwarz und weiß.
Und das ist das, was mir auch
auf vielen Social-Media-Diskussionen
auch ein bisschen verloren geht.
Entweder bist du dafür oder du bist dagegen.
Aber in Wirklichkeit
ist das halt
oftmals so ein bisschen grau.
Und das wird oftmals nicht genug Rechnung
getragen.
So, ich weiß nicht, wie ich dazu
drauf... Wir müssen jetzt mal...
Wir haben das sortiert und jetzt gucken wir mal,
was sie sortiert.
Selbstbewilligung, Da-Sinn,
vielleicht Gehalt und...
Sicherheit. Ich glaube, Gehalt ist schon wichtig.
Ich glaube, Sicherheit ist so eines der...
Also, würde ich eh auf erster Stelle
lassen, weil ich mir denke, ich will nicht jeden
Tag zappeln müssen, ob ich heute gekündigt werde.
Ganz einfach in der IT arbeiten,
dann hast du morgen schon einen neuen Job.
Oder nicht.
Und wie sieht es mit der idealen Wochenarbeitszeit aus?
30.
Ja, 30 Stunden ist okay.
Ich denke, ich mag das nicht schlecht.
38 Stunden
oder so, aber dann freitags früher
aushaben.
38 Stunden... Okay, die meint
quasi 40 Stunden, dafür Freitag 2.
Also, okay, verstehe.
Neue Generation scheint Glück über Karriere zu stellen.
Ja. Ja, das ist doch auch vollkommen
okay. Es ist eigentlich
bescheuert, Glück nicht über Karriere
zu stellen. Für viele war vielleicht
Glück gleich Karriere.
Das hängt so sicherlich auch ein bisschen mit
den eigenen Erwartungen an sich
zusammen, ja. Aber es wäre doch
blödsinnig zu sagen, man stellt Glück
nicht über Karriere, oder?
Ich habe schon oft genug das Beispiel gebracht,
wenn du Leute fragen
könntest, ja, kurz bevor sie sterben,
so mal angenommen, du hättest, du könntest
quasi mit jedem ein 5 Minuten
Interview, ja, du bist jetzt
du bist jetzt so halb Gott und
kannst jetzt mit jedem kurz
ein Interview führen, 5 Minuten
bevor er stirbt, so nach dem Motto, so. Und wenn
du die Leute dann fragst, ey, was hättest du in deinem
Leben anders machen wollen? Die wenigsten
werden sagen, alter,
mein Wunsch wäre echt noch in meinem Vertrieb
auf den Mount Everest zu kommen. Ich hätte mir gewünscht,
dass ich noch das Gold
in eine Vertriebsabzeichen kriege und
ich hätte mal mehr arbeiten sollen. Nee,
das werden die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht sagen.
Die meisten werden dir erzählen, oh,
hätte ich mal schon ein bisschen früher angefangen,
irgendwie mehr in Urlaub zu fliegen, hätte ich mal ein bisschen
mehr mit meiner Familie gemacht, hätte
ich mich ein bisschen mehr um meine Kinder gekümmert,
hätte ich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr damals
in meiner Band
gespielt, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Hätte ich mal mehr Sinnvolles
gemacht für mich selbst oder für
Leute, die mir wichtig sind. Das werden dir
die meisten sagen und nicht,
hätte ich mal krass mehr
gehustled, ja. Es sei denn,
es sei denn, er hat selbst ein Unternehmen
gegründet, ne, das kann natürlich, es
mag auch immer den anderen,
andere Extremen geben, so nach dem Motto,
er hat jemand mal ein Unternehmen gegründet
und hat irgendwie eine richtige Fehlentscheidung
getroffen, die dann dazu geführt hat, dass
es den Bach runtergegangen ist,
ja, dass der dann
sagt, oh Mist, hätte ich mich damals anders entschieden,
mag sein, ja.
Warum steht dann Sinn bei dir ganz unten?
Weil es nicht um den Sinn meines Lebens
geht oder den Sinn des Jobs
sind ja zwei unterschiedliche
paar Sachen, die wir hier
bewerten. Hier haben wir
geratet, wie sinnvoll ist der Job
quasi oder wie wichtig ist der Job für die
Menschheit, für die Allgemeinheit,
was man da macht, also sprich,
sorgt man dafür, dass Leute nicht verbluten
oder sorgt man dafür, dass
Leute besser Versicherungen verkaufen können?
Da würde ich sagen, ich sorge dafür, dass Leute
besser Versicherungen verkaufen können, das ist
jetzt sicherlich nicht wahnsinnig wichtig
für die Allgemeinheit, das ist mir aber
persönlich auch nicht wichtig, dass ich was
wichtiges für die Allgemeinheit mache.
Ein Satz, den auch Leonie unterschreiben würde.
In ihrem alten Job war sie nämlich nicht glücklich.
Den Generationen-Konflikt habe ich dort
sehr stark gemerkt.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum die immer das gleiche
einblenden, die haben glaube ich nur diesen
einen Einblender, den haben die wahrscheinlich
von irgendeinem Fiverr-Inner erstellen lassen
und der hat halt nur einen erstellt und deswegen
sind es jetzt alles, alle Leute, die hier
auftreten in dem Video, sind einfach Leonie24
Social Media Managerin.
In der Hoffnung, das merkt eh keiner.
Ja, auf jeden Fall diese Kontrolle.
Homeoffice war gar keine Möglichkeit.
Dass man auch irgendwie immer mehr arbeitet,
als man eigentlich angestellt ist.
Und wenn du früher gegangen bist, war das ein absolutes No-Go.
Und dann hast du dir irgendwie
drei Wochen später das noch anhören dürfen
in der Küche.
Damals bist du aber sehr früh gegangen.
Das sind so Dinge, die
echt nicht mehr zeitgemäß sind, meiner Meinung nach.
Deswegen ist das Beste, was Leonie
hätte machen können zu dem Zeitpunkt,
zu sagen, alter fuckt mich dieser
Laden ab, ich suche mir jetzt was
Neues. Und wenn sie was Neues hat,
einfach zu sagen, okay
Jungs, ich bin dann mal weg.
Oder was weiß ich, zwei Monate Kündigungsfrist,
14 Tage, drei Monate, weiß ja nicht, was sie hat.
Und tschüss.
Ohne einen neuen Job zu haben,
entscheidet sie sich damals als Letzte
einen Ausweg zu kündigen.
Bis ich dann wirklich irgendwann gesagt habe,
okay, das geht nicht mehr.
Also ich muss jetzt echt hier raus.
Es ist mir völlig egal, ob ich jetzt einen neuen Job habe,
ob ich irgendwas in der Hand habe.
Ich muss da echt raus.
Heute ist es anders.
Seit nun knapp drei Jahren arbeitet Leonie hier
bei Digitalwerk.
Ihre Arbeitszeiten sind flexibel.
Und vor kurzem hat sie sich bewusst dazu entschieden,
auf Teilzeit zu reduzieren.
Ich arbeite aktuell 32 Stunden.
Ich habe freitags frei immer einen Tag.
Ich muss sagen, mir geht es
sehr, sehr viel besser.
Freitag?
Ich finde, Montag ist die bessere Variante.
Aber muss jeder
selbst wissen. Ich kann euch auch sagen, warum
das Montag die bessere Variante ist.
Und zwar, Montags sind
alle noch super krass motiviert.
Das hat den Vorteil, wenn man selbst
was machen möchte, für sich,
beziehungsweise für
wenn man irgendwas braucht,
ist Montag ein guter Tag,
das umzusetzen.
Montag auf der Arbeit
ist immer stressig,
weil die Leute sind super motiviert.
Es sind vielleicht am Wochenende irgendwelche Sachen,
kleinere Sachen kaputt gegangen,
die man sich angucken muss. Also Montags ist eigentlich
richtig was los.
Und freitags
ist eigentlich immer übelst
gechillt.
Deswegen bin ich montags
nicht auf der Arbeit.
Erstens spart man sich den Montagsstress auf der Arbeit
und zweitens, wenn man selbst was erledigen will,
ist man meistens montags selbst noch ein bisschen motivierter
und alle, mit denen man was
machen will, sind auch noch motivierter.
Das heißt, montags ist ein super Tag, wenn man selbst
Sachen schaffen will für sich
oder erledigen muss für sich
und das ist die beste Kombination.
Freitag eh übelst gechillter Tag
und montags super stressig.
Das heißt, montags einfach
nicht arbeiten. Beste Entscheidung.
Das fühlt sich echt super an.
Job kündigen, wenn dieser unglücklich macht.
Teilzeit arbeiten.
Eine Einstellung, die bei der älteren Generation
Fragen aufwirft.
Bei allem Verständnis, aber von was
wirst du deine Miete zahlen?
Von meinem Gehalt?
Die GNZ muss auch Miete bezahlen?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Vielleicht noch dieses idealistische,
dieses ein bisschen romantisierte,
dieses noch unrealistisch Denkende,
weil ich frage mich dann wirklich...
Okay, sie meint,
so nach dem Motto,
wenn die noch daheim wohnen,
dann müssen sie noch...
Ja, okay, mag sein,
dann werden sie das aber feststellen,
wenn sie ausziehen. Alternativ ist
einfach nicht für ein Apfel und ein Ei arbeiten
gehen, sondern sich einen gescheiten Job
suchen, was ja
in der gescheiten Branche und in der heutigen
Zeit dank Fachkräftemangel
ganz gut funktioniert.
Und zum Thema Fachkräftemangel,
ich denke nicht,
dass es einen Fachkräftemangel
in der...
Ja, also der Definition nach
vom Arbeitsamt gibt es einen Fachkräftemangel.
Nach meiner
Definition nach gibt es
zwar auch einen,
aber keinen allzu großen, so wie es dargestellt
wird. Die Definition vom
Arbeitsamt, was Fachkräftemangel ist,
bedeutet ja, diese Stelle ist
so und so lang offen und unbesetzt
und das wird gezählt und das ist dann
so und so viele Leute fehlen uns, also Fachkräftemangel.
Also sprich, solange Stellen offen bleiben,
Fachkräftemangel. Was da nicht
reingeht ist,
die Stelle ist total unattraktiv,
die will ja keiner machen,
deswegen bewirbt sich da keiner drauf. Also
für das Arbeitsamt ist das Fachkräftemangel, sobald
die Stelle unbesetzt bleibt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Ja, das
nicht alle, die, sagen wir mal, wenn man mal
in der IT, wenn man mal von
irgendwelchen IT-Jobs ausgeht, das nicht
jeder Arbeitgeber in der IT
sofort
exakt den Kandidaten findet,
den er haben will,
da würde ich mitgehen und sagen, wenn das schon Fachkräftemangel
ist, dann haben wir Fachkräftemangel.
Aber die
meisten Unternehmen, wenn sie sich
etwas Mühe geben würden,
denke ich, dass sie Leute finden würden.
So, das heißt aber auch,
Dumsverb, danke schön für den Sub und danke
auch an, ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas
übersehen. Ne, habe ich nicht.
Okay, alles klar. Ja, also ich denke,
übrigens, wenn ihr Prime-Subs übrig habt, ich freue
mich immer drüber, aber ihr müsst die nicht mir geben,
gebt die nur irgendjemand auf Twitch, weil
sonst ist ja quasi
direkte Überweisung an Besos und weiß nicht, ob
ihr das wollt. Muss nicht ich sein.
So, aber was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, also wenn das schon
Fachkräftemangel ist, dann
okay, aber ich denke, die meisten
würden jemanden bekommen.
Wenn sie an einem der drei
Stellschrauben drehen, die es denn da gibt,
Leute zu bekommen. Die erste ist,
man muss sein eigenes Unternehmen
attraktiver machen. Da gibt's
zig Varianten.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit, wo ich jetzt arbeite,
die haben sogar einen Kindergarten.
Kinderbetreuung. Das ist natürlich
für Eltern oder angehende Eltern
ein riesen Ding.
Das kann sich selbstverständlich
nicht jeder leisten.
Classic420, danke schön für den Sub.
Nur mal so als Beispiel.
Also man muss den eigenen
Laden attraktiver machen.
Und das kann oftmals, also in
nach außen hin für Bewerbungen
attraktiver machen. Das kann durchaus sein,
dass der eigene Laden oder das
Unternehmen, was Leute sucht, sogar schon
attraktiv ist, aber das einfach nur nicht richtig
kommuniziert. Zum Beispiel
freie Betriebssystemauswahl,
Kantine im Haus,
Firmenhandys,
die man privat benutzen darf, was auch immer.
Es gibt da schon durchaus Pluspunkte, die man
einfach mal erwähnen kann, wenn's die gibt
und die auch sicherlich bei dem
einen oder anderen gut ankommen. Also man muss irgendwie
gucken, dass man sein eigenes Unternehmen attraktiv
dastehen lässt. Da scheitern ja schon ganz
viele Betriebe dran,
die Bewerber suchen.
Leute, wir haben uns oft genug Stellenanzeigen
angeguckt. Die meisten Stellenanzeigen sind
so extrem
langweilig, 0815.
Wir sind
Technologie, in der
Technologie führend, bla bla bla,
Marktführer im Bereich XY.
Wir suchen neue,
motivierte Mitarbeiter
für unser Administrationsteam,
für unser Entwicklerteam,
und bla bla bla.
Es ist so langweilig.
Es ist immer der gleiche Kram.
Lässiger Lord, danke schön für den lässigen Satz.
Es ist so
langweilig und
sticht überhaupt nicht raus
und gibt auch überhaupt keinen
Anlass, warum sich da jemand
jetzt dazu
ja irgendwie hingezogen
fühlen sollte, sich da zu bewerben.
Also da sind die Unternehmen teilweise
schon echt selbst dran schuld, dass sie da so
0815 Bewerbung machen.
Ich bin überzeugt von, dass viele Unternehmen es deutlich
besser machen könnten, wenn sie ordentliche
Stellenanzeigen
schreiben würden und sich da mal wirklich
Gedanken drüber machen würden
und auch mal in sich gehen, was ist denn bei uns wirklich
gut. Also sie könnten wirklich
viel bessere Stellenanzeigen schreiben,
machen sie aber nicht. Das ist schon mal das
erste, also die Einstiegshürde
überhaupt gefunden zu werden.
Das nächste, was sie machen können ist,
sie können ihre
Ansprüche runterschrauben.
Das können selbstverständlich Unternehmen auch machen,
wenn sie sagen, ey, wir finden niemanden, der 15 Jahre
Kubernetes-Erfahrung hat.
Ja, es reicht vielleicht auch, wenn wir jemanden haben,
der nur zwei Jahre Erfahrung hat, aber
wo wir den Eindruck haben,
der interessiert sich sehr dafür und
den arbeiten wir dann ein.
Das war jetzt ein Witz mit 15 Jahre Kubernetes,
aber da gibt es den Kram ja noch gar nicht.
Die können die Ansprüche runterschrauben.
Was auch
sicherlich sinnig ist in vielen
Bereichen, weil
gerade in der IT
ist es nun mal so,
der Skill sich einarbeiten zu können
beziehungsweise zu googeln
ist eigentlich das wichtigste schlechthin.
Und wenn du einen hast,
der motiviert ist und das kann,
der kann sich relativ schnell,
gerade mit Unterstützung von Leuten,
die Ahnung in dem Thema haben,
relativ schnell einarbeiten.
Guck mal, du kannst mich heute auch vor
irgendeine Kiste setzen,
von der ich keine Ahnung habe,
nach ein paar Tagen,
je nachdem wie kompliziert das ist,
nach ein paar Wochen,
ich krieg das hin,
das ist eigentlich meistens kein Ding,
solange ich will.
Es gibt Sachen, die will ich nicht,
zum Beispiel Windows administrieren,
mache ich auch nicht.
Und der dritte Punkt,
was Unternehmen machen können,
wenn sie keine Leute bekommen ist,
sie können einfach bessere Gehälter bieten
und dementsprechend offensiv auch das reinschreiben.
Nicht nur diese Sache mit
leistungsorientiertes Gehalt,
ein marktübliches Gehalt,
diese Formulierung will doch keine Sau lesen.
Wenn da drinnen steht,
das ist eine
keine Ahnung,
Einsteiger, Junior Entwicklerstelle,
wir bezahlen dir aber 65.000 im Jahr,
dann sagen die,
ja, das guck ich mir doch mal an.
Ist mir eigentlich egal,
dass die Stellenanzeige sich ziemlich 0815 liest,
aber die bezahlen mir zum Einstieg 65k,
das bezahlt sonst keiner
und dann auf geht's, let's go.
Das kann man natürlich auch machen,
die Variante gibt's.
Und nur weil Unternehmen da komplett drinnen failen,
heißt das nicht zwangsläufig,
dass sie nicht Leute bekommen könnten,
würden sie sich ein bisschen Mühe geben.
Klar, insgesamt gibt's nicht genug Leute,
das würde ich auch so unterschreiben.
Außerdem gibt es heute mittlerweile
viel mehr Rekrutierungsmöglichkeiten.
Ich hab vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
ein Video geguckt,
da hat ein so Recruiting-Spezialist,
was von den meisten dieser Leute
nicht so gut ist,
heute halte ich nix,
aber der hat wirklich was Sinnvolles gesagt.
Und zwar hat er gesagt,
hey, es ist heute so,
dass viele Leute in ihrem aktuellen Job
eigentlich nur noch Dienst nach Vorschrift machen
und noch in dem Job sind,
weil sich's noch nicht genug abfuckt,
aber wirklich groß verbunden mit dem Job
und dem Arbeitgeber fühlen die sich nicht mehr
und die haben eigentlich gar keinen großen Bock da drauf,
die machen's weiter, weil sie zu faul sind
und sich was Neues zu suchen,
dass der Leidensdruck noch nicht hoch genug ist,
das ist ein Angebot,
dann sind die sehr wohl bereit sich das anzuhören
und auch relativ zügig zu wechseln.
Und das kann ich gerade rückblickend,
wenn ich mir die Leute angucke,
also mich selbst und bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber auch
und mir jetzt noch die Leute angucken,
viele sind genau auf diesem Standpunkt.
Die sind da, weil es ist okay,
es nervt nicht,
es ist jetzt nicht super,
es ist aber auch nicht super schlimm,
es ist auch ein gewisser Aufwand
sich mal aufzuraffen, Bewerbungen zu schreiben,
die sind auch da, sind innerlich nicht so wirklich
da verbunden mit dem Arbeitgeber,
würden wechseln, aber haben keinen Bock
sich selbst drum zu kümmern.
Wenn man denen mit einem guten Job
am Angebot kommt,
dann sagen die relativ schnell
let's go,
wenn die Sachen stimmen und der neue Arbeitgeber
das bietet, was den Leuten wichtig ist.
So, aber ich muss das Video fertig gucken,
ich krieg langsam übelst Hunger.
Wie die das später machen wollen.
Die Gen Z wird ihre
Miete genauso bezahlen,
wie Gen Y und Gen X.
Mit dem, was sie so verdienen.
Vielleicht sagt allerdings Gen Z,
mir reicht auch eine kleinere Wohnung aus,
oder ich kann
dank Homeoffice
beispielsweise
von woanders arbeiten,
wo das Wohnen nicht so teuer ist.
Das Argument von ihr verstehe
ich jetzt nicht.
Wie die das später machen wollen.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage,
wie kann sich die Gen Z leisten,
auch einfach nicht 40 Stunden zu arbeiten.
Einfach die Ansprüche runterschrauben.
Du musst nicht
fünfmal im Jahr im Urlaub fahren,
du brauchst kein Riesenhaus oder sonst was.
Vielleicht, wenn du später selbst denkst,
du willst das haben, dann musst du halt wieder mehr schaffen.
Aber wenn du nicht für jeden Scheiß Geld ausgibst,
geht das schon.
Was natürlich nicht geht ist,
neues Auto, Autotunen,
laufend neues Smartphone, fette Wohnung
oder sonst was, ja klar,
dann ist die Kohle weg.
Dann kannst du das nicht machen.
Aber wenn du einen ordentlichen Job arbeitest,
wo es viel Geld gibt,
ja das ist natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit.
Das ist so ein Punkt, der wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen schwieriger ist.
Die Mietpreise gehen wahnsinnig in die Höhe.
Es wird nicht günstiger, es wird nur immer teurer.
Einfach ein Haus erben, easy.
Alleine wohnen.
Und da, ja, da clasht dieser Wunsch
mit diesen äußeren Umständen wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen zusammen, weil es halt
teilweise dann doch unleistbar ist.
Obwohl es noch schwierig scheint
ist, einen Weg für sich gefunden.
BG oder sowas bestimmt.
Ich nehme das in Kauf.
Also ja, es ist weniger Geld.
Ich kann dann vielleicht im Monat
zweimal weniger essen gehen
oder dreimal weniger ausgehen,
aber mir ist das einfach mehr wert,
die Zeit, die ich dafür habe.
Klingt doch
voll und ganz nachvollziehbar.
Und wenn die Kohle reicht,
und gerade, ich weiß ja nicht,
wie gut es bei den Influencer-Marketingleuten da läuft,
ja, gerade in dem Bereich,
wenn du gut bist und einen
gescheiten Arbeitgeber hast,
oder manche sind ja sogar selbstständig,
kannst du wirklich enorm viel Geld machen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich es erzählen darf.
Ne, ich erzähle es nicht.
Vielleicht kann ich mit ihm mal ein Video machen
irgendwann und er erzählt es selber.
Ich kenne ja
schon seit Jahren ein paar,
die Online-Marketing und sowas machen
und mit manchen hat man auch ein bisschen mehr Kontakt,
mit manchen ein bisschen weniger.
Ja, also meine Meinung bleibt
weiterhin bestehen. Ne, kann ich nicht erzählen.
Irgendwelche internen Sachen,
das will ich nicht erzählen.
Also ich kann euch sagen, wie gesagt,
aus meiner Sicht ist Online-Marketing
die einzige Kloake an Jobs,
gerade Influencer-Kram.
Aber ich habe es letztens schon gesagt,
weil, was mich auch sehr gewundert hat,
weil ich es selbst nicht vermutet hätte,
und zwar,
von allen Marketing-Agenturen
und Social-Media-Management-Gedöns
und so,
was ich in letzter Zeit gehört habe,
wo es wirklich ganz gut sein muss,
ist tatsächlich TikTok.
Mag es fast nicht glauben,
aber die China-Chinesen
haben wohl echt gute,
eine echt gute Arbeitsatmosphäre
im Online-Marketing.
Zumindest in der
EU,
tja, wie auch immer man das nennt,
EU-Niederlassung.
Ausgerechnet TikTok von denen,
wo man es am wenigsten erwarten würde.
Faul sein habe das aber nichts zu tun.
Man will es nur eben nicht so machen,
wie man es in anderen Situationen davor.
Wir haben andere Prioritäten,
einfach das Leben zu genießen,
also eben sowas wie Reisen,
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung,
Reisen,
das für nicht 40, 50 Jahre lang
an etwas arbeiten,
was uns nicht Spaß macht.
Ich glaube schon,
dass es so bei uns ist,
dass wir gesehen haben,
dass auch mit weniger Geld
wir eher glücklich sein wollen,
als die Arbeit zu verrotten,
oder sich eben zum Burnout zu stressen.
Leonie ist davon überzeugt,
Ich verstehe gar nicht,
wie man das irgendwie groß kritisieren kann.
Man kann es alles kritisieren,
aber das klingt doch
komplett logisch und nachvollziehbar.
Ja, wenn man mit ein bisschen,
im Prinzip das, was ich gesagt habe,
wenn man mit ein bisschen weniger auskommt,
macht es einen unterm Strich
glücklicher,
auch mit weniger Arbeit.
Es ist doch gut,
es muss doch nicht immer nur,
das neue Smartphone sein,
was einen happy macht.
Oder neuer Fernseher,
neues Auto,
was ich glaube,
dass ich tatsächlich
so die Generation davor
und auch danach,
also meine Generation
und auch die vor mir,
schon so ein bisschen auch ihr Glück
darüber definiert hat,
wie krass sie sich was leisten können.
Für die war Glück neuer Fernseher,
die sie auch gewünscht haben
und ob das wirklich das ist,
was sie jetzt ultimativ glücklich gemacht hat,
sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich glaube, da sind die tatsächlich
einfach schon ein bisschen
moderner im Kopf einfach.
Die sind ja auch noch jünger
und ich kann mich mehr
mit dieser Sicht der Dinge identifizieren
als mit der anderen.
Deswegen arbeite ich auch nur Teilzeit.
Ich gebe kaum Geld aus
und arbeite Teilzeit.
Was mache ich mit meinem Geld?
Ich kaufe mir ein bisschen Stonks,
damit das nicht weniger wird.
Rufe nach neuen Arbeitsmodellen
werden immer lauter.
Island führt das weltweit größte Experiment
zur Vier-Tage-Woche durch.
Wer, wer, wer?
Ja, Island ist Epoch.
Teilnehmende haben
über mehrere Jahre
ihre Wochenarbeitszeit
von 40 auf 35 Stunden
bei gleichem Gehalt reduziert.
Sie zeigen, die Zufriedenheit,
aber auch die Produktivität verbesserten sich.
Vier-Tage-Woche, Arbeitszeitreduktion
Und Isländer sind doch, glaube ich,
eh schon die glücklichsten Menschen, oder?
Oder denen? Nee, denen sind, glaube ich,
die glücklichsten Menschen.
Denen.
... bei gleichem Gehalt flexibles
und individuelles Arbeiten.
Auch in Österreich stellen immer mehr Unternehmen...
Nee, Schweden nicht.
... wenn ihr keine Reportage mehr
von uns verpassen wollt...
Ähm, ich wollte irgendwas noch...
... vergessen.
Ja, Unternehmen umfixieren sich.
Resultate zeigen,
die Zufriedenheit, aber auch die Produktivität...
Ja, ach ja, genau, jetzt weiß ich noch eine Sache,
die ich zum Schluss noch sagen wollte.
Also sollten die bei uns wirklich mal auf die Idee kommen,
zu sagen, 35
oder gar 30 Stunden
Woche für gleiches Gehalt,
ich bin sofort
dabei. Also,
schade, dass es bei uns keine
Volksabstimmungen gibt wie in der Schweiz
zu sowas. Ich wäre
sofort dabei, weil...
Wisst ihr, was das für mich bedeuten würde?
Das würde bedeuten
instant 20% mehr Geld.
Weil ich mache ja schon 4 Tage
Woche. Also insofern
wäre ich sofort dabei.
Sobald, sobald
sowas kommt, also
ohne Mist, sollte irgendeine Partei
damit in den Wahlkampf gehen,
35 Stunden Woche, die wird gewählt.
Instant.
Das würde für mich nämlich einfach nur direkt Gehaltserhöhung
bedeuten.
Und selbst wenn es die AfD ist,
wenn irgendjemand verspricht,
also es muss nachvollziehbar versprochen
werden, oder auch wenn es die Linken
sind, wenn versprochen wird, wenn wir
was zu sagen haben, dann gibt es
garantiert, und das müsste in irgendeiner
Form natürlich auch glaubhaft sein,
gibt es 30
Stunden, instant, ist mir alles andere
egal.
Instant 30 Stunden. Ich meine, hey, wer würde
Nein sagen zu 20% mehr Gehalt
fürs gleiche, was er macht?
Das Dumme ist nur,
im Endeffekt, dass die alle nur schwätzen
und gerade die AfD ist, und die Linken
aber auch, aber gerade die AfD ist wunderbar
im Labern, so nach dem Motto
oh ja, hier mit uns wird das alles besser. Die müssen ja
aktuell eigentlich hauptsächlich existieren
und
die anderen quasi Werbung für sich machen
lassen, also Negativwerbung für sich machen
lassen.
Das heißt, das ist dann auch nicht, sondern nicht glaubwürdig.
Aber wenn es glaubwürdig wäre,
wenn es glaub-, wenn es irgendeine Partei
für mich glaubwürdig,
ja, glaubwürdig vertreten würde,
was die aus 40 Stunden Woche, 30 Stunden
Woche machen würden, wenn sie gewählt wären,
dann wähle ich die. Ist mir egal, wer das ist.
20%
mehr Kohle, easy. Ist mir egal.
Juckt mich nicht. Und wenn, und selbst
wenn es so scheiße werden sollte,
in dieser Regierungsperiode,
dann mache ich Homeoffice vom Ausland
aus.
Ist mir egal. 20, zu 20%
mehr Geld, sage ich
nicht nein. Dann mache ich
Workation, genau. Gut, realistisch
betrachtet ist das natürlich Blödsinn.
Weil, wenn es uns hier so scheiße
geht, dass man nur noch mit Homeoffice arbeiten kann,
dann geht es auch anderweitig den Bach runter.
Ja, wenn man es mal, wenn man es mal
im Kern durchdenkt, ergibt das natürlich keinen Sinn,
das so zu machen.
Und es wird ja eh keiner wirklich glaubhaft
das, äh, verklickern,
äh, also, so bewerben
können, dass sie es auch machen, wenn sie das durchhalten.
Aber,
20% instant mehr wäre schon geil.
Nach Dubai.
Ja. Zu, zu, zu
Dings. Den ganzen Influencer.
Boah, ey,
da würde ich im Leben nicht hingehen, Alter.
Ist auch so ein Kackland, auf das ich keinen Bock hätte.
Ich muss ja sagen, es wird hier immer viel rumgehackt,
ne. Aber ich lebe
hier eigentlich ganz gerne.
Trotz, dass alles ja so angeblich
furchtbar schlimm ist.
Zumindest, wenn man sich das auf Social Media anguckt.
Gefühlt so schlimm wie noch nie.
Aber ich, ich
finde es hier eigentlich ganz gut.
Und, wenn man es mal realistisch
betrachtet, hat sich
auch die letzten Jahrzehnte
sehr viel verbessert.
Es ist sicherlich nicht alles gut,
aber es hat sich sehr viel verbessert.
Also diese, diese Weltuntergangsszenarien
und, äh, ja,
dass man so tut, irgendwie als, als hättest du
heute immer noch so viele Probleme.
Du kannst dich heute persönlich so frei entfalten,
wie noch, wie noch nie vorher.
Und da bin ich eigentlich ganz dankbar drum,
dass wir hier, hier,
dass es hier so ist.
Wenn man mal in andere Länder guckt,
da hast du mehr Probleme.
Wenn man mal nach Russland geht und sagt,
ich bin schwul, dann hast du andere Sorgen.
Hier würde das keinen interessieren.
Leute, wenn ich mich hier in den Stream stelle und sage,
Jungs, wisst ihr eigentlich, ich bin schwul,
dann würdet ihr sagen, ja, pff, und weiter, Max, mir juckt's.
Ja, du hast den ein oder anderen verwirrten
Leute, die dann irgendwie ein bisschen rumhaten
müssen oder so. Aber im Großen
und Ganzen
geht's den Leuten mega am Arsch vorbei.
Und das finde ich okay.
Das muss dich auch überhaupt nicht interessieren.
Das ist auch sowas, was mich Social Media
technisch immer nervt. So nach dem Motto, bist du nicht
dafür, bist du dagegen.
Leute, den meisten Leuten geht's am Arsch
vorbei, ob ich schwul wäre oder nicht.
Und das ist okay.
Ist in Ordnung.
Die sollen mich in Ruhe lassen
und ich lass sie auch in Ruhe.
Insofern finde ich das
so, wie es jetzt aktuell ist, schon
enorme Fortschritte versus
die letzten 50 Jahre reicht schon,
die du dir angucken musst.
Klar, es ist sicherlich nicht alles toll.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du dich
in Dresden an der falschen
Stelle als Schwarzer vor ein Einkaufszentrum
stellst, hast du wahrscheinlich so ein paar Probleme.
Je nachdem, in welcher Region,
in welcher Gegend
das so ist.
Es ist nicht alles gut und es gibt sicherlich noch
viele Sachen, die man verbessern kann.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, wenn man sich mal die Fortschritte anguckt,
die wir die letzten 50 Jahre gemacht haben,
es macht keinen Sinn,
so krass rumzuheulen, wie es auf Social Media
passiert. Es ist vieles,
gerade persönliche Entfaltung,
was sich enorm verbessert hat.
Und ich finde es hier eigentlich ganz gut.
Also ich habe keine Ambitionen
auszuwandern. Es gibt ja Leute,
ich habe beispielsweise jetzt, wie gesagt,
ich denke, sollen sie machen, wenn sie wollen.
Ich habe beispielsweise MMO, eine Weile MMO
gespielt, jetzt in letzter Zeit wieder
und bei einem aus unserer Gruppe,
der ist, wir haben da alle möglichen,
jüngere bis ältere Leute in der Gilde.
Wir haben zum Beispiel einen,
der ist
so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen,
so ein bisschen
gegen viele der aktuellen
Entwicklungen.
Der hat die ganze Zeit erzählt,
ich will jetzt auswandern, ich kann nicht mehr
atmen hier und sowas, die Freiheit
geht zugrunde und so. Hast du halt
auch so Leute, ja.
Ich bin da irgendwie so, ist schon ein bisschen
übertrieben alles.
Ich finde es hier insgesamt eigentlich
ganz gut.
Ja genau, genau.
5 Minuten Delay war das oder 10 Minuten Delay.
Ich kann aktuell
kein MMO empfehlen, ich spiele gerade aktuell
kein MMO.
Ich finde ehrlich gesagt,
dass beide Seiten
sehr übertreiben.
Ja so nach dem Motto, oh hier ist alles ganz
furchtbar schlimm und Unterdrückung und
Rassismus und an jeder Ecke ist hier
ganz furchtbar wild und man muss sich
permanent drüber auskotzen, überall auf Twitter.
Und dann hast du die andere Seite
so nach dem Motto, oh Impfzwang
und hier und ganz furchtbar schlimm und
hier kann man nicht mehr atmen und so.
Ich finde das übertreiben beide Seiten einfach nur maßlos.
Insgesamt finde ich das, finde ich
die Mischung hier bei uns eigentlich echt,
ganz okay.
Es ist nicht nur die Medien, das sicherlich auch.
Es ist vor allem die Leute, die sich so krass
reinsteigern überall.
Ich glaube am besten kann man das damit zusammenfassen,
diese Mentalität,
die es immer verbreitet
und gerade auf Social Media gibt,
jeder der nicht ganz klar für was
ist, ist automatisch
dagegen und muss zerstört werden, so nach dem Motto.
Das ist leider
viel zu reingesteigert
auch mittlerweile.
Reinsteigern trifft es denke ich dann wirklich
wirklich ganz gut.
Man sieht es doch allein schon daran,
man sieht es doch allein schon daran,
dass die Cronk
alter, Cronk, das ist glaube ich
so eines der, ich meine ich habe persönlich mit ihm
was nie zu tun, ich bin auch kein großer
Cronk-Gucker, aber ich glaube
das ist eigentlich so eines der
der basedesten,
gibt es dieses Wort,
am gebasedesten
Streamer und
Let's Player und YouTuber, den es so gibt.
Dass die bei dem so riesen
Attacke gemacht haben da vor ein paar Monaten,
allein schon das, sieht man doch, dass die alle nicht mehr
ganz dicht sind. Natürlich,
das passiert ja immer,
das passiert doch immer. Du hast,
das ist auch das, woraus ich
in dem einen Livestream,
wo ich einen Clip vorhin gesehen habe, so drüber aufgeregt
hat. Macht er was?
Wird er angeschissen dafür, dass er es
macht? Macht er es nicht,
wird er von den anderen Leuten angeschissen,
dass er eingebrochen ist und nachgegeben hat.
Der arme Cronk, Alter,
an der Stelle.
Du kannst jetzt natürlich auch sagen, who cares, Cronk,
der hat eh schon ausgesorgt, aber man hat gemerkt,
den nervt das richtig.
Unterm Strich
hat er, unterm Strich hat er
sogar noch mehr Zuschauer. Diese ganze
Diskussion um das Wizard Game
zum Beispiel, hat ja im Endeffekt schlussendlich
nur dafür gesorgt, dass sich am Ende
der Scheiß sogar noch mehr verkauft hat.
Also es hat nichts gebracht, so
dieses ganze ultra reingesteigere.
Und was halt prinzipiell nie was bringt
ist, pauschal allen Leuten
zu sagen, sie sind scheiße.
Unabhängig davon, ob es
stimmt oder nicht. Niemand hört
gerne, dass er scheiße ist.
Oftmals noch nicht mal wissend, um was
es eigentlich geht.
So nach dem Motto, ey du bist scheiße,
um was geht es, ist egal, du bist scheiße.
Das hört halt keiner gerne und der lässt
sich dann von sowas auch nicht überzeugen.
Das muss da anders angehen. Und Leute
überzeugen ist eh unglaublich schwierig.
Weil viele sind nicht für Fakten empfänglich,
für
andere Meinungen auch nicht.
Viele Leute sind auch einfach nicht überzeugbar.
Damit muss man auch leben.
Und ihr wisst, wie sehr mich der Umgang
mit anderen Menschen abfuckt.
Ich bin, ich bin
anti-mensch.
Ist es
rassistisch, wenn man alle nicht mag?
Nicht, oder?
Ich mag alle Menschen nicht.
Was ich mag, sind Katzen zum Beispiel.
Oder ich würde
beispielsweise,
seriously, ich kann mit
meinem Geld machen, was ich will. Aber
ich würde lieber
an mein Tierheim
spenden, hier lokal,
wo ich weiß, was abgeht
und dass die es wirklich nicht einfach
haben und dass sie gerade jetzt nach
Corona-Zeiten auch viele Probleme haben mit
eingelieferten Tieren und sich kaum noch retten können
vor
Kosten und
Unterbringung und allem. Ich würde lieber
an mein, was heißt ich würde, ich habe
ja auch schon, nicht nur an
mein Tierheim hier gespendet, sondern auch schon
an andere Tierorganisationen gespendet.
Lieber
dafür spenden, als sagen wir ans
Rote Kreuz oder sowas.
Ich spende lieber für Tiere,
die nichts dafür können, als
an irgendwelche Menschenhilfsorganisationen.
Apo2G,
bestes Thema zum Subscriben, ja ich weiß.
Gerade Finanzamt schaut zu.
Finanzamt kann zuschauen, weil ich mache
meine Steuern mit dem Steuerberater immer
ultra korrekt und habe auch für sowas Belege.
Gut, man kann davon abgesehen sein, man kann es auch ohne
Belege machen, aber dann kriegt man halt kein Geld
wieder. Naja.
Rundumschlag zu
Social, Social Media und Zeug.
Chainlaw, nicht alles verraten.
In Wirklichkeit,
erinnert ihr euch noch an das Containerschiff?
Das so ein bisschen schief stand?
Hat wahrscheinlich schon wieder jeder
vergessen. Leute, ich habe Hunger as fuck.
Ich glaube, ich muss jetzt was essen.
Ne, nicht Concordia.
Concordia war das Ding in Italien.
Ich weiß
nicht mal, wie das Ding hieß.
Das Schiff war in diesem Kanal
festgestellt. Evergreen hieß das?
Evergiven?
Nee, Concordia war das Ding, was
vor der italienischen
Küste auf Grund gelaufen ist.
Mit dem Captain, der sich
aus dem Staub gemacht hat.
Das war ja auch ein geiler Dude.
So nach dem Motto, oh Mist, ich bin Captain.
Oh fuck, mein Schiff
geht unter. Das erste, was ich mache
ist, ich bring mich mal in Sicherheit.
Dann ruft ihn
irgendwie die Seerettung oder sowas noch
an und dann erzählt
er denen irgendeinen Shit zu.
Das Video war richtig gut.
Fall auf.
Wie hieß das?
Cost of Concordia hieß das. Ja, genau.
Das war ein mega geiles Video.
Richtig, richtig gut gemacht.
Zu einer eigentlich ziemlich tragischen Sache
muss man ja sagen.
Das war wirklich ein richtig gut gemachtes Video.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich glaube, nachher
eventuell machen wir noch
folgendes. Nachher
machen wir, glaube ich,
I use PHP, by the way.
Irgendwie ist es mir heute
danach, ein bisschen PHP zu machen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von PHP.
Also
schon ewig her, wo ich zuletzt PHP
benutzt habe.
Und wir werden Keck W as a Service
in PHP neu entwickeln.
Also wer sich fragt, was Keck W as a Service ist.
Das ist nicht das.
Was ist denn meins?
Gibt es das gar nicht mehr?
GitHub down, PostChamp.
Ne, Browser kaputt, PostChamp.
Also Repo.
Keck W.
Keck W as a Service, genau.
Das werden wir neu bauen
in PHP.
Das ist was ultra simples.
Das ist eine Web-Anwendung.
Wenn man sie aufruft, erscheint ein Keck W-Bild
und rotiert sich
random im Kreis.
Das ist alles. Wer macht das nicht?
Aber das ist mega
simpler kann
das echt nicht sein.
Das ist die gesamte Logik.
Aber wir probieren das mal in PHP
zu machen, was glaube ich ganz gut ist
zum Einstieg in PHP, weil ich keine Ahnung
habe von PHP. Alles klar.
So.
Wem follow-inge
ich denn?
Besten deutschsprachiger
Streamer, der es nötig hat, mal
gehostet zu werden. Der Lost hat es nicht nötig.
Der hat 1,1k Zuschauer.
Weiß grad nicht.
Ich hab Hunger, Leute. Ich geh jetzt essen.
Ist das der von Semper Video?
Der ist gar nicht on.
Haben wir glaube ich das letzte Mal gehostet.
Vielleicht...
Ne, egal. Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss jetzt was essen.
Bis denn. See you.